Welcome to our Advanced artificial
intelligence full course video so what
exactly is artificial intelligence well
it's the ability of a machine or
computer program to perform task that
usually requires human intelligence such
as problem solving learning and decision
making with the help of AI computers can
process vast amounts of data understand
natural language and even drive cars and
play chess but that's not all AI is
capable of do you know that AI can
create art make music and even write
stories and it's not just robots and
computers that can benefit from AI with
the help of AI we are able to better
understand the world around us and
create more efficient and effective
systems in areas such as Healthcare
finance and transportation whether you
are a tech Enthusiast or just curious
about the world around you there's no
denying that AI is a game changer so why
not join the fun and start learning more
about this amazing technology who knows
maybe one day you will be the part of
the next big AI breakthrough this
there's no better time to train yourself
in the exciting field of machine
learning if you're looking for a course
that covers everything from the
fundamentals to Advanced Techniques like
machine learning algorithm development
and unsupervised learning look no
further than our CCH postgraduate
program in Ai and machine learning in
partnership with IBM this a& ml course
covers the latest tools and Technologies
from the AI ecosystem and features
master classes by ctech faculty and IBM
experts hackathon and ask me anything
sessions this program showcases Celtic
ctm is excellence and IBM's industry
progress the artificial intelligence
course covers key Concepts like
statistics data science with python
machine learning deep learning NLP and
reinforcement learning through an
Interactive Learning model with live
sessions androll now and unlock exciting
a ml opportunities the course link is
mentioned in the description box below
so let's get started it's a weekend and
John decided to watch the latest movie
recommended by Netflix at his friend's
place before heading out he asked Siri
about the weather and realized it would
rain so he decided to take his Tesla for
the long journey and switch to autopilot
on the highway after coming home from
the eventful day he started wondering
how technology has made his life easy he
did some research on the internet and
found out that Netflix Siri and Tesla
are all using AI so what is ai ai or
artificial intelligence is nothing but
making computers based machines think
and act like humans artificial
intelligence is not a new term John
McCarthy a computer scientist coined the
term artificial intelligence back in
1956 but it took time to evolve as it
demanded heavy computing power
artificial intelligence is not confined
to just movie recommendations and
virtual assistance broadly classifying
there are three types of AI artificial
narrow intelligence also called weak AI
is the stage where machines can perform
a specific task Netflix Siri chatbots
spatial recommendation systems are all
examples of artificial narrow
intelligence next up we have artificial
general intelligence referred to as an
intelligent agent's capacity to
comprehend or pick up any intellectual
skill that a human can we are halfway
into successfully implementing this
space IBM's Watson supercomputer and
gpt3 fall under this category and lastly
artificial super intelligence it is the
stage where machines surpass human
intelligence
you might have seen this in movies and
imagined how the world would be if
machines occupy it fascinated by this
John did more research and found out
that machine learning deep learning and
natural language processing are all
connected with artificial intelligence
machine learning a subset of AI is the
process of automating and enhancing how
computers learn from their experiences
without human health machine learning
can be used in email spam detection
medical diagnosis Etc deep learning can
be considered a subset of machine
learning it is a field that is based on
learning and improving on its own by
examining computer
algorithms while machine learning uses
simpler Concepts deep learning works
with artificial neural networks which
are designed to imitate the human brain
this technology can be applied in face
recognition speech recognition and many
more
applications natural language processing
popularly known as NLP can be defined as
the ability of machines to learn human
language and translated chatbots fall
under this category artificial
intelligence is advancing in every
crucial field like healthcare education
robotics banking e-commerce and the list
goes on like in healthcare AI is used to
identify diseases helping healthcare
service providers and their patients
make better treatment in lifestyle
decisions coming to the education sector
AI is helping teachers automate grading
organizing and facilitating parent
parent Guardian
conversations in robotics AI powered
robots employ real-time updates to
detect obstructions in their path and
instantaneously design their routes
artificial intelligence provides
Advanced data analytics that is
transforming banking by reducing fraud
and enhancing compliance with this
growing demand for AI more and more
Industries are looking for AI Engineers
who can help them develop intelligent
systems and offer them lucrative
salaries going north of10
,000 the future of AI looks promising
with the AI Market expected to reach
$190 billion by 2025 begin first let's
understand what really is artificial
intelligence artificial intelligence is
the science of building intelligent
machines from vast volumes of
data this data can be structured
semi-structured or unstructured in
nature AI systems learn from past
experiences and perform humanlike tasks
artificial intelligence and enhances the
speed precision and effectiveness of
human efforts AI uses sophisticated
algorithms and methods to build machines
that can make decisions on their own
deep learning and machine learning are
the two subsets of artificial
intelligence so you need both machine
learning algorithms and deep learning
networks to build intelligence systems
AI is now being widely used in almost
every sector of business such as
Transportation Healthcare banking retail
entertainment and e-commerce
now let's look at the different types of
artificial
intelligence so AI can be classified
based on capabilities and
functionalities under capabilities there
are three types of artificial
intelligence they are narrow AI General
Ai and super AI under functionalities we
have four types of artificial
intelligence reactive machine limited
memory theory of mind and self-awareness
let's look at them one by
one first we will look at the different
types of artificial intelligence based
on
capabilities so what is narrow AI narrow
AI also known as weak AI focuses on one
narrow task and cannot perform Beyond
its limitations it aims at a single
subset of cognitive abilities and
advances in that Spectrum applications
of narrow AI are becoming increasingly
common in our day-to-day lives as
machine learning and deep learning
methods continue to
evolve Apple Siri is a simple example of
an narrow AI that operates with a
limited predefined range of functions
Siri often has challenges with tasks
outside its range of abilities IBM
Watson supercomputer is another example
of narrow AI which applies cognitive
Computing machine learning and natural
language processing to process
information and answer your
questions IBM Watson once outperformed
human contestant Ken Jenkins to become
the champion on the popular game show
Jeopardy other examples of narrow AI
include Google Translate image
recognition software recommendation
systems spam filtering and Google's page
ranking
algorithm next we have General
artificial intelligence or general AI
General AI also known as strong AI has
the ability to understand and learn any
intellectual task that a human can
General artificial intelligence has
received a one billion dollar investment
from Microsoft through open AI it allows
a machine to apply Knowledge and Skills
in different contexts AI researchers and
scientists have not achieved strong AI
so far to succeed they would need to
find a way to make machines conscious
programming a full set of cognitive
abilities Fujitsu built the K computer
which is one of the fastest computers in
the world it is one of the most notable
attempts at achieving strong AI it took
took 40 minutes to simulate a single
second of neural activity so it is
difficult to determine whether or not
strong AI will be achieved in the near
future tan 2 is a superc computer
created by China's national university
of Defense technology it currently holds
the record for CPS at 33.86 petaflops
although it sounds exciting the human
brain is estimated to be capable of one
exaflop now CPS means characters per
second that the system can
process third in the list of AI that is
based on capabilities we have super AI
super AI exceeds human intelligence and
can perform any task better than a
human the concept of artificial super
intelligence sees AI evolved to be so
akin to human emotions and experiences
that it doesn't just understand them it
evokes emotions needs beliefs and
desires of its own its existence is
still hypothetical some of the key
characters stics of super AI include the
ability to think solve puzzles make
judgments and decisions on its
own now if you have enjoyed watching
this video so far please make sure to
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the Bell icon to stay updated with all
the latest Technologies also if you have
any questions related to this video
please put it in the chat section our
team of experts will help you address
your
questions moving ahead now we will see
the different types of artificial
intelligence based on
functionalities in this category first
we have reactive machine a reactive
machine is the basic form of AI that
does not store memories or use past
experiences to determine future actions
it works only with present data they
simply perceive the world and react to
it reactive machines are given certain
tasks and don't have capabilities Beyond
those
duties IBM deep blue which defeated
chess Grandmaster Gary casprov is a
reactive machine that sees the pieces on
a chest board and reacts to them it
cannot refer to any of its prior
experiences and cannot improve with
practice deep blue can identify the
pieces on a chess board and know how
each moves it can make predictions about
what moves might be next for it and its
opponent it can choose the most optimal
moves from among the possibilities deep
blue ignores everything before the
present
moment all it does is look at the pieces
on the chessboard as it stands right now
and choose from possible next
moves up next we have limited memory
limited memory AI learns from past data
to make decisions the memory of such
systems is
shortlived while they can use this data
for a specific period of time they
cannot add it to a library of their
experiences this kind of technology is
used for self-driving Vehicles they
observe how other vehicles are moving
around them in the present and as time
passes that ongoing collected data gets
added to the static data within the AI
machine such as Lane markers and traffic
lights there included when the vehicle
decides to change lanes to avoid cutting
of another driver or being hit by a
nearby vehicle Mitsubishi Electric is a
company that has been figuring out how
to improve such technology for
applications like self-driving
cars then we have theory of Mind theory
of Mind represents a very advanced class
of technology and exists as a concept
this kind of AI requires a thorough
understanding that the people and the
things within an environment can alter
feelings and
behaviors it should be able to
understand people's emotions sentiment
and
thoughts even though a lot of
improvements are there in this field
this kind of AI is not complete yet one
real world example of theory of Mind AI
is Kismet a robot head made in the late
'90s by a Massachusetts Institute of
Technology researcher Kismet can mimic
human emotions and recognize them both
abilities are key advancements in theory
of Mind AI but Kismet can't follow gazes
or convey attention to humans sopia from
Hansen robotics is another example where
the theory of Mind AI was implemented
cameras within Sophia's eyes combined
with computer algorithms allow her to
see see and follow faces sustain eye
contact and recognize individuals she is
able to process speech and have
conversations using natural language
subsystem finally we have
self-awareness self-awareness AI only
exists
hypothetically such systems understand
that internal traits States and
conditions and person perceive human
emotions these machines will be smarter
than the human
mind this type of AI will not only be
able to understand and evoke emotions in
those it interacts with but also have
emotions needs and beliefs of its own
while we are probably far away from
creating machines that are self-aware we
should focus our efforts towards
understanding memory learning and the
ability to base decisions on past
experiences let's look at the definition
of each of these learning techniques
supervised learning uses labeled data to
train machine learning models labeled
data means that the output is already
known to you the model just needs to map
the inputs to the outputs an example of
supervised learning can be to train a
machine that identifies the image of an
animal below you can see we have a
trained model that identifies the
picture of a cat unsupervised learning
uses unlabeled data to train machines
unlabelled data means there is no fixed
output variable
the model learns from the data discovers
patterns and features in the data and
Returns the output here is an example of
an unsupervised learning technique that
uses the images of vehicles to classify
if it's a bus or a truck so the model
learns by identifying the paths of a
vehicle such as the length and width of
the vehicle the front and rear end
covers roof hoods the types of Wheels
used Etc based on these features the
model classifies if the vehicle is a bus
or a
truck reinforcement learning trains a
machine to take suitable accs and
maximize reward in a particular
situation it uses an agent and an
environment to produce actions and
rewards the agent has a start and an end
state but there might be different paths
for reaching the end State like a maze
in this learning technique there is no
predefined target variable an example of
reinforcement learning is to train a
machine that can identify the shape of
an object given a list of different
objects such as Square triangle
rectangle or a circle in the example
shown the model tries to predict the
shape of the object which is a square
here now let's look at the different
machine learning algorithms that come
under these learning techniques some of
the commonly used supervised learning
algorithms are linear regression
logistic regression support Vector
machines K nearest neighbors decision
tree random forest and knife
base examples of unsupervised learning
algorithms are k clustering hierarchical
clustering DB scan principal component
analysis and others choosing the right
algorithm depends on the type of problem
you're trying to
solve some of the important
reinforcement learning algorithms are Q
learning Monte Carlo sarsa and deep Q
Network now let's look at the approach
in which these machine learning
techniques
work so supervised learning takes
labeled inputs and Maps it to known
outputs which means you already know the
target
variable unsupervised learning finds
patterns and understands the trends in
the data to discover the output so the
model tries to label the data based on
the features of the input
data while reinforcement learning
follows trial and error method to get
the desired solution after accomplishing
a task the agent receives an award an
example could be to train a dog to cast
the ball if the dog learns to catch a
ball you give it a reward such as a
biscuit now
let's discuss the training process for
each of these learning
methods so supervised learning methods
need external supervision to trade
machine learning models and hence the
name
supervised they need guidance and
additional information to return the
result unsupervised learning techniques
do not need any supervision to train
models they learn on their own and
predict the output similarly
reinforcement learning methods do not
need any supervision to train machine
learning models
and with that let's focus on the types
of problems that can be solved using
these three types of machine learning
techniques so supervised learning is
generally used for classification and
regression problems we'll see the
examples in the next
slide and unsupervised learning is used
for clustering and Association problems
while reinforcement learning is
reward-based so for every task or for
every step completed there will be a
reward received by the agent and if the
task is not achieved correctly there
will be some penalty
used now let's look at a few
applications of supervised unsupervised
and reinforcement
learning as we saw earlier supervised
learning are used to solve
classification and regression problems
for example You can predict the weather
for a particular day based on humidity
precipitation wind speed and pressure
values you can use supervised learning
algorithms to forecast sales for the
next month or the next quarter for
different products similarly you can use
it for stock price analysis or
identifying if a cancer cell is
malignant or
benign now talking about the
applications of unsupervised learning we
have customer segmentation So based on
customer Behavior likes dislikes and
interest you can segment and cluster
similar customers into a group another
example where unsupervised learning
algorithms are used is customer churn
analysis now let's see what applications
we have in re enforcement learning so
reinforcement learning algorithms are
widely used in the gaming Industries to
build games it is also used to train
robots to perform human tasks profit
estimation of a company if I was going
to invest in a company I would like to
know how much money I could expect to
make so we'll take a look at a venture
capitalist firm and try to understand
which companies they should invest in so
we'll take the idea that we need to
decide the companies to invest in we
need to predict the profit the company
makes and we're going to do it based on
the company's expenses and even just a
specific expense in this case we have
our company we have the different
expenses so we have our R&D which is
your research and development we have
our marketing uh we might have the
location we might have what kind of
administration it's going through based
on all this different information we
would like to calculate the profit now
in actuality there's usually about 23 to
27 different markers that they look at
if they're a heavy duty investor we're
only going to take a look at one basic
one we're going to come in and for
Simplicity let's consider a single
variable R&D and find out which
companies to invest in based on that so
when we take a R&D and we're plotting
The Profit based on the R&D expenditure
how much money they put into the
research and development and then we
look at the profit that goes with that
we can predict a line to estimate the
profit so we can draw a line right
through the data when you look at that
you can see how much they invest in the
R&D is a good marker as to how much
profit they're going to have we can also
note that companies spending more on R&D
make good profit so let's invest in the
ones that spend a higher rate in their
R&D what's in it for you first we'll
have an introduction to machine learning
followed by Machine learning algorithms
these will be specific to linear
regression and where it fits into the
larger model then we'll take a look at
applications of linear regression
understanding linear regression and
multiple linear regression finally we'll
roll up our sleeves and do a little
programming in use case profit
estimation of companies let's go ahead
and jump in let's start with our
introduction to machine learning along
with some machine learning algorithms
and where that fits in with larar
regression let's look at another example
of machine learning based on the amount
of rainfall how much would be the crop
yield so here we have our crops we have
our rainfall and we want to know how
much we're going to get from our crops
this year so we're going to introduce
two variables independent and dependent
the independent variable is a variable
whose value does not change by the
effect of other VAR variables and is
used to manipulate the dependent
variable it is often denoted as X in our
example rainfall is the independent
variable this is a wonderful example
because you can easily see that we can't
control the rain but the rain does
control the crop so we talk about the
independent Dev variable controlling a
dependent variable let's Define
dependent variable as a variable whose
value change when there is any
manipulation in the values of the
independent variables it is often
denoted as why and you can see here our
crop yield is dependent variable and it
is dependent on the amount of rainfall
received now that we've taken a look at
a real life example let's go a little
bit into the theory and some definitions
on machine learning and see how that
fits together with linear regression
numerical and categorical values let's
take our data coming in and this is kind
of random data from any kind of project
we want to divide it up into numerical
and categorical so numerical is numbers
age salary height where categorical
would be a description the color a dog's
breed gender categoricals limited to
very specific items where numerical is a
range of information now that you've
seen the difference between numerical
and categorical data let's take it look
at some different machine learning
definitions when we look at our
different machine learning algorithms we
can divide them into three areas
supervised
unsupervised reinforcement we're only
going to look at supervised today
unsupervised means we don't have the
answers and we're just grouping things
reinforcement is where we give positive
and negative feedback to our algorithm
to program it and it doesn't have the
information till after the fact but
today we're just looking at supervised
because that's where linear regression
fits in in supervised data we have our
data already there and our answers for a
group and then we use that to program
our model and come up with an answer the
two most common uses for that is through
the regression and classification now
we're doing linear regression so we're
just going to focus on the regression
side and in the regression we have
SIMPLE linear regression we have
multiple linear regression and we have
polom linear regression now on these
three simple linear regression is the
examples we've looked at so far where we
have a lot of data and we draw a
straight line through it multiple linear
regression means we have multiple
variables remember where we had the
rainfall and the crops we might add
additional variables in there like how
much food do we give our crops when do
we Harvest them those would be
additional information add into our
model and that's why it' be multiple
linear regression and finally we have
polinomial linear regression that is
instead of drawing a line we can draw a
curved line through it now that you see
where regression model fits into the
machine learning algorithms and we're
specifically looking at linear
regression let's go ahead and take a
look at applications for linear
regression let's look at a few
applications of linear regression
economic growth used to determine the
economic growth of a country or a state
in the coming quarter can also be used
to predict the GDP of a country product
price can be used to predict what would
be the price of a product in the future
we can guess whether it's going to go up
or down or should I buy today housing
sales to estimate the number of houses a
builder would sell and what price in the
coming months score predictions Cricut
fever to predict the number of runs a
player with score in the coming matches
based on the previous performance I'm
sure you can figure out other
applications you could use linear
regression for so let's jump in and
let's understand linear regression and
dig into the theory understanding linear
regression linear regression is the
statistical model used to predict the
relationship between independent and
dependent variables by examining two
factors the first important one is which
variables in particular are significant
predictors of the outcome variable and
the second one that we need to look at
closely is how significant is the
regression line to make predictions with
the highest possible accuracy if it's
inaccurate we can't use it so it's very
important we find out the most accurate
line we can get since linear regression
is based on drawing a line through data
we're going to jump back and take a look
at some ukian geometry the simplest form
of a simple linear regression equation
with one dependent and one independent
variable is represented by y = m * x + C
and if you look at our model here we
plotted two points on here uh X1 and y1
X2 and Y2 y being the dependent variable
remember that from before and X being
the independent variable so y depends on
whatever X is m in this case is the
slope of the line where m equals the
difference in the Y 2us y1 and X2 - X1
and finally we have C which is the
coefficient of the line or where happens
to cross the zero axis let's go back and
look at an example we used earlier of
linear regression we're going to go back
to plotting the amount of crop yield
based on the amount of rainfall and here
we have our rainfall remember we cannot
change rainfall and we have our crop
yield which is dependent on the rainfall
so we have our independent and our
dependent variables we're going to take
this and draw a line through it as best
we can through the middle of the data
and then we look at that we put the red
point on the y axis is the amount of
crop yield you can expect for the amount
of rainfall represented by the Green Dot
so if we have an idea what the rainfall
is for this year and what's going on
then we can guess how good our crops are
going to be and we've created a nice
line right through the middle to give us
a nice mathematical formula let's take a
look and see what the math looks like
behind this let's look at the intuition
behind the regression line now before we
dive into the math and the formulas that
go behind this and what's going on
behind the scenes I want you to note
that when we get into the case study and
we actually apply some python script
that this math that you're going to see
here is already done automatically for
you you don't have to have it memorized
it is however good to have an idea
what's going on so if people reference
the different terms you'll know what
they're talking about let's consider a
sample data set with five rows and find
out how to draw the regression line
we're only going to do five rows because
if we did like the rainfall with 100 of
points of data that would be very hard
to see what's going on with the
mathematics so we'll go ahead and create
our own two sets of data and we have our
independent variable X and our dependent
variable Y and when X was 1 we got Y = 2
when X was uh 2 y was 4 and so on and so
on if we go ahead and plot this data on
a graph we can see how it forms a nice
line through the middle you can see
where it's kind of grouped going upwards
to the right the next thing we want to
know is what the means is of each of the
data coming in the X and the Y the means
doesn't mean anything other than the
average so we add up all the numbers and
divide by the total so 1 + 2 + 3 + 4 + 5
over 5 equals 3 and the same for y we
get four if we go ahead and plot the
means on the graph we'll see we get 3
comma 4 which draws a nice line down the
middle a good estimate here we're going
to dig deeper into the math behind the
regression line now remember before I
said you don't have to have all these
formulas memorized or fully understand
them even though we're going to go into
a little more detail of how it works and
if you're not a math whz and you don't
know if you've never seen the sigma
character before which looks a little
bit like an e that's opened up that just
means summation that's all that is so
when you see the sigma character it just
means we're adding everything in that
row and for computers this is great
because as a programmer you can easily
iterate through each of the XY points
and create all the information you need
so in the top half you can see where
we've broken that down into pieces and
as it goes through the first two points
it computes the squared value of x the
squared value of y and x * Y and then it
takes all of X and adds them up all of Y
adds them up all of X squ adds them up
and so on and so on and you can see we
have the sum of equal to 15 the sum is
equal to 20 all the way up to x * Y
where the sum equals 66 this all comes
from our formula for calculating a
straight line where y equal the slope *
X plus a coefficient C so we go down
below and we're going to compute more
like the averages of these and we're
going to explain exactly what that is in
just a minute and where that information
comes from it's called the square means
error but we'll go into that in detail
in a few minutes all you need to do is
look at the formula and see how we've
gone about Computing it line by line
instead of trying to have a huge set of
numbers pushed into it and down here
you'll see where the slope m equals and
on the top part if you read through the
brackets you have the number of data
points times the sum of x * Y which we
computed one line at a time there and
that's just the 66 and take all that and
you subtract it from the sum of x times
the sum of Y and those have both been
computed so you have 15 * 20 and on the
bottom we have the number of lines times
the sum of X2 easily computed as 86 for
the sum minus I'll take all that and
subtract the sum of x^ s and we end up
as we come across with our formula you
can plug in all those numbers which is
very easy to do on the computer you
don't have to do the math on a piece of
paper or calculator and you'll get a
slope of 6 and you'll get your C
coefficient if you continue to follow
through that formula you'll see it comes
out as equal to 2.2 continuing deeper
into what's going behind the scenes
let's find out the predicted values of Y
for corresponding finding values of X
using the linear equation where M = 6
and C = 2.2 we're going to take these
values and we're going to go ahead and
plot them we're going to predict them so
y = 6 * where x = 1 + 2.2 = 2.8 so on
and so on and here the Blue Points
represent the actual y values and the
brown points represent the predicted yv
values based on the model we created the
distance between the actual and
predicted values is known as re uals or
errors the best fit line should have the
least sum of squares of these errors
also known as e square if we put these
into a nice chart where you can see X
and you can see Y what we actual values
were and you can see why predict it you
can easily see where we take y- y
predicted and we get an answer what is
the difference between those two and if
we square that Yus y prediction squared
we can then sum those squared values
that's where we get the 64 plus the 36 +
1 all the way down until we have a
summation equals 2.4 so the sum of
squared errors for this regression line
is 2.4 we check this error for each line
and conclude the best fit line having
the least e Square value in a nice
graphical representation we can see here
where we keep moving this line through
the data points to make sure the best
fit line has the least Square distance
between the data points and the
regression line now we only looked at
the most commonly used form formula for
minimizing the distance there are lots
of ways to minimize a distance between
the line and the data points like sum of
squared errors sum of absolute errors
root mean square error Etc what you want
to take away from this is whatever
formula is being used you can easily
using a computer programming and
iterating through the data calculate the
different parts of it that way these
complicated formulas you see with the
different summations and absolute values
are easily computed one piece at a time
up until this point we've only been
looking at two values X and Y well in
the real world it's very rare that you
only have two values when you're
figuring out a solution so let's move on
to the next topic multiple linear
regression let's take a brief look at
what happens when you have multiple
inputs so in multiple linear regression
we have uh well we'll start with the
simple linear regression where we had y
= m + x + C and we're trying to find the
value of y now with multipolar
regression we have multiple variables
coming in so instead of having just X we
have X1 X2 X3 and instead of having just
one slope each variable has its own
slope attached to it as you can see here
we have M1 M2 M3 and we still just have
the single coefficient so when you're
dealing with multiple linear regression
you basically take your single linear
regression and you spread it out so you
have y = M1 * X1 + M2 * X2 so on all the
way to m to the nth x to the n and then
you add your coefficient on there
implementation of linear regression now
we get into my favorite part let's
understand how multiple linear
regression works by implementing it in
Python if you remember before we were
looking at a company and just based on
its R&D trying to figure out its profit
we're going to start looking at the
expenditure of the company we're going
to go back to that we're going to
predict as profit but instead of
predicting it just on the R&D we're
going to look at other factors like
Administration costs marketing costs and
so on and from there we're going to see
if we can figure out what the profit of
that company's going to be to start our
coding we're going to begin by importing
some basic libraries and we're going to
be looking through the data before we do
any kind of linear regression we're
going to take a look at the data see
what we're playing with then we'll go
ahead and format the data to the format
we need to be able to run it in the
linear regression model and then from
there we'll go ahead and solve it and
just see how valid our solution is so
let's start with importing the basic
libraries now I'm going to be doing this
in Anaconda Jupiter notebook a very
popular IDE I enjoy it CU it's such a
visual to look at and so easy to use um
just any ID for python will work just
fine for this so break out your favorite
python IDE so here we are in our Jupiter
notebook let me go ahead and paste our
first piece of code in there and let's
walk through what libraries were
importing first we're going to import
numpy as NP and then I want you to skip
one line and at import pandas as PD
these are very common tools that you
need with most of your linear regression
the numpy which stands for number python
is usually denoted as NP and you have to
almost have that for your SK learn
toolbox you always import that right off
the beginning pandas although you don't
have to have it for your sklearn
libraries it does such a wonderful job
of importing data setting it up into a
data frame so we can manipulate it
rather easily and it has a lot of tools
also in addition to that so we usually
like to use the pandas when we can and
I'll show show you what that looks like
the other three lines are for us to get
a visual of this data and take a look at
it so we're going to import map plot
library. pyplot as PLT and then caborn
as SNS caborn works with the matplot
library so you have to always import
matplot library and then caborn sits on
top of it and we'll take a look at what
that looks like you could use any of
your own plotting libraries you want
there's all kinds of ways to look at the
data these are just very common ones and
the caborn is so easy to use that just
looks beautiful it's a nice
representation that you can actually
take and show somebody and the final
line is the Amber sign map plot Library
inline that is only because I'm doing an
inline IDE my interface in the Anaconda
Jupiter notebook requires I put that in
there or you're not going to see the
graph when it comes up let's go ahead
and run this it's not going to be that
interesting because we're just setting
up variables in fact it's not going to
do anything that we can see but it is
importing these different libraries and
setup the next step is is load the data
set and extract independent and
dependent variables now here in the
slide you'll see companies equals pd.
read CSV and it has a long line there
with the file at the end 1,000
companies. CSV you're going to have to
change this to fit whatever setup you
have and the file itself you can request
just go down to the commentary below
this video and put a note in there and
simply learn we'll try to get in contact
with you and Supply you with that file
so you can try this coding yourself so
we're going to add this code in here and
we're going to see that I have companies
equals pd. reader CSV and I've changed
this path to match my computer c/s
simplylearn
1000 companies. CSV and then below there
we're going to set the x equals to
companies under the ication and because
this is companies is a PD data set I can
use this nice notation that says take
every row that's what the colon the
first colon is comma except for the last
column that's what the second part is
where we have a colon minus one and we
want the values set into there so X is
no longer a data set a pandis data set
but we can easily extract the data from
our pandas data set with this notation
and then y we're going to set equal to
the last row well the question is going
to be what are we actually looking at so
let's go ahead and take a look at that
and we're going to look at the
companies. head which lists the first
five rows of data and I'll open up the
file in just a second so you can see
where that's coming from but let's look
at the data in here as far as the way
the pandas sees it when I hit run you'll
see it breaks it out into a nice setup
this is what pandas one of the things
pandas is really good about is it looks
just like an Excel spreadsheet you have
your rows and remember when we're
programming we always start with zero we
don't start with one so it shows the
first five rows 0 1 2 3 4 and then it
shows your different columns R&D spend
Administration marketing spend State
profit it even notes that the top are
column names it was never told that but
pandas is able to recognize a lot of
things that they're not the same as the
data rows why don't we go ahead and open
this file up in a CSV so you can
actually see the raw data so here I've
opened it up as a text editor and you
can see at the top we have R&D spin
comma Administration comma marketing
spin comma State comma profit carriage
return I don't know about you but I'd go
crazy trying to read files like this
that's why we use the pandas you could
also open this up in an Excel and it
would separate it since it is a comma
separated variable file but we don't
want to look at this one we want to look
at something we can read rather easily
so let's flip back and take a look at
that top part the first five row now as
nice as this format is where you can see
the data to me it doesn't mean a whole
lot maybe you're an expert in business
and Investments and you understand what
$165,300 compared to the administration
cost of
$136,800 so on so on helps to create the
profit of $192,000
26183 that makes no sense to me
whatsoever no pun intended so let's flip
back here and take a look at our next
set of code where we're going to graph
it so we can get a better understanding
of our data and what it means so at this
point we're going to use a single line
of code to get a lot of information so
we can see where we're going with this
let's go ahead and paste that into our
uh notebook and see what we got going
and so we have the visualization and
again we're using SNS which is pandas as
you can see we imported the map plot
library. pyplot as PLT which then the
caborn uses and we imported the caborn
as SNS and then that final line of code
helps us show this in our um inline
coding without this it wouldn't display
and you can display it to a file and
other means and that's the matap plot
library in line with the Amber sign at
the beginning so here we come down to
the single line of code caborn is great
because it actually recognizes the panda
data frame so I can just take the
companies. core for coordinates and I
can put that right into the Seaborn and
when we run this we get this beautiful
plot and let's just take a look at what
this plot means if you look at this plot
on mine the colors are probably a little
bit more purplish and blue than the
original one uh we have the columns and
the rows we have R and D spending we
have Administration we have marketing
spending and profit and if you cross
index any two of these since we're
interested in profit if you cross index
profit with profit it's going to show up
if you look at the scale on the right
way up in the Dart why because those are
the same data they have an exact
correspondence so R&D spending is going
to be the same as R&D spending and the
same thing with Administration cost so
right down the middle you get this dark
row or dark um diagonal row that shows
that this is the highest corresponding
data that's exactly the same and as it
becomes lighter there's less connections
between the data so we can see with
profit obviously profit is the same as
profit and next it has a very high
correlation with R&D spending which we
looked at earlier and it has a slightly
less connection to marketing spending
and even less to how much money we put
into the administration so now that we
have a nice look at the data let's go
ahead and dig in and create some actual
useful linear regression model so that
we can predict values and have a better
profit now that we've taken a look at
the visualization of this data we're
going to move on to the next step
instead of just having a pretty picture
we need to generate some hard data some
hard values so let's see what that looks
like we're going to set up our linear
regression model in two steps the first
one is we need to prepare some of our
data so it fits correctly and let's go
ahead and paste this code into our
Jupiter notebook and what we're bringing
in is we're going to bring in the
sklearn preprocessing where we're going
to import the label encoder and the one
hot encoder to use the label encoder
we're going to create a variable called
label encoder and set it equal to
capital L label capital E encoder this
creates a class that we can reuse for
transferring the labels back and forth
now about now you should ask what labels
are we talking about let's go take a
look at the data we processed before and
see what I'm talking about here if you
remember when we did the companies. head
and we printed the top five rows of data
we have our columns going across we have
column zero which is R&D spending column
one which is Administration column two
which is marketing spending and column
three is State and you'll see under
State we have New York California
Florida now to do a linear regression
model it doesn't know how to process New
York it knows how to process a number so
the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to change that New York
California and Florida and we're going
to change those to numbers that's what
this line of code does here x equals and
then it has the colon comma 3 in
Brackets the first part the colon comma
means that we're going to look at all
the different rows so we're going to
keep them all together but the only row
we're going to edit is the third row and
in there we're going to take the label
code and we're going to fit and
transform the X also the third row so
we're going to take that third row we're
going to set it equal to a
transformation and that transformation
basically tells it that instead of
having a uh New York it has a zero or
one or a two and then finally we need to
do a one hot encoder which equals one
hot encoder categorical features equals
three and then we take the X and we go
ahead and do that equal to one hot
encoder fit transform X to array this
final transformation preps our data for
us so it's completely set the way we
need it as just a row of numbers even
though it's not in here let's go ahead
and print X and just take a look what
this data is doing you'll see you have
an array of arrays and then each array
is a row of numbers and if I go ahead
and just do row zero you'll see I have a
nice organized row of numbers that the
computer now understands we'll go ahead
and take this out there because it
doesn't mean a whole lot to us it's just
a row of numbers next on setting up our
data we have avoiding dummy variable
trap this is very important why because
the computer has automatically
transformed our header into the setup
and it's automatically transformed all
these different variables so when we did
the encoder the encoder created two
columns and what we need to do is just
have the one because it has both the
variable and the name that's what this
piece of code does here let's go ahead
and paste this in here and we have x = x
colon comma 1 colon all this is doing is
removing that one extra column we put in
there when we did our one hot encoder
and our labeling coding let's go ahead
and run that and now we get to create
our linear regression model and let's
see what that looks like here and we're
going to do that in two steps the first
step is going to be in splitting the
data now whenever we create a uh
predictive model of data we always want
to split it up so we have a training set
and we have a testing set that's very
important otherwise we'd be very
unethical without testing it to see how
good our fit is and then we'll go ahead
and create our multiple linear
regression model and train it and set it
up let's go ahead and paste this next
piece of code in here and I'll go ahead
and shrink it down a size or two so it
all fits on one line so from the sklearn
module selection we're going to import
train test split and you'll see that
we've created four completely different
variables we have capital x train
capital X test smaller case y train
smaller case y test that is the standard
way that they usually referenes when
we're doing different uh models you
usually see that a capital x and you see
the train and the test and the lowercase
Y what this is is X is our data going in
that's our R&D spin our Administration
our marketing and then why which we're
training is the answer that's the profit
because we want to know the profit of an
unknown entity so that's what we're
going to shoot for in this tutorial the
next part train test split we take X and
we take y we we've already created those
X has the columns with the data in it
and Y has a column with profit in it and
then we're going to set the test size
equals 2 that basically means 20% So 20%
of the rows are going to be tested we're
going to put them off to the side so
since we're using a th000 lines of data
that means that 200 of those lines we're
going to hold off to the side to test
for later and then the random State
equals zero we're going to randomize
which ones it picks to hold off to the
side we'll go ahead and run this it's
not overly exciting so it's setting up
our variables but the next step is the
next step we actually create our linear
regression model now that we got to the
linear regression model we get that next
piece of the puzzle let's go ahe and put
that code in there and walk through it
so here we go we're going to paste it in
there and let's go ahead and since this
is a shorter line of code let's zoom up
there so we can get a good luck and we
have from the SK learn. linear model
we're going to import linear regression
now I don't know if you recall from
earlier when we were doing all the math
let's go ahead and flip back back there
and take a look at that do you remember
this or we had this long formula on the
bottom and we were doing all this suiz
and then we also looked at setting it up
with the different lines and then we
also looked all the way down to multiple
linear regression where we're adding all
those formulas together all of that is
wrapped up in this one section so what's
going on here is I'm going to create a
variable called regressor and the
regressor equals the linear regression
that's a linear regression model that
has all that math built in so we don't
have to have it all memorized or have to
compute it individually and then we do
the regressor do fet in this case we do
X train and Y train because we're using
the training data X being the data in
and Y being profit what we're looking at
and this does all that math for us so
within one click and one line we've
created the whole linear regression
model and we fit the data to the linear
regression model and you can see that
when I run the regressor it gives an
output linear regression it says copy x
equals True Fit intercept equals true in
jobs equal 1 normalize equals false it's
just giving you some general information
on what's going on with that regressor
model now that we've created our linear
regression model let's go ahead and use
it and if you remember we kept a bunch
of data aside so we're going to do a y
predict variable and we're going to put
in the X test and let's see what that
looks like scroll up a little bit paste
that in here predicting the test set
results so here we have y predict equals
regressor do predict X test going in and
this gives us y predict now because I'm
in Jupiter in line I can just put the
variable up there and when I hit the Run
button it'll print that array out I
could have just as easily done print y
predict so if you're in a different IDE
that's not an inline setup like the
Jupiter notebook you can do it this way
print y predict and you'll see that for
the 200 different test variables we kept
off to the side it's going to produce
200 answers this is what it says the
profit are for those 200 predictions but
let's don't stop there let's keep going
and take a couple look we're going to
take just a short detail here and
calculating the coefficients and the
intercepts this gives us a quick flash
at what's going on behind the line we're
going to take a short detour here and
we're going to be calculating the
coefficient and intercepts so you can
see what those look like what's really
nice about our regressor we created is
it already has a coefficients for us and
we can simply just print regressor do
coefficient uncore when I run this
you'll see our coefficient here and if
we can do the regressor coefficient we
can also do the regressor intercept and
let's run that and take a look at that
this all came from the multiple
regression model and we'll flip over so
you can remember where this is going
into and where it's coming from you can
see the formula down here where y = M1 *
X1 + M2 * X2 and so on and so on plus C
the coefficient so these variables fit
right into this formula y = slope 1 *
column 1 variable Plus slope 2 * column
2 variable all the way to the m into the
n and x to the N plus C the coefficient
or in this case you have -
8.89 to the^ of 2 etc etc times the
First Column and the second column and
the third column and then our intercept
is the minus
10309 Point boy it gets kind of
complicated when you look at it this is
why we don't do this by hand anymore
this is why we have the computer to make
these calculations easy to understand
and calculate now I told you that was a
short detour and we're coming towards
the end of our script as you remember
from the beginning I said if we're going
to divide this information we have to
make sure it's a valid model that this
model works and understand how good it
works so calculating the r SAR value
that's what we're going to use to
predict how good our prediction is and
let's take a look at what that looks
like in code and so we're going to use
this from sklearn docs we're going to
import R2 score that's the R squ value
we're looking at the error so in in the
R2 score we take our y test versus our y
predict y test is the actual values
we're testing that was the one that was
given to us that we know are true the Y
predict of those 200 values is what we
think it was true and when we go ahead
and run this we see we get a.
9352 that's the R2 score now it's not
exactly a straight percentage so it's
not saying it's 93% correct but you do
want that in the upper 90s oh and higher
shows this is a very valid prediction
based on the R2 score and if r squ value
of 91 or 92 as we got on our model
remember it does have a random
generation involved this proves the
model is a good model which means
success yay we successfully trained our
model with certain predictors and
estimated the profit of the companies
using linear regression the why linear
regression now that we have come this
far I'm planning to take a closer look
at our cells so that we can estimate
cells in the future how about we hire a
data scientist you can see our two
corporate individuals looks more like
they should be agents or secret agents
someplace discussing how to better
forward their company and so they're
going to come in and ask the data
scientist to come in good idea this will
help us to keep a constant track of our
sales so why do we need linear
regression let's assume that we need to
predict the number of skiers based on
snowfall so this happens to be uh we've
kind of jumped one business to the next
we're looking at the uh skiing business
very popular in a lot of areas and it's
based on snowfall a lot of times you
figure you don't have snow you don't
have skiers but can we actually use
something more specific instead of look
it's snowing and instead of saying Hey
look it's snowing we can actually start
drawing graphs and the graph shows that
with an increase in snowfall the
frequency of skiers also increases so
and there's a pretty direct correlation
if you've ever been up to ski areas when
there's a lot of snowfalls the skiers
all show up because they know it's going
to be better skiing right afterward so
it's kind of easy to see why skiers and
snowfall would go together and it
usually draws a nice straight line and
you can easily predict how many skiers
and that way you can also predict how
many people you need to service them how
many lifts to have up and running and
all the stuff that goes with running a
ski area thus we see that the number of
skiers are directly proportional to the
amount of snowfall regression models a
relation between a dependent Y and an
independent X variable this is real
important to understand regression
because when we talk about linear
regression it's the basis of almost all
our machine learning algorithms out
there and it's usually an underlying
part of the math in our deep learning so
it all starts here with linear
regression and we talk about a dependent
Y and an independent X variable these
are numbers we're usually talking about
floats so we want to have an actual
number value coming out and that's
different than something that's
categorical where we want to know yes or
no true false so regression means we're
looking for a number the independent
variable is known as predictor variable
and dependent variable is known as the
response variable so we have one
predictor variable the amount of
snowfall and one response variable how
many skiers are going to show up and
then we can take this relationship and
it can be expressed as y equals beta
we're going to use the Greek um letter
beta and we have beta KN plus beta 1 X1
and if you continue out it' be plus beta
2 X2 and so on till the nth degree in
this case no fall is an independent
variable and skars is a dependent
variable so we kind of had a little
quick overview let's go ahead and talk a
little bit more about what is linear
regression so we're going to go from why
predicting a number of skiers for
snowfall and uh we looked at the formula
a little bit but let's look a bit closer
at what exactly is going on with linear
regression and the question is going to
come up at an interview what is linear
regression linear regression is a type
of statistical analysis that attempts to
show the relationship between two
variables linear regression creates a
predictive model on any data showing
Trends in data the model is found by
using the least Square method it there
are other methods the least Square
method happens to be the most commonly
used out there and we usually start with
the least Square method since it's the
most common and usually works the best
on most models and we're already looking
at how linear regression works but let's
dig deeper into it and let's take a
closer look how linear regression works
I will provide you with a data set which
has rent area other information in it
looks like our secret agents have uh put
on their casual wear for this one you
need to predict rent accordingly we are
given area and rent here so you can do
linear regression with more variables
but we're just going to look at the area
and then from that try to figure out
what the rent should be we plot the
graph and if you look at it here you can
see that the graph kind of a linear
pattern with a little dip in it so the
area seems the rent seems to be based on
the area in most of our work as data
scientists we usually try to start with
a physical graph if we can so we can
actually look at it and say hey does
what I'm fitting to this graph look
right you can solve a lot of problems
that arise by looking at the graph and
saying no that doesn't look right at all
or oh I should be looking over here for
this then we find the mean of area and
rent so the mean just means average and
if you take 1 2 3 4 five and add them
all together and divide by in this case
there's five areas you get three and the
rent is 2 4 6 5 and eight if you add
them all together and divide by five you
get five and we plot the mean on the
graph so you can see right here here's
the mean of the rim and the area it's
kind of a very Central Point which is
what we're looking for the average of
everything in there the best fit line
passes through the mean this is real
important when you're um eyeballing it
as humans we can do this fairly easy if
it's a straight line through a bunch of
data it gets more complicated
mathematically when you start adding
multiple variables and instead of a line
you have a curve but for basic linear
regression we're going to draw a line
through the data and the line should go
through the means that's going to be
part of the best fit for that line but
we see there are multiple lines can pass
through the means so depending on how
you look at it you can kind of Wiggle
the line around back and forth so we
keep moving the line to ensure that the
best fit line has the least Square
distance from the data points and this
is you can see right here residual we
have our data point and then we look at
this distance between them and we square
that distance and that's what they mean
by the least squared distance we want
all those distances to add up to the
smallest amount we can when we talk
about that distance we call it the
residual it equals the Y actual minus
the Y predicted very straightforward
just looking at the distance you can
accidentally switch these and it'll come
out the same because we're going to
square it but when you're working with
other sets of linear regression you want
to make sure you do the Y actual minus
the Y predicted the value of M and C for
the best fit line y = mx + C can be
calculated using the mentioned formula
and you can see here we have m equals
the number of points that's what n
stands for then we have the sigma the
Greek symbol is there which is a
summation of x x * y minus the summation
of x * the summation of Y over the
number of the summation of x^2 minus the
summation of X squar of X all of it
squared that can be a little confusing
trying to say that and then of course
your C value is going to be the
summation of y * the summation of X2
minus the summation of x * the summation
of x * y over the total count of the
summation x^2 minus the summation of x^
SAR that's a mouthful normally we don't
worry too much about these formulas
other than to know they're there now if
you're a mathematician you might go back
in there and work on those and those
people who originally started to put
together the different models in R of
course had to know all this math to
build them and had to test it out that's
one of the nice things about R what is
important is that you know about these
formulas so that you know where it's
coming from so if you're using one
linear regression model this is how this
one works there's other linear
regression models based on different
math and so you'd have to be aware when
that math changes and how that changes
the model we find the corresponding
values so in this case if you're going
to break this up and you're building
your own model instead of using the one
in R you would have your rent you would
have your area you would find your rent
squared your area squared and your rent
times area and if we go back one we can
see that that's all the different little
pieces in this model we have x * y we
have X2 we have the sum of X which is
going to be squared we have the sum of X
the sum of Y this is the same these are
all the little pieces in here that we
see for m equals and C equals and so
once we compute all these we have 15 25
55 145 88 very easy to do on a computer
thankfully you could have millions of
these points and it would do it in a
very short period we can then plug in
those values very easily into this
formula and get a final answer and we'll
see that m equal 1.3 and C = 1.1 and
then when we take this for the Y
predicted equals m of i x of I + C we
can take these and actually run the data
we have so we're going to see how it
predicts so now we find the Y the value
of y predicted so we have our xn and we
want to know what Y what we think y will
be based on our formula we generated the
linear regression formula and so we come
in here we have our X we have our actual
y then we have our y predict what we
think it's going to be and then we have
uh we take y minus y predict and we get
those values minus point4 it's off by3
this one's off by one this one's on off
by minus 1.3 by4 and we go ahead and
square that and then we can sum that
square and average it out and we'll get
a value this is just a summation down
here of Yus y predicted square is 3.1
and we call that the least Square value
for this line is 3.1 and we go ahead and
divide that by five so when we plot the
Y predict and this is the best fit line
and you can see that does a pretty good
job going right through the middle of
lines and in something like rent versus
area if you're trying to figure out how
much rent to charge or how many people
are allowed to be in the area that's
going to work but if you're looking for
the rent value compared to the area this
gives you a good idea based on the area
of what you should rent the place for
it's close enough that in the business
world this would work you're not
Computing something down to the
millimeters or micrometers or Nuclear
Physics we're just charging people and
so if you're off by a couple dollars
it's not a big deal you'll be pretty
close to what you think it's worth and
get the right value for your property
use case predicting the revenue using
linear regression now that you have a
good idea of how linear regression works
and we're kicking back on our lounging
sofa today let's work on a real life
scenario where you have to predict the
revenue so we're going to take a data
set and we'll pull this up in just a
minute we'll have a paid organic social
and revenue there are three attributes
we'll be working on the first one is our
paid traffic so all the traffic through
the advertisement that comes in the
non-paid traffic from search engines so
these are people coming to the website
and are doing so because they did a
search for something specific so it's
pulling it from your website all the
traffic coming from social networking
sites so we want to know what's coming
from Twitter and Facebook and somehow
they've linked into your website and
coming into your marketing area to buy
something and we'll use this to predict
the revenue so we want to know how all
this traffic comes together and how it's
going to affect our sales if the
traffic's coming in we're going to make
use of the multiple linear regression
model so you'll see that this is very
similar to we had before where we had y
= m * * x + C but instead we have y = M1
X1 + M2 X2 + M3 X3 + c m is the slope so
you have M1 M2 M3 the three different
slopes of three different lines Y is the
revenue so we're only looking for one
variable and remember this is regression
so we're looking for a number X1 is
going to be the PID traffic and of
course M1 the corresponding slope X2 the
organic traffic and X3 the social
traffic we will follow these steps to
create the regression model we'll start
by generating inputs using the CSV files
we'll then import the libraries
splitting the data into train and test
very important whenever you're doing any
kind of data science applying regression
on paid traffic organic traffic social
traffic so we're going to apply our
regression model on them and then we're
going to validate the model that's the
whole reason we split it to a training
and testing is so we can now validate to
see just how good our model is now
before we open up R I always like to
just take a quick look at the data
itself and we're using the Rev CSV file
and this is a CS file or comma separated
variable file we'll just open that with
word pad any kind of text editor would
be nice to show you what's going on and
you can see we have paid organic social
and revenue across the top so those your
titles for your columns and the values
going down and this is the same as what
we saw on the slide just a minute ago
paid organic social and then revenue
from them they probably have it in more
of a spreadsheet than just a word pad
and I'm using the newer version of our
stud Studio which already has a nice
layout automatically opens up with your
console terminal window down and left
you have your script and we'll run it in
script and then when I run it line by
line in script you'll see it show up on
the console bottom left I could type it
straight into the console and it would
do the same thing and then on the right
we have our environment and under the
environment we'll see uh plots if you're
in an older version the plots will pop
up and you usually are running just in
the console and then you have to open up
a different window to run the script and
you can run the script from there this
opens up everything at the same time
when you use the new R Studio setup and
the first thing we want to do is we want
to go ahead and generate a variable
we'll call it cells and we want to load
this with our data set and so uh in R we
use the less than minus sign that's the
same as assigned to it's like an arrow
pointing at cells and it says whatever
it goes past here is going to be
assigned to cells and we want to read in
our CSV file and then I went ahead and
uh fixed the CSV file up a little bit
when I say the CSV file I mean the path
to it um and we'll go ahead and just
paste that in there and this is my
edited version and you'll see I took
wherever we had the um backward slash I
switched it for a forward slash because
a backwards slash is an escape character
and whenever you're programming in just
about any scripting language you want to
do the forward slash instead so uh like
a good Chef I prepped this and copied it
into my clipboard and we can see the
full path here and the full path ends in
our rev. CSV file that's the path on my
machine and then I'm going to run that
and now we have down here you see it
appear right here uh oh must have an
error in my path it says object rev not
found let me fix that real quick and run
it again and this time it does assign
the cells the data set and then we'll
just type in cells and this is the same
as printing it so if you work in other
languages you'll do like print and then
cells or maybe print cells. head if
you're in pandas and python or something
like that but in R you just type in the
variable we'll run this and you can see
it printed out all those columns so
that's the same thing we just looked at
and it says uh Max print so it emitted
750 rows so it has a total of a thousand
rows and we can scroll up here on our
console where the answer came in and if
I scroll up to the top whoop way up to
the top there we go you'll see paid
organic social and revenue so everything
looks good on this and then there's a
lot of cool things we can do with it one
of the things we can do is I can summary
it so let's do a summary of cells and
we'll run that and the summary of cells
comes in it tells your Min first quarter
median mean third quarter Max for paid
organic social breaks it up and you can
actually get kind of a quick view as to
what the data is doing you can take more
time to study this a lot of people look
at this and you can see from the median
the mean that tells you a lot and it's
divided into quarters so you have your
first quarter value and your third
quarter setup on there and Max it just
gives you a quick idea of what's going
on in the data summary is a really
wonderful tool one of the reasons I like
to jump into R before I might do a major
project in something else or you can run
everything in our and let's take a look
at the head head of cells and let me run
this and you can see it just shows the
head of our data the first six rows in
this case and it starts with one
important to know other different
systems start with zero and go up R is
one that starts with the first as one
and then uh if we want to do a plot I'll
go ahead and do a plot cells another
really powerful tool that you can just
jump right into with r once you have
your data in here and you'll see that
the plot comes over on the right hand
side side and what it does is it
Compares them so if I look at my paid
and my organic and you cross the two
you'll see there's a nice line down the
middle big black line where it plots the
two together let me just widen this a
little bit so we can see more of it
there we go the same thing with paid and
social paid and revenue so each one of
these has a clear connection to each
other so that's a good sign we have a
nice correlation between the data and
you can just eyeball that that's a good
way to jump in and explore your data
rather quickly and see what's going on
on so we'll go ahead and I'll put a
pound sign there hashtag and uh
splitting the data into training and
test data and we want to split it so
that we have something to work with to
train our data set and when we do our
data set you do this with any data set
because you want to make sure you have a
good model and then once we've trained
it we're going to take the other set of
data we pulled off to the side and we'll
test it to see how good it is if you
test it with the training data it's
already got that memorized and should
give you really good answer in fact when
you get into more advanced machine
learning tools you watch those very
closely you watch your training set and
how it does versus your testing set and
if your training set starts doing better
than your testing set then you're
starting to overtrain it now that's more
with deep learning and uh some other
packages that are beyond what we're
working with today but you know this is
important it's very important to
understand that that test and that
training correlate with each other gives
you an idea what's going on and make
sure that you're set up correctly and
we'll go ahead and set a seed of two and
that's for our random generators so that
when we run them you could SE them with
just a r there's ways to randomize a
number or you could do like date and
stuff like that but that way we always
use the same random numbers so we'll
seat it with two and then we're going to
need a library in this case we're going
to import the library and we want to
import CA tools and CA tools has our
split function so we're going to be able
to split our data along with many the
other tools we're going to need for this
example so they're all built into this
CA tools that's why we need to import
that a lot of times they call them
library or sometimes you hear them
referred to as packages so let's go
ahead and run that line and that brings
the library in so now we can use all
those different tools that are in there
and then I'm going to do a split and
we're going to ass to the split that's
going to be our variable sample split
okay so that's one of the tools we just
brought in is to sample is the actual
keyword or the function word sample
dosit and we're going to take our cells
and we're going to go ahead and a split
ratio IO equals
to7 and let's do 0.7 so we make sure it
knows it's a decimal point or float and
what this is saying is that we're going
to take our um cells data the variable
we created called cells that has the
data in there and I want to split it and
I'm going to split it so that 70% of it
goes in one side we'll use that for
training and 30% will go into the other
side which we'll use then for testing
out our model let me go ahe and run that
and oops hold on one second got an error
there spit is definitely very different
than split I don't think we want to spit
our data out we which is actually kind
of what we're doing is spitting it out
but we want to split we want to split
the data so let me get that spelled
correctly and then when I type in Split
we can just run that because that's now
a variable you'll see that it has true
false false true so it generates a
number of interesting different
statistics going across there as far as
the way it splits the data and right
here if you have not used R in a while
or um if you're new to R completely that
line one that's what what the little one
means down there and then true false
false true that means that's how we're
looking at the data we're splitting all
those different pieces of data in line
one different directions and so we now
want to create our train set and we're
going to assign that and when we take it
and we assign to the train set a subset
of cells and then the subset of cells is
going to be based on split equal and put
this in Brackets true so you see the
values down here is capital T capital r
capital u capital E so I just want to
reflect that on the train and this is
going to take everything where our split
variable is equal to true and it's going
to set cells equal to that and we'll go
ahead and run that and then we're going
to set our test variable as a subset of
cells and if we assign the true to the
train set then we want to assign the
false to our test set so now we'll have
uh this will have 30% of the variables
in it and train will have 70% we'll go
ahead and run run that so we now created
both our training set and our test set
and we can just real quickly type in
train hit the run on there and you can
see our train set if we scroll way up to
the top I'll have the column names on
there which should match what we had
before paid organic social and revenue
and then we'll type in test when I hit
run on there that's going to do the same
thing it'll sped out all the test
variables going out so now that we have
the test and train variables we want to
go ahead and create the model and you'll
see this in any of the machine learning
tutorials they always refer to them as
models we're modeling a function of some
kind on the data to fit the data and
then we're going to put the the test
data through there to see how well it
does and so we're going to create the
variable called models and I'm going to
assign that LM that is our linear
regression model I love how simplified R
makes it just LM linear regression and
then model
M um I guess it dates back because the
linear regression model is like one of
the first major models use so they kept
it easy on there and uh Revenue happens
to be the main variable that we're want
to track so if you remember correctly
from our formula Y is the revenue and
then we have X is our paid traffic X2
organic traffic and X3 our social
traffic so Y is what we want to predict
in here and then you'll see this
notation where we have our squiggle and
the period which means we're going to
match up the revenue lines with the
lines of the data we're putting in here
and then I'll put comma and then our
data equals train and of course that's
the training data that we created so
when I hit the Run remember we did all
that discussion about all those
different functions and formulas to
compute our model and how that's set up
when it comes down to it we spend all
our time setting up our data and then I
hit the Run button on the single line
and our model's been trained so we now
have a trained model here and we can do
a summary of the model summary is such a
wonderful command because you can do
that on r that works on all kinds of
different things on there oops and of
course it does help if I remember that
that my model has a capital N when I run
it and you'll see right here tells you a
little bit about the model use the
summary on there comes down here has our
residuals this is all the information on
there as far as like the minimum the
median the Max has all our coefficients
in there if you remember correctly from
our formula let's just go ahead and
switch back over to that we have M1 X1
M2 X2 M3 X3 plus C well that's right
here here's our intercept and then we
have our different values for each of
these we have our intercept our paid
organic and social and then it also
shows us error and information on the
error and uh one of the really nice
things about when you're working with r
you can come down here and you see um
where we have our Stars down here and it
says uh three stars really good two
stars maybe one star probably no
correlation and we can see with all of
these it has three stars on them so out
of three stars we get three stars on all
these there's no four stars four stars
would mean that you have the exact same
data going in as coming out and then if
we're going to do this we want to
actually run a prediction on here and
that's what we saved our test uh data
for so let's come down here we'll do our
prediction we'll take this variable and
we'll sign it predict model and remember
the predict comes from when we imported
that package the ca tools that's all
part of the ca Tools in there so we're
going to predict we're going to use the
model and then we're going to use our
test data pretty straightforward quick
and easy we'll run this and then if we
go ahead and type in the predict it'll
print out what's in that variable and
you'll see down here the predicted
values it expects to come out it's going
to see our revenue is and it goes
through and it gives it both the line
number and the actual Revenue value so
that's quick and easy boy we got a
prediction really fast and this is also
how you would do it if you had new data
coming in after this you could predict
the revenue based on these other factors
so now that we have a training model
which or we train the data with our
training data or we trained the model
with our training data and we've done a
prediction on our model with our test
data we want to look looked this up and
we took a quick glance from our training
thing our training said it trained
really well but that's not the final
word on it the final word is going to be
comparing it so we want to go ahead and
we going to do comparing predicted
versus actual values what I'm going to
do is I'm going to do a plot and I'm
going to do our test and we're going to
do test revenue. type equals and we're
going to put this in as a type uh type
one and or L and then we have lty yal 1
8 and we're going to set up for column
blue that's a lot of stuff in there
let's go ahead and just run that so we
can see what that looks like and what's
that doing it's going to generate this
nice graph we see on the right there's
our graph you can see the data comes up
and down um we're plotting the
prediction on there so this is the
values we predicted and then let's go
ahead and do uh lines and I actually did
this backwards so let me try that again
and we'll start with the red one we're
going to do the first one in red and I
want to start with the actual test
Revenue so here here's our test revenue
and we'll go ahead and run this and so
we have our red plot over here in red go
and take a look at that pull that over
you can see how that looks goes up and
down hard to track there and then we're
going to do a couple things here we'll
plot our test
revenue and then we'll make it a little
pretty although it's kind of hard to say
see the way I have it scrunched up here
on the right as far as size and sizing
and everything but we'll go ahead and
have our um columns in blue and run our
prediction on there too you can see they
overlap the two graphs so we have our
test revenue and our prediction and then
finally what I started with is we'll go
ahead and plot the prediction fully on
the bottom and run that and if you look
over here on the graph we put the blue
lines over the red lines and so you'll
see a couple spots where there's red
underneath there but for the most part
our predictions pretty right on so it
looks really tight looks like a good set
of predictions for what we're working on
and this is what we were looking at the
slide right before we started diving
into the r Studio we can see in the
slide here here's a red just a little
bit better spread out than uh what I
have on my screen for my R studio and
the graph shows a predicted Revenue we
see that the two lines are very close so
again they're tight it's right on this
is what we're looking for in our
prediction model but it's not good
enough just having a graph and you
always do both and the reason we do both
is you want to have a visual of it
because sometimes you look at these you
get to the graph you're like oh my gosh
what is that and then sometimes you look
at the graphic go that's right on how
come my um accuracy doesn't look right
and you realize that your accuracy might
be off or you're plotting it incorrectly
so let's go ahead and look up the
accuracy and we'll use rmsse that's
going to be the variable name we're
going to give it and sqrt the square
root of the mean and mean just means
average and then we want prediction
minus sales revenue and then we're going
to take this whole thing and we're going
to square it so what we've got here is
we're going to go through let's just
explain this formula we're using is I'm
going to look at the what I predict it
for to be and with the actual sales
what's our prediction versus our sales
comparison to the revenue and when we
compare those two we're going to find
the average and then I'm going or we're
going to square each one of those values
and then we're going to average the
square and then find the square root of
that and that's quite a mouthful the
reason we do it this way the reason we
Square the value and then we find the
means is to generate an answer based on
doesn't matter whether it's plus or
minus there's a lot of other formulas
you can use there to check your accuracy
and all kinds of other things you can do
but a quick straightforward way of doing
it is just like this and then let's go
ahead and run this and then we type in
the rmse and that'll give us an actual
printed value out let's just see what
that looks like and so we have
8666 338 for our accuracy and so we look
at the
866.686.1808 playing with accuracies and
start dividing out other different
aspects of it to get something you can
communicate better with but you always
start with the square root means that's
always a good place to start there's no
better time to train yourself in the
exciting field of machine learning if
you're looking for a course that covers
everything from the fundamentals to
Advanced Techniques like machine
learning algorithm development and
unsupervised learning look no further
than our CCH postgraduate program in Ai
and machine learning in partnership with
IBM this& ml course coveres the latest
tools and Technologies from the AI
ecosystem and features master classes by
ctech faculty and IBM experts hecaton
and ask me anything sessions this
program showcases Celtic ctm is
excellence and IBM's industry progess
the artificial intelligence course
covers key Concepts like statistics data
science with python machine learning
deep learning NLP and reinforcement
learning through an Interactive Learning
model with live sessions androll now and
unlock exciting a ml opportunities the
course link is mentioned in the
description box below what is logistic
regression let's say we have to build a
predictive model or a machine learning
model to predict whether the passengers
of the Titanic ship have survived or not
the Shipwreck so how do we do that so we
use logistic regression to build a model
for this how do we use logistic
regression so we have the information
about the passengers their ID whether
they have survived or not their class
and name and so on and so forth and we
use this information where we already
know whether the person has survived or
not that is the labeled information and
we help the system to train based on
this information based on this labeled
data this is known as labeled data and
during the process of building the model
we probably will remove some of the
non-essential parameters or attributes
here we only take those attributes which
are really required to make these
predictions and once we train the model
we run new data through it whereby the
model will predict whether the passenger
has survived or not let's start with
what is supervised learning supervised
learning is one of the two main types of
machine learning methods here we use
what is known as labeled data to help
the system learn this is very similar to
how we human beings learn so let's say
you want to teach a child to recognize
an apple how do we do that we never tell
the child okay this is an apple has a
certain diameter on the top certain
diameter at the bottom and this has a
certain RGB color no we just show an
apple to the child and tell the child
this is Apple and then next time when we
show an apple child immediately
recognizes yes this is an apple supervis
learning works very similar on the
similar lines so where does logistic
regression fit into the overall mission
learning process machine learning is
divided into two types mainly two types
there is is's a third one called
reinforcement learning but we will not
talk about that right now so one is
supervised learning and the other is
unsupervised learning unsupervised
learning uses techniques like clustering
and Association and supervised learning
uses techniques like classification and
regression now supervised learning is
used when you have labeled data you have
historical data then you use supervised
learning when you don't have labeled
data then you used unsupervised learning
it's it's supervised learning there are
two types of techniques that are used
classification and regression based on
what is the kind of problem we are
solved let's say we want to take the
data and classify it it could be binary
classification like a zero or a one an
example of classification we have just
seen whether the passenger has survived
or not survived like a zero or one that
is known as binary classification
regression on the other hand is you need
to predict a value what is known as a
Contin continuous value classification
is for discrete values regression is for
continuous values let's say you want to
predict a share price or you want to
predict the temperature that will be
there what will be the temperature
tomorrow that is where you use
regression whereas classification are
discrete values is will the customer buy
the product or will not buy the product
will you get a promotion or you will not
get a promotion I hope you're getting
the idea or it could be multiclass
classification as well let's say you
want to build an image classification
model so the image classification model
would take an image as an input and
classify into multiple classes whether
this image is of a cat or a dog or an
elephant or a tiger so there are
multiple classes so not necessarily
binary classification so that is known
as multiclass classification so we are
going to focus on classification because
logistic regression is one of the
algorithms used for classification now
the name may be a little confusing in
fact whenever people come across
logistic regression it always causes
confusion because the name has
regression in it but we are actually
using this for performing classification
okay so yes it is logistic regression
but it is used for classification and in
case you're wondering is there something
similar for regression yes for
regression we have linear regression
keep that in mind so linear regression
is used for regression logistic
regression is used for classification so
in this video we are going to focus on
supervised learning and within
supervised learning we going to focus on
classification and then within
classification we are going to focus on
logistic regression algorithm so first
of all classification so what are the
various algorithms available for
performing classification the first one
is decision tree there are of course
multiple algorithms but here we will
talk about flu dision trees are quite
popular and very easy to understand and
therefore they used for classification
then we have K nearest neighbors this is
another algorithm for performing
classification and then there is
logistic regression and this is what we
are going to focus on in this video and
we're going to go into a little bit of
details about logistic regression all
right what is logistic regression as a
mentioned earlier logistic regression is
an algorithm for performing binary
classification so let's take an example
and see how this works let's say your
car has not been serviced for quite a
few years and now you want to find out
if it is going to break down in the near
future so this is like a classification
problem find out whether your car will
break down or not so how are we going to
perform this classification so here's
how it looks if we plot the information
along the X and Y AIS X is the number of
years since the last service was
performed and why is the probability of
your car breaking down and let's say
this information was this data rather
was collected from several car users
it's not just your car but several car
users so that is our labeled data so the
data has been collected and um for for
the number of years and when the car
broke down and what was the probability
and that has been plotted along X and Y
AIS so this provides an idea or from
this graph we can find out whether your
car will break down or not we'll see how
so first of all the probability can go
from 0 to one as you all aware
probability can be between 0 and one and
as we can imagine it is intuitive as
well as the number of years are on the
Lower Side maybe one year two years or 3
years till after the service the chances
of your car breaking down are very
limited right so for example chances of
your car breaking down or the
probability of your car breaking down
within 2 years of your last service are
.1 probability similarly 3 years is
maybe3 and so on but as the number of
years increases let's say if it was six
or seven years there is almost a
certainty that your car is going to
break down that is what this graph shows
so this is an example of a application
of the classification algorithm and we
will see in little details how exactly
logistic regression is applied here one
more thing needs to be added here is
that the dependent variables outcome is
discrete so if we are talking about
whether the car is going to break down
or not so that is a discrete value the Y
that we are talking about the dependent
variable that we are talking about what
we are looking at is whether the car is
going to break down or not yes or no
that is what we are talking about so
here the outcome is discrete and not a
continuous value so this is how the
logistic regression curve looks let me
explain a little bit what exactly and
how exactly we are going to uh determine
the class at the outcome rather so for a
logistic regression curve a threshold
has to be set saying that because this
is a probability calculation remember
this is a probability calculation and
the probability itself will not be zero
or one but based on the probability we
need to decide what the outcome should
be so there has to be a threshold like
for example 0.5 can be the threshold
let's say in this case so any value of
the probability below 0.5 is considered
to be zero and any value above 05 is
considered to be one so an output of
let's
say8 will mean that the car will break
down so that is considered as an output
of one and let's say an output of 0. 29
is considered as zero which means that
the car will not break down so that's
the way logistic regression works now
let's do a quick comparison between
logistic regression and linear
regression because they both have the
term regression in them so that can
cause confusion so let's try to remove
that confusion so what is linear
regression linear regression is a
process is once again an algorithm for
supervised learning however here you're
going to find a continuous you're going
to determine a continuous value it could
be the price of a real estate property
it could be your hike how much hike
you're going to get or it could be a
stock price these are all continuous
values these are notation that is
available and the system learns from
this it is trained and it learns from
this labeled information so that when a
new employees information is fed based
on the rating it will determine what
should be the height so this is a linear
regression problem and a linear
regression example now salary is a
continuous value you can get 5,000
5,500 5,600 it is not discrete like a
cat or a dog or an apple or a banana
these are discrete or a yes or a no
these are discrete values right so this
where you are trying to find continuous
values is where we use linear regression
so let's say just to extend on this
scenario we now want to find out whether
and this is the ratings for which people
did not get promotion that is a no and
this is the rating for which people got
promotion we just plotted the data about
whether a person has got an employee has
got promotion or not yes no right so
there is nothing in between and what is
the employees rating okay and ratings
can be continuous that is not an issue
but the output is discrete in this case
whether employee got promotion yes no
okay so if we try to plot that and we
try to find a straight line this is how
it would look and as you can see it
doesn't look very right because looks
like there will be lot of errors this
root mean square error if you remember
for linear regression would be very very
high and also the the values cannot go
beyond zero or Beyond one so the graph
should probably look somewhat like this
clipped at 0 and one but still the
straight line doesn't look right
therefore instead of using a linear
equation we need to come up with
something different and therefore the
logistic regression model looks somewhat
like this so we calculate the
probability and if we plot that
probability not in the form of a
straight line but we need to use some
other equation we will see very soon
what that equation is then it is a
gradual process right so you see here
people with some of these ratings are
not getting any promotions and then
slowly uh at certain ratings they get
promotion so that is a gradual process
and U this is how the math behind
logistic regression looks so we are
trying to find the odds for a particular
event happening and this is the formula
for finding the odds so the probability
of an event happening divided by the
probability of the event not happening
so P if it is the probability of the
event happening probability of the
person getting a promotion and divided
by the probability of the person not
getting a promotion that is 1 minus
P so this is how you measure the odds
now the values of the odds range from 0o
to Infinity so when this probability is
zero then the odds will the value of the
odds is equal to Z and when the
probability becomes one then the value
of the odds is 1 by 0 that will be
Infinity but the probability itself
remains between 0 and 1 now this is how
an equation of a straight line look so Y
is equal to Beta 0 + beta 1 x where beta
0 is the Y intercept and beta 1 is the
slope of the line if we take the odds
equation and take a log of both sides
then this would look somewhat like this
and the term logistic is actually
derived from the fact that we are doing
this we take a log of DX by 1us PX this
is an extension of the calculation of
odds that we have seen right and that is
equal to beta 0 + beta 1 x which is the
equation of the straight line and now
from here if you want to find out the
value of PX we will see we can take the
exponential on both sides and then if we
solve that equation we will get the
equation of PX like this PX is equal to
1 by 1 + e^ of minus beta 0 + beta 1 x
and recall this is nothing but the
equation of the line which is equal to y
y is equal to Beta 0 + beta 1X so that
this is the equation also known as the
sigmoid function and this is the
equation of the logistic regression all
right and if this is plotted this is how
the sigmoid curve is obtained so let's
compare linear and logistic regression
how they are different from each other
let's go back so linear regression is
solved or used to solve regression
problems and logistic regression is used
to solve classification problem so both
are called regression but linear
regression is used for solving
regression problems where we predict
continuous values whereas logistic
regression is used for solving
classification problems where we have
had to predict discrete values the
response variables in case of linear
regression are continuous in nature
whereas here they are categorical or
discrete in nature and um linear
regression helps to estimate the
dependent variable when there is a
change in the the independent variable
whereas here in case of logistic
regression it helps to calculate the
probability or the possibility of a
particular event happening and linear
regression as the name suggests is a
straight line that's why it's called
linear regression whereas logistic
regression is a sigmoid function and the
curve is the shape of the curve is s
it's an s-shaped curve this is another
example of application of logistic
regression in weather prediction whether
it's going to rain or not rain now keep
in mind both are used in weather
prediction if we want to find the
discrete values like whether it's going
to rain or not rain that is a
classification problem we use logistic
regression but if we want to determine
what is going to be the temperature
tomorrow then we use linear regression
so just keep in mind that in weather
prediction we actually use both but
these are some examples of logistic
regression so we want to find out
whether it's going to be rain or not
it's going to be sunny or not whe it's
going to snow or or not these are all
logistic regression examples a few more
examples classification of objects this
is a again another example of logistic
regression now here of course one
distinction is that these are multiclass
classification so logistic regression is
not used in its original form but it is
used in a slightly different form so we
say whether it is a dog or not a dog I
hope you understand so instead of saying
is it a dog or a cat or elephant we
convert this into saying so because we
need to keep it to Binary classification
so we say is it a dog or not a dog is it
a cat or not a cat so that's the way
logistic regression can be used for
classifying objects otherwise there are
other techniques which can be used for
performing multiclass classification in
healthcare logistic regression is used
to find the survival rate of a patient
so they take multiple parameters like
traumas scope and age and so on and so
forth and they try to predict the rate
of survival all right now finally let's
take an example and see how we can apply
logistic regression to predict the
number that is shown in the image so
this is actually a live demo I will take
you into Jupiter notebook and um show
the code but before that let me take you
through a couple of slides to explain
what we're trying to do so let's say you
have an 8x8 image and the the image has
a number 1 2 3 4 and you need to train
your model to predict what this number
is so how do we do this so the first
thing is obviously in any machine
learning process you train your model so
in this case we are using logistic
regression so and then we provide a
training set to train the model and then
we test how accurate our model is with
the test data which means that like any
machine learning process we split our
initial data into two parts training set
and test set with the training set we
train our model and then with the test
set we we test the model till we get
good accuracy and then we use it for for
inference right so that is typical
methodology of uh uh training testing
and then deploying of machine learning
models so let's uh take a look at the
code and uh see what we are doing so
I'll not go line by line but just take
you through some of the blocks so first
thing we do is import all the libraries
and then and we basically take a look at
the images and see what is the total
number of images we can display using
mat plot lip some of the images or a
sample of these images and um then we
split the data into training and test as
I mentioned earlier and we can do some
exploratory analysis and uh then we
build our model we train our model with
the training set and then we test it
with our test set and find out how
accurate our model is us using the
confusion Matrix the heat map and use
heat map for visualizing this and I will
show you in the code what exactly is the
confusion Matrix and how it can be used
for finding the accuracy in our example
we got we get an accuracy of about .94
which is pretty good or 94% which is
pretty good all right so what is the
confusion Matrix this is an example of a
confusion Matrix and uh this is used for
identifying the accuracy of a
uh classification model or like a
logistic regression model so the most
important part in a confusion Matrix is
that first of all this as you can see
this is a matrix and the size of the
Matrix depends on how many outputs uh we
are expecting right so the the most
important part here is that the model
will be most accurate when we have the
maximum numbers in its diagonal like in
this case that's why it has almost 93
94% because because the diagonals should
have the maximum numbers and the others
other than diagonals the cells other
than the diagonals should have very few
numbers so here that's what is happening
so there is a two here there are there's
a one here but most of them are along
the diagonal this what does this mean
this means that the number that has been
fed is zero and the number that has been
detected is also zero so the predicted
value and the actual value are the same
so along the diagonals that is true
which means that let's let's take this
diagonal right if if the maximum number
is here that means that like here in
this case it is 34 which means that 34
of the images that have been fed or
rather actually there are two
misclassifications in there so 36 images
have been fed which have number four and
out of which 34 have been predicted
correctly as number four and one has
been predicted as number eight and
another one has been predicted as number
nine so these are two
misclassifications okay so that is the
meaning of saying that the maximum
number should be in the diagonal so if
you have all of them so for an ideal
model which has let's say 100% accuracy
everything will be only in the diagonal
there will be no numbers other than zero
in all other cells so that is like 100%
accurate model okay so that's uh gist of
how to use this Matrix how to use the
this confusion Matrix I know the name is
a little funny sounding confusion Matrix
but actually it is not very confusing
it's very straightforward so you are
just plotting what has been predicted
and what is the labeled information or
what is the actual data that's also
known as the ground truth sometimes okay
these are some fancy terms that are used
so predicted label and actual label
that's all it is okay yeah so we are
showing a little bit more information
here so 38 have been predicted and here
you will see that that all of them have
been predicted correctly there have been
38 zeros and the the predicted value and
the actual value is is exactly the same
whereas in this case right it has uh
there are I think 37 + 5 yeah 42 have
been fed the images 42 images are of
Digit three and uh the accuracy is only
37 of them have been accurately
predicted three of them have been
predicted as number seven and two of
them have predicted as number eight and
so on and so forth okay all right so
with that let's go into Jupiter notebook
and see how the code looks so this is
the code in in Jupiter notebook for
logistic regression in this particular
demo what we are going to do is train
our model to recognize digits which are
the images which have digits from let's
say 0 to 5 or 0 to 9 and um and then
then we will see how well it is trained
and whether it is able to predict these
numbers correctly or not so let's get
started so the first part is as usual we
are importing some libraries that are
required and uh then the last line in
this block is to load the digits so
let's go ahead and run this code then
here we will visualize the shape of
these uh digits so we can see here if we
take a look this is how the shape is
17797 by 64 these are like 8 by 8 images
so that's that's what is reflected in
this shape now from here onwards we are
basically once again importing some of
the libraries that are required like
numpy and map plot and we will take a
look at uh some of the sample images
that we have loaded so this one for
example creates a figure uh and then we
go ahead and take a few sample images to
see how they look so let me run this
code and so that it becomes easy to
understand so these are about five
images sample images that we are looking
at 0 1 2 3 4 so this is how the images
this is how the data is okay and uh
based on this we will actually train our
logistic regression model and then we
will test it and see how well it is able
to recognize so the way it works is the
pixel information so as you can see here
this is an 8 by 8 pixel kind of a image
and uh the each pixel whether it is
activated or not activated that is the
information available for each pixel now
based on the pattern of this activation
and non-activation of the various pixels
this will be identified as a zero for
example right similarly as you can see
so overall each of these numbers
actually has a different pattern of the
the pixel activation and that's pretty
much that our model needs to learn for
which number what is the pattern of the
activation of the pixels right so that
is what we are going to train our model
okay so the first thing we need to do is
to split our data into training and test
data set right so whenever we perform
any training we split the data into
training and test so that the training
data set is used to train the system so
we pass this probably multiple times uh
and then we test it with the test data
set and the split is usually in the form
of there and there are various ways in
which you can split this data it is up
to the individual preferences in our
case here we are splitting in the form
of 23 and 77 so when we say test size as
20 23 that means 23% of the entire data
is used for testing and the remaining
meaning 77% is used for training so
there is a readily available function
which is uh called train test split so
we don't have to write any special code
for the splitting it will automatically
split the data based on the proportion
that we give here which is test size so
we just give the test size automatically
training size will be determined and uh
we pass the data that we want to split
and the the results will be stored in
xcore train and Yore train for the
training data set and what is xcore
train this are these are the features
right which is like the independent
variable and Yore train is the label
right so in this case what happens is we
have the input value which is or the
features value which is in xor train and
since this is labeled data for each of
them each of the observations we already
have the label information saying
whether this digit is a zero or a one or
a two so that this this is what will be
used for comparison to find out whether
the the system is able to recognize it
correctly or there is an error for each
observation it will compare with this
right so this is the label so the same
way xcore train Yore train is for the
training data set xcore test Yore test
is for the test data set okay so let me
go ahead and execute this code as well
and then we can go and check quickly
what is the how many entries are there
and in each of this so xcore train the
shape is 13 83 by 64 and Yore train has
1383 because there is uh nothing like
the second part is not required here and
then xcore test shape we see is 414 so
actually there are 414 observations in
test and 1383 observations in train so
that's basically what these four lines
of code are are are saying okay then we
import the logistic regression library
and uh which is a part of psychic learn
so we we don't have to implement the
logistic regression process itself we
just call these the function and uh let
me go ahead and execute that so that uh
we have the logistic regression Library
imported now we create an instance of
logistic regression right so logistic RR
is a is an instance of logistic Reg
ression and then we use that for
training our model so let me first
execute this code so these two lines so
the first line basically creates an
instance of logistic regression model
and then the second line is where we are
passing our data the training data set
right this is our the the predictors and
uh this is our Target we are passing
this data set to train our model all
right so once we do this in this case
the data is not large but by and large
uh the training is what takes usually a
lot of time so we spend in machine
learning activities in machine learning
projects we spend a lot of time for the
training part of it okay so here the
data set is relatively small so it was
pretty quick so all right so now our
model has been trained using the
training data set and uh we want to see
how accurate this is so what we'll do is
we will test it out in probably faces so
let me first try out how well this is
working for uh one image okay I will
just try it out with one image my the
first entry in my test data set and see
whether it is uh correctly predicting or
not so and in order to test it so for
training purpose we use the fit method
there is a method called fit which is
for training the model and once the
training is done if you want to test for
uh a particular value new input you use
the predict method Okay so so let's run
the predict method and we pass this
particular image and uh we see that the
shape is or the prediction is four so
let's try a few more let me see for the
next 10 uh seems to be fine so let me
just go ahead and test the entire data
set okay that's basically what we will
do so now we want to find out how
accurately this has um performed so we
use the score method to find what is the
percent
of accuracy and we see here that it has
performed up to 94% Accurate okay so
that's on this part now what we can also
do is we can um also see this accuracy
using what is known as a confusion
Matrix so let us go ahead and try that
as well uh so that we can also visualize
how well uh this model has uh done so
let me execute this piece of code which
will basically import some of the
libraries that are required and um we we
basically create a confusion Matrix an
instance of confusion matrix by running
confusion Matrix and passing these uh
values so we have so this confusion
underscore Matrix method takes two
parameters one is the Yore test and the
other is the prediction so what is the
Yore test these are the labeled values
which we already know for the test data
set and predictions are what the system
has predicted for the test data set okay
so this is known to us and this is what
the system has uh the model has
generated so we kind of create the
confusion Matrix and we will print it
and this is how the confusion Matrix
looks as the name suggests it is a
matrix and um the key point out here is
that the accuracy of the model is
determined by how many numbers are there
in the diagonal the more the numbers in
the diagonal the better the accuracy is
okay and first of all the total sum of
all the numbers in this whole Matrix is
equal to the number of observations in
the test data set that is the first
thing right so if you add up all these
numbers that will be equal to the number
of observations in the test data set and
then out of that the maximum number of
them should be in the diagonal that
means the accuracy is pretty good if the
the number in the diagonal are less and
in all other places there are a lot of
numbers which means the accuracy is very
low the diagonal indicates a correct
prediction that this means that the
actual value is same as the predicted
value here again actual value is same as
the predicted value and so on right so
the moment you see a number here that
means the actual value is something and
the predicted value is something else
right similarly here the actual value is
something and the predicted value is
something else so that is basically how
we read the confusion Matrix now how do
we find the accuracy you can actually
add up the total values in the diagonal
so it's like 38 + 44 Plus 43 and so on
and divide that by the total number of
test observations that will give you the
percentage accuracy using a confusion
Matrix now let us visualize this
confusion Matrix in a slightly more
sophisticated way uh using a heat map so
we will create a heat map with some
we'll add some colors as well it's uh
it's like a more visually visually more
appealing so that's the whole idea so if
we let me run this piece of code and
this is how the heat map looks uh and as
you can see here the diagonals again are
are all the values are here most of the
values so which means reasonably this
seems to be reasonably accurate and yeah
basically the accuracy score is 94% this
is calculated as I mentioned by adding
all these numbers divided by the total
test values or the total number of
observations in test data set okay so
this is the confusion Matrix for
logistic
regression all right so now that we have
seen the confusion Matrix let's take a
quick sample and see how well uh the
system has classified and we will take a
few examples of the data so if we see
here we we picked up randomly a few of
them so this is uh number four which is
the actual value and also the predicted
value both are four this is an image of
zero so the predicted value is also zero
actual value is of course zero then this
is the image of nine so this is also
been predicted correctly nine and actual
value is nine and this is the image of
one and again this has been predicted
correctly as like the actual value okay
so this this was a quick demo of
logistic regression how to use logistic
regression to identify images Okay so
let's summarize what we have learned in
this video we discussed about what is
logistic regression and how it fits into
the overall machine learning we
discussed about the different types of
machine learning and how logistic
regression is one of the algorithms for
classification and then we compared
logistic regression with linear
regression ression because the names may
be sounding similar but these are
completely different algorithms linear
regression is used for predicting
continuous values whereas logistic
regression is used for finding discrete
values and then we talked about the math
behind logistic regression and we
derived that function as well the
sigmoid function we did a quick table
comparison between linear and logistic
regression we saw some examples of
day-to-day life how logistic regression
is used for some of the class for
solving some of the classification
problems and then in the end we looked
at the code to see how we can Implement
logistic regression to train the module
to identify images there's all kinds of
regression models that come out of this
so we put them side to about side we
have our linear regression which is a
predictive number used to predict a
dependent output variable based on
Independent input variable accuracy is a
measured uh using least Square
estimation so that's where you take uh
you could also use absolute value uh the
least squares is more popular there's
reasons for that mathematically and also
for computer
runtime uh but it does give you an an
accuracy based on the the least Square
estimation the best fit line is a
straight line and clearly that's not
always used in all the regression models
there's a lot of variations on that the
output is a predicted integer value
again this is what we're talking about
we're talking about linear regression
and we're talking about regression it
means the numers coming out linear
usually means we're looking for that
line versus a different model and it's
used in business domain forecasting
stocks uh it's used as a basis of of
most um uh predictions with numbers so
if you're looking at a lot of numbers
you're probably looking at uh a linear
regression
model uh for instance if you do just the
high lows of the stock exchange and
you're you're going to take a lot more
of that if you want to make money off
the stock you'll find that the linear
regression model fits uh probably better
than almost any of the other models even
you know highend neural networks and all
these other different machine learning
and AI models because they're numbers
they're just a straight set of numbers
you have a high value a low value volume
uh that kind of thing so when you're
looking at something that straight
numbers um and are connected in that way
usually you're talking about a linear
regression model and that's where you
want to start a logistic regression
model used to classify dependent output
variable based on Independent input
variable so just like the linear
regression model and like all of our
machine learning tools you have your
features coming in uh and so in this
case you might have uh label you know an
image or something like that is is
probably the very popular thing right
now labeling broccoli and vegetables or
whatever accuracy is measured using
maximum likelihood estimation the best
fit is given by a curve and we saw that
um we're talking about linear regression
you definitely are talking about a
straight line although there is other
regression models that don't use
straight lines and usually when you're
looking at a logistic regression the
math as you saw was still kind of a
ukian line but it's now got that sigmoid
activation which turns it into um a
heavily weighted curve and the output is
a binary value between 0o and one and
it's used for for classification image
processing as I mentioned is is what
people usually think of um although they
use it for classification of um like a
window of things so you could take a
window of stock history and you could CL
generate classifications based on that
and separate the data that way if it's
going to be that this particular pattern
occurs it's going to be upward trending
or downward
trending in fact a number of stock uh uh
Traders
use that not to tell them how much to
bid or what to bid uh but they use it as
to whether it's worth looking at the
stock or not whether the Stock's going
to go down or go up and it's just a0 one
do I care or do I even want to look at
it so let's do a demo so you can get a
picture of what this looks like in
Python code let's predict the price at
which insurance should be sold to a
particular customer based on their
medical history we will also classify on
a mushroom data set to find the
poisonous and nonpoisonous mushro
mushrooms and when you look at these two
datas the first one uh we're looking at
the price so the price is a number um so
let's predict the price which the
insurance should be sold to and the
second one is we're looking at either
it's poisonous or it's not poisonous so
first off before we begin the demo I'm
in the Anaconda Navigator in this one
I've loaded the python
3.6 and using the Jupiter notebook and
you can use jupyter notebook by itself
um you can use the Jupiter lab which
allows multiple tabs it's basically the
notebook with tabs on it uh but the
jupyter notebook is just fine and it'll
go into uh Google Chrome which is what
I'm using for my Internet Explorer and
from here we open up new and you'll see
Python 3 and again this is loaded with
python
3.6 and we're doing the linear versus
logic uh regression or logit you'll see
L git T um as one one of the one of the
names that kind of pops up when you do a
search on here uh but it is a logic
we're looking at the logistic regression
models and we'll start with the linear
regression uh because it's easy to
understand you draw a line through stuff
um and so in programming uh we got a lot
of stuff to unfold here in our in our uh
startup as we pre-load all of our
different
parts and let's go ahead and break this
up we have at the beginning
import uh pandas so this is our data
frame uh it's just a way of storing the
data think of a uh when you talk about
data frame think of a spreadsheet you
have rows and columns it's a nice way of
viewing the data and then we have uh
we're going to be bringing in our
pre-processing label en Co coder I'll
show you what that is um when we get
down to it it's easier to see in the
data uh but there's some data in here
like um sex it's male or female so it's
not like an actual number it's either
your one or the other that kind of stuff
ends up being encoded that's what this
label encoder is right here we have our
test split
model if you're going to build a model
uh you do not want to use all the data
you want to use some of the data and
then test it to see how good it is and
if it can't have seen the data you're
testing on until you're ready to test it
on there and see how good it is and then
we have our uh logistic regression model
our categorical one and then we have our
linear regression model these are the
two these right here let me just um um
clear all that there we go uh these two
right here are what this is all about
logistic versus uh linear is it
categorical are we looking for a true
false or are we looking for um a
specific
number and then finally um usually at
the very end we have to take and just
ask how accurate is our model did it
work um if you're trying to predict
something in this case we're going to be
doing um uh Insurance costs uh how close
to the insurance cost does it measure
that we expect it to be you know if
you're an insurance company you don't
want to promise to pay everybody's
medical bill and not be able
to and in the case of the mushrooms you
probably want to know just how much at
risk you are for following this model uh
to far as whether going to get to eat a
poisonous mushroom and die or
not um so we'll look at both of those
and we'll get talk a little bit more
about the shortcomings and the um uh
value of these different processes so
let's go ahead and run this this is
loaded the data set on here and then
because we're in Jupiter notebook I
don't have to put the print on there we
just do data set and by and it prints
out all the different data on here and
you can see here for our insurance
because that's what we're starting with
uh we're loading that with our pandas
and it prints it in a nice format where
you can see the age sex uh body mass
index number of children smoker so this
might be something that the insurance
company gets from the doctor it says hey
we're going to this is what we need to
know to give you a quote for what we're
going to charge you for your
insurance and you can see that it has uh
1,338 rows and seven columns you can
count the columns 1 two 3 four five six
seven so there's seven columns on here
and the column we're really interested
in is charges um I want to know what the
charges are going to be what can I
expect not a very good Arrow drawn um
what to expect them to charge on there
uh so is this going to be you know is
this person going to cost me uh
$16,814.23
how do we guess that so that we can
guess what the minimal charge is for
their
insurance and then there's one other
thing you really need to notice on this
data um and I mentioned it before but
I'm going to mention it again because
pre-processing data is so much of the
work in data science um sex well how do
you how do you deal with female versus
male um are you a smoker yes or no what
does that mean Reg
how do you look at Region it's not a
number how do you draw a line between
Southwest and
Northwest um you know they they're
objects it's either you're Southwest or
you're Northwest it's not like I'm
southwest I guess you could do longitude
and latitude but the data doesn't come
in like that it comes in as true false
or whatever you know it's either your
Southwest or your
Northwest so we need to do a little bit
of pre-processing of the data on here to
make this
work oops there we go okay so let's take
a look and see what we're doing with
pre-processing and again this is really
where you spend a lot of time with data
Sciences trying to understand how and
why you need to do that and so we're
going to do uh you'll see right up
here label uh and then we're going to do
the do a label encoder one of the
modules we brought in so this is SK
learns uh label
encoder I like the fact that it's all
pretty much automated uh but if you're
doing a lot of work with encoder you
should start to understand how that
fits um and then we have uh label. fit
right here where we're going to go ahead
and do the data set uh. se. drop
duplicates and then for data set sex
we're going to do the label transform
the data set sex and so we're looking
right here at um male or female and so
it usually just converts it to a01
because there's only two choices on here
same thing with the smoker it's zero or
one so we're going to transfer the trans
change the smoker uh 01 on this and then
finally we did region down here region
does it a little bit different we'll
take a look at that and um it's I think
in this case it's probably going to do
it because we did it on this label
transform um with this particular setup
it gives each region a number like 0 1 2
3 so let's go ahe and take a look and
see what that looks like go and run
this and you can see that our new data
set um has age that's still a number uh
Sex Is Zero or one uh so zero is female
one is male number of children we left
that alone uh smoker one or zero it says
no or yes on there we actually just do
one for no zero or no yeah one for no
I'm not sure how it organized them but
it turns the smoker into zero or one yes
or no uh and then region it did this as
uh 0 one two three so it's three
regions now a lot of times in in when
you're working with data science and
you're dealing with uh regions or even
word
analysis um instead of doing one column
and labeling it 0 one two three a lot of
times you increase your features and so
you would have region Northwest would be
one column yes or no region Southwest
would be one column yes or no true zero
one uh but for this this this particular
setup this will work just fine on here
now that we spend all that time getting
it set up uh here's the fun part uh
here's the part where we're actually
using our setup on this and you'll see
right here we have our um y linear
regression uh data set drop the charges
because that's what we want to
predict and so our X I'm sorry our X
linear data set drop the charges because
that's where we're going to predict
we're predicting charges right here so
so we don't want that as our input for
our features and our y output is charges
that's what we want to guess we want to
guess what the charges
are and then what we talked about
earlier is we don't want to do all the
data at once so we're going to take
um3 means 30% we're going to take 30% of
our data and it's going to be as the
train as the testing site so here's our
y test and our X test down there um and
so that part our model will never see it
until we're ready to test to see how
good it is and then of course right here
you'll see our um training set and this
is what we're going to train it we're
going to trade it on 70% of the data and
then finally the big ones uh this is
where all the magic happens this is
where we're going to create our magic
setup and that is right here our linear
model we're going to set it equal to the
linear regression model and then we're
going to fit the data on here
and then at this point I always like to
pull up um if you if you if you're
working with a new models good to see
where it comes from and this comes from
the pyit uh learn and this is the
sklearn linear model linear regression
that we imported earlier and you can see
they have different parameters the basic
parameter works great if you're dealing
with just numbers uh mentioned that
earlier with stock high lows this model
will do as good as any other model model
out there for do if you're doing just
the very basic high lows and looking for
a linear fit a regression model fit um
and what you one of the things when I
looking at this is I look for
methods and you'll see here's our fit
that we're using right now and here's
our
predict and we'll actually do a little
bit in the middle here as far as looking
at some of the parameters hidden behind
it the math that we talked about
earlier and so we go in this and we go
ahead and run run this you'll see it
loads the linear regression model and
just has a nice output that says hey I
loaded the linear regression model and
then the second part is we did the fit
and so this model is now trained our
linear model is now trained on the
training
data and so one of the things we can
look at is the um um for idx and colon
name and enumerate X linear train
columns kind of an interesting thing
this prints out the coefficient
uh so when you're looking at the back
end of the data you remember we had that
formula uh BX X1 plus bxx2 plus the plus
the uh intercept uh and so forth these
are the actual coefficients that are in
here this is what it's actually
multiplying these numbers
by and you can see like region gets a
minus value so when it adds it up I
guess a region you can read a lot into
these numbers uh it gets very
complicated there's ways to mess with
them if you're doing a basic linear
regression model you usually don't look
at them too closely uh but you might
start looking in these and saying hey
you know what uh smoker look how smoker
impacts the cost um it's just massive uh
so this is a flag that hey the value of
the smoker really affects this model and
then you can see here with a body mass
index uh so somebody who is overweight
is probably less healthy and more like
to have cost money and then of course
age is a factor um and then you can see
down here we have uh sex is than a
factor also and it just it changes as
you go in there negative number it
probably has its own meaning on there
again it gets really complicated when
you dig into the um workings and how the
linear model works on that and so um we
can also look at the intercept this is
just kind of fun um so it starts at this
negative number and then adds all these
numbers to it that's all that means
that's our intercept on there and that
fits the data we have on that and so you
can see right here we can go back
and oops give me just a second there we
go we can go ahead and predict the
unknown data and we can print that out
and if you're going to create a model to
predict something uh we'll go ahead and
predict it here's our y prediction value
linear model
predict and then we'll go ahead and
create a new data frame in this case
from our X linear your test group we'll
go ahead and put the cost back into this
data frame and then the predicted cost
we're going to make that equal to our y
prediction and so when we pull this up
uh you can see here that we have uh the
actual cost and what we predicted the
cost is going to
be there's a lot of ways to measure the
accuracy on there uh but we're going to
go ahead and jump into our mushroom
data and so in this you can see here we
we've run our basic model we built our
coefficients you can see the intercept
the back end you can see how we're
generating a number here uh now with
mushrooms we want to yes or no we want
to know whether we can eat them or not
and so here's our mushroom file we're
going to go and run this take a look at
the data and again you can ask for a
copy of this file uh send a note over to
Simply
learn.com and you can see here that we
have a class um the cap shape cap
surface and so forth so there's a lot of
feature in fact there's 23 different
columns in here going
across and when you look at this um I'm
not even sure what these particular like
PE PE I don't even know what the class
is on
this I'm going to guess by the notes
that the class is uh poisonous or
edible so if you remember before we had
to do a little precoding on our data uh
same thing with with here uh we have our
cap shape which is b or X or k um we
have cap color uh these really aren't
numbers so it's really hard to do
anything with just a a single number so
we need to go ahead and turn those into
a label encoder which again there's a
lot of different encoders uh with this
particular label encoder it's just
switching it to 0 1 2 3 and giving it an
integer
value in fact if you look at all the
columns all of our columns are labels
and so we're just going to go ahead and
uh loop through all the columns in the
data and we're going to transform it
into a um label encoder and so when we
run this you can see how this gets
shifted from uh xbxx K to 0 1 2 3 4 5 or
whatever it is class is
01 one being poisonous zero looks like
it's
editable and so forth on here so we're
we're just encoding it if you were doing
this project depending on the results
you might encode it differently like I
mentioned earlier you might actually
increase the number of features as
opposed to laboring at 0 1 2 3 4 five um
in this particular example it's not
going to make that big of a difference
how we encode
it and then of course we're looking for
uh the class whether it's poisonous or
edible so we're going to drop the class
in our x uh Logistics model and we're
going to create our y Logistics model is
based on that class so here's our
XY and just like we did before we're
going to go ahead and split it uh using
30% for
test 70% to program the model on
here and that's right here whoops there
we go there's our U train and
test and then you'll see here on the
this next setup um this is where we
create our model all the magic happens
right here uh we go ahead and create a
logistics model I've up the max
iterations if you don't change this for
this particular problem you'll get a
warning that says this has not
converged um because then that that's
what it does is it goes through the math
and it goes hey can we minimize the
error and it keeps finding a lower and
lower error and it still is changing
that number so that means it hasn't
conversed yet it hasn't find the lowest
amount of error it can and the default
is 100 uh there's a lot of settings in
here so when we go in here to let me
pull that up from the sklearn uh so we
pull that up from the sklearn
model you can see here we have our
logistic it has our different settings
on here that you can mess with most of
these work pretty solid on this
particular setup so you don't usually
mess a lot usually I find myself
adjusting the um iteration and it'll get
that warning and then increase the
iteration on there and just like the
other model you can go just like you did
with the other model we can scroll down
here and look for our
methods and you can see there's a lot of
methods uh available on here and
certainly there's a lot of different
things you can do with it uh but the
most basic thing we do is we fit our
model make sure it's set right uh and
then we actually predict something with
it so those are the two main things
we're going to be looking at on this
model is fitting and predicting there's
a lot of cool things you can do that are
more advanced uh but for the most part
these are the two which um I use when
I'm going into one of these models and
setting them
up so let's go ahead and close out of
our sklearn setup on there and we'll go
ahead and run this and you can see here
it's now loaded this up there we now
have a uh uh logistic model and we've
gotone ahead and done a predict here
also just like I was showing you earlier
uh so here is where we actually
predicting the dat data so we we've done
our first two lines of code as we create
the model we fit the model to our
training data and then we go ahead and
predict for our test data now in the
previous model we didn't dive into the
test score uh I think I just showed you
a graph and we can go in there and
there's a lot of tools to do this we're
going to look at the uh model score on
this one and let me just go ahead and
run the model
score and it says that it's pretty
accurate we're getting a roughly 95%
accuracy well that's good one 95%
accuracy 95% accuracy might be good for
a lot of
things but when you look at something as
far as whether you're going to pick a
mushroom on the side of the trail and
eat it we might want to look at the
confusion Matrix and for that we're
going to put in our y listic test the
actual values of edible and unedible and
we're going to put in our prediction
value and if you remember on here U
let's see I believe it's poisonous was
one uh zero is edible so let's go ahead
and run that 01 zero is good so here is
um a confusion Matrix and this is if
you're not familiar with these we have
true true true
false true false false false so it says
out of the edible mushrooms we correctly
labeled 121 mushrooms edible that were
edible
and we correctly measured
1,113 poisonous mushrooms as
poisonous but here's the
kicker I labeled uh 56 edible mushrooms
as being um poisonous well that's not
too big of a deal we just don't eat them
but I measured 68 mushrooms as being
edible that were poisonous so probably
not the best choice to use this model to
predict ICT whether you're going to eat
a mushroom or not and you'd want to dig
a Little Deeper before you U start e
picking mushrooms off the side of the
trail so a little warning there when
you're looking at any of these data
models looking at the error and how that
error fits in with what domain you're in
domain in this case being edible
mushrooms uh be a little careful make
sure that you're looking at them
correctly so we've looked at uh edible
or not edible we've looked at uh
regression model as far as um the end
values what's going to be the cost and
what our predicted cost is so we can
start figuring out how much to charge
these people for their
insurance and so these really are the
fundamentals of data science when you
pull them together uh when I say data
science talking about your machine
learning
code and hopefully you got a
classification is probably one of the
most widely used tools in machine
learning in today's world it is also one
of the simpler versions to start a
understanding how a lot of machine
Learning Works we're going to start by
taking a look at what exactly is
classification the important
terminologies around classification
we'll look at some real world
applications my favorite popular
classification algorithms and there are
a lot out there so we're only going to
touch briefly on a variety of them so
you can see how they the different
flavors work and we'll have some
Hands-On Demos in Python embedded
throughout the tutorial classification
classific ation is a task that requires
the use of machine learning algorithms
to learn how to assign a class label to
a given data you can see in this diagram
we have our unclassified data it goes
through a classification algorithms and
then you have classified data it's hard
to just see it as data and that really
is where you kind of start and where you
end when you start running these um
machine learning algorithms and
classification and the classification
algorithms is a little black box in a
lot of respects and we'll look into that
you can see what I'm talking about when
we start swapping in and out different
models let's say we are given the task
of classifying a given bunch of fruits
and vegetables on the basis of their
category I.E fruits are to be grouped
together and vegetables are to be
grouped together and so we have a data
set we'll call it the bunch is divided
into clusters one of which consists of
the fruits while the other has the
vegetables you can actually look at this
as any kind of data when we talk about
breast answer can we sort out in images
to see what is malignant what is benign
very popular one can you classify
flowers the iris uh data set uh
certainly in Wildlife can you classify
different animals and track where
they're going classification is really
the bottom starting point or the
Baseline for a lot of machine learning
and setting it up and trying to figure
out how we're going to break the data up
so we can use it in a way that is
beneficial so here the fruits and the
vegetables are are grouped into clusters
and each clusters has a specific
characteristic I.E whether they are a
fruit or a vegetable and you can see we
have a pile of fruits and vegetables we
feed it into the algorithm and the
algorithm separates them out and you
have fruits and vegetables so some
important terminologies before we dig
into how it sorts them out and what that
all means uh when we look at the
terminologies you have a classifier
that's the algorithm that is used to map
the input data to a specific category
the classification model the model that
predicts or draws a class to the input
data given for training feature it is an
individual measurable property of the
phenomena being observed and labels the
characteristics on which the data points
of a data set are categorized the
classifier and the classification model
go together a lot of times the
classifier is part of the classification
model um and then you choose which
classifier you use after you choose
which model you're using where features
are what goes in labels are what comes
out so your classifier models right in
the middle of that that's that little
black box we were just talking about
clusters they are a group of data points
which have some common characteristics
binary classification it is a
classification condition with two
outcomes which are either true or false
multi-label classification this is a
classification condition where each
sample is assigned to a set of labels or
targets multiclass classification the
classification with more than two
classes here each sample is assigned to
one and only one label when we look at
this group of terminologies a few
important things to notice uh going from
the top clusters when we cluster data
together we don't necessarily have to
have an end goal we just want to know
what features cluster together these
features then are mapped to the outcome
we want in many cases the first step
might not even care about the outcome
only about what data connects with other
data and there's a lot of clustering
algorithms out there that do just the
clustering part binary classification it
is a classification condition with two
outcomes which are either true or false
we're talking usually um it's a uh it's
either a cat or it's not a cat it's
either a dog or it's not a dog um that's
the kind of thing we talk about binary
classification and then that goes into
multi-label classification think of
label you can have an object that is
brown you can have an object that is
labeled as a dog so it has a number of
different labels that's very different
than a multiclass classification where
each one's a binary uh you can either be
a cat or a dog you can't be both a cat
and a dog real world applications so to
make sense of this uh of course the
challenge is always in the details is to
understand how we apply this in the real
world so in real world applications we
use this all the time we have email spam
classifier so you have your uh email
inbox coming in uh it goes through the
email filter that we usually don't see
in the background and it goes this is
either valid email or it's a Spam and it
puts it in the spam filter if that's
what it thinks it is uh Alexa's voice
classifier Google Voice any of the voice
classifiers they're looking for points
so they try to group words together and
then they try to find those groups of
words trigger a class classifier so it
might be that the classifier is to open
your tasks program or open your
program so you can start sending a text
sentimental sentiment analysis is really
big uh when we're tracking products
we're tracking marketing trying to
understand uh whether something is liked
or disliked is huge uh that's like one
of the biggest driving forces in sales
nowadays and you almost have to have
these different filters going on if
you're running a large business of any
kind fraud detection uh you can think of
banks uh they find different things on
your bank statement and they detect that
there's something going on there they
have algorithms for tracking the logs on
computers they start finding weird logs
on computers they might find a hacker I
mention the cat and dog so here's our
image classification we have a neighbor
who runs an outdoor webcam and we like
to have it come up with a classification
when the wild animals in our area are
out like foxes we actually have a
mountain lion that lives in the area so
it's nice to know when he's here
handwriting prediction uh classifying A
B C D and then classifying words to go
with that so let's go ahead and uh roll
our sleeves up and take a look at some
popular classification algorithms before
we look at the algorithms uh let's go
back and take a look at our definitions
we have a classifier and a
classification model so we're looking at
the classifier an algorithm that is used
to map the input data to a specific
category one of those algorithms is a
logistic regression the logistic
regression is a classification algorithm
used to model the probability of a
certain class or event exist existing
such as pass fail or win lose Etc it
provides its output using the logistic
function or sigmoid function to return
the probability value that can then be
mapped to two or more discret classes a
sigmoid function is an activation
function that fits the variable and
limit the output to a range between zero
and one a standard sigmoid function or
logistic function is represented by the
formula FX = 1 / 1 + e- x where X is the
equation of the line and E is the
exponential just taking a quick look at
this um you can think of this as being a
point of uncertainty and so as we get
closer and closer to the middle of the
line it's either um activated or not and
we want to make that just shoot way up
uh so you'll see a lot of the activation
formulas kind of have this nice scurb
where it approaches one and approaches
zero and based on that there's only a
small region of a error and so you can
see in the sigmoid logistic function uh
the 1 over 1+ e- X to the- X you can see
it fames that that nice s curb uh we
also can use a tangent variation there's
a lot of other different uh models here
as far as the actual algorithm this is
the most commonly used one let's go
ahead and roll up our sleeves and take a
look at a demo that is going to use a
logistic regression so we're going to
have the activation formula and the
model because you have to have you have
to have both for this we will go into
our Jupiter notebook now I personally
use the Anaconda navigator to open up
the Jupiter notebook to set up my IDE as
a webbased it's got some advantages that
it's very easy to display in uh but it
also has some disadvantages in that if
you're trying to do multi- threads and
multi-processing you start running into
a single git issues with python and then
I jump to uh py charm really depends on
whatever ID you want just make sure
you've installed installed uh numpy and
the sklearn modules into your Python and
whatever environment you're working in
so that you'll have access to that for
this demo now the team in the back has
prepared my code for me which I'll start
bringing in one section at a time so we
can go through it before we do that it's
always nice to actually see where this
information is coming from and what
we're working with uh so the first part
is we're going to import our packages
which you need to install into your
Python and that's going to be your numpy
uh we usually use nump as NP and then
from sklearn the learn model we're going
to use a logistic regression and from
sklearn metrix we're going to import the
classification report confusion Matrix
and if we go ahead and open up S uh the
scikit-learn org and go under their API
you can see all the different um
features and models they have and we're
looking at the linear model uh logistic
regression one of the more common
classifiers out there and if we go ahead
and go into that and dig a Little Deeper
you'll see here where they have the
different settings and it even says
right here note the regularization is
applied by default so by default that is
the activation formula being used now
we're not going to spend we might come
back to this look at some of the other
models it's always good to see what
you're working with but let's go ahead
and jump back in here and we have our
Imports we're going to go ahead and run
those uh so these are now available to
us as we go through our Jupiter notebook
script and they put together a little
piece of data for us this is simp simply
um going through uh 0 to one actually
let's go ahead and print this out over
here we'll go ahe and print X just so
you can see where it actually looking
for and when we run this you can see
that we have our X is 01 2 through 9 we
reshaped it the reason for this is just
looking for a row of data usually we
have multiple features we just have the
one feature which happens to be 0o
through nine and then we have our 10
answers right down here uh 0 1 0 0
1111111 you can bring in a a lot of
different data depending on what you're
working with uh you can make your own
you can instead of having this as just a
single you could actually have like
multiple features in here but we just
have the one feature for uh this
particular demo and this is really where
all the magic happens right here uh and
I told you it's like a black box that's
the part that is is is kind of hard to
follow and so if you look right here we
have our model we talked about the model
right there and then we went ahead and
set it for Library linear as I showed
you earlier that's actually default so
it's not that important uh random State
equals zero this stuff you don't worry
too much about and then with the S kit
learn you'll see the model fit this is
very common to S kit they use similar
stuff in a lot of other different
packages but you'll you'll see that
that's very common you have to fit your
data and that means we're just taking
the data and we're fitting our X right
here which is our features that's our X
and here's y these are the labels we're
looking for so before we were looking at
is it fraud is it not is it cat is it
not um that kind of thing and this is
looking at 01 we want to have a binary
setup on this and we'll go ahead and run
this uh you can see right here it just
tells us what we loaded it with as our
defaults and that this model has now
been created and we've now fit our data
to it and then comes the fun part you
work really hard to clean your data to
um bake it and cook it there's all kinds
of I don't know why they go with the
cooking ter terms as far as how we get
this data formatted then you go through
and you pick your model you pick your
solver and you have to test it to see
hey which one's going to be best and so
we want to go ahead and evaluate the
model and you do this is that once
you've figured out which one is going to
work the best for you you want to
evaluate it so you can compare it to
your last Model and you can either
update it to create a new one or maybe
change the um solver to something else I
mentioned tangent that's one of the
other common ones that's commonly used
with language for some reason the
tangent even though it looks almost to
me identical to the one we're using with
the sigmoid function uh it for some
reason it activates better with language
even though it's a very small shift in
the actual math behind it we already
looked at the um data early but we'll go
and look at it again just you can see we
look at we have our rows of zero one row
it only has one entity and we have our
output that matches these rows and these
do have to match you'll get an error if
you put in something with a different
shape so if you have um 10 rows of data
and nine answers it's going to give you
an error because you need to have 10
answers for it a lot of times you
separate this too when you're doing
larger models uh but for this we're just
going to take a quick look at that the
first thing we want to start looking at
is uh The Intercept one of the features
inside our linear regression model we'll
go ahead and run that and print it uh
you'll see here we have an intercept of
minus 1.51 6 and if we're going to look
at the uh intercept we should also look
at our um coefficients and if you run
that you'll see that we get a we get the
um our coefficient is the 7035 you can
just think of this as your eidan
geometry for very basic model like this
where it intercepts the Y at some point
and we have a coefficient multiplying by
it little more complicated in the back
end but that is the gist of this simple
model with just the one feature in there
and we'll go ahead and uh we'll reprint
the Y because I want to put them on top
of each other with the Y predict and so
these were the Y values we put in and
this is the Y predict we had coming out
and you can see yeah here we go uh
there's the Y actual and there's what
the prediction comes in uh now keep in
mind that we used the actual complete
data as part of our training uh that is
if you're doing a real model a big
stopper right there because you can't
really see how good it did unless you
split some data off to test it on this
is the first step is you want to see how
your model actually test on the data you
trained it with with and you can see
here there is this point right here
where it has it wrong and this point
right here where it also has it wrong
and it makes sense because we're going
our input is 0 1 0 through 9 and it has
to break it somewhere and this is where
the break is uh so it says this half the
data is going to be zero because that's
what it looked like to me if I was
looking at it without an algorithm and
this data is probably going to be one
and I I didn't I forgot to point this
out so let's go back up here I just kind
of glanced over this window here we did
a lot of stuff let's go back and and
just take a look at that what was done
here is we ran a prediction uh so this
is where our predict comes in is our
model. predict so we had a model fit we
created the model we programmed it to
give us the right answer uh now we go
ahead and predict what we think it's
going to be there's our model. predict
probability of X and then we have our y
predict which is very similar but this
is has to do more with the probability
numbers so if you remember down below we
had the setup where we're looking at uh
that sigmoid function that's what this
is returning and the Y predict is
returning a zero or a one and then we
have our um confusion Matrix we'll look
at that and we have our report which
just basically Compares our y to our y
predict which we just did it's kind of
nice as simple data so it's really easy
to see what we're doing that's what we
do use the simple data this can get
really complicated when you have a lot
of different features and things going
on and splits uh so here we go we've had
our I printed out our actual and our
prediction so this is the actual data
this is what the predict ran um and then
we'll go ahead and do we're going to
print out the confusion Matrix we were
just talking about that uh this is great
if you have a lot of data to look at but
you can see right here a confusion
Matrix says uh if you remember from the
confusion Matrix we have the two this is
two correct one two and uh it's been a
while since I looked at a a confusion
Matrix there's the two and then we have
this one which is our six that's where
the six comes from and then we have this
one which is the um one false this is
the two one so we have this one here and
this one here which is
misclassified this really depends on
what data you're working with as to what
your is important um you might be
looking at this model and if this model
this confusion Matrix comes up and says
that uh you
misclassified even one person as being
nonmalignant cancer that's a bad model
uh I wouldn't want that classification
I'd want this number to be zero I
wouldn't care if this false positive was
off by a little bit more long as I knew
that I was correct on the important
factor that I don't have cancer so you
can see that this confusion Matrix
really aims you in the right direction
of what you need to change in your model
how you need to adjust it uh and then
there's of course a report reports are
always nice um if you notice we
generated a report earlier we'll go and
just print the report up and you can
remember this is our report it's a
classification report why come a y
predict so we're just putting in our two
values basically what we did here
visually with our actual and our
predicted value and we'll go ahead and
run the report and you can see it has
the Precision uh the recall your F1
score your support uh translated into a
accuracy macro average and weighted
average so it has all the numbers a lot
of times
when working with um clients or with the
shareholders in the company this is
really where you start because it has a
lot of data and they can just kind of
stare at it and try to figure it out and
then you start bringing in like the
confusion Matrix I almost do this in
Reverse as to what they show I would
never show your shareholders The
Intercept of the coefficient that's for
your internal team only working on
machine language uh but the confusion
Matrix and the report are very important
those are the two things you really want
to be able to show on these uh and you
can see here we did a decent job of um
classifying the data managed to get a
significant portion of it correct uh we
had our was it accuracy here is a 080 F1
score uh that kind of thing so you know
it's a pretty accurate model of course
this is pretty goofy it's very simple
model and it's just splitting the model
between uh ones and zeros so that was
our demo of the um on logistic
regression on there let's go take a look
at K nearest neighbors uh this one is
another very highly used and important
algorithm to understand K nearest
neighbors is a simple algorithm which
stores all available cases and
classifies new cases based on the
similarity measure the K nearest
neighbor finds out the class of the new
data point by finding its nearest
neighbors if there are three data points
of Class A and two data points of Class
B near to the new data point then the KN
andn classifies the new data point as
Class A the K and K nearest neighbors is
the number of nearest neighbors we are
looking for I I.E if we say k equals 3
this means that we are looking for
nearest three neighbors of unclassified
data point usually we take the K value
between 3 to 10 as it leads to a better
result a smaller value of K means that
noise will have a bigger influence on
the result and a larger value of K makes
it computationally expensive hence the
data scientists prefer the range of K
between 3 and 10 when we talk about
noise you remember the data we just
looked at was 0 one 1 0 0 it had some
some values where cut it and said
everything to the right is a one
everything to the left is a zero but it
had some ones and zeros mixed in there
that's called noise that's what they're
talking about is there's some things
that are right in the middle in the
classification which makes it very hard
to classify so suppose we're trying to
find the class for a new Point indicated
by the red color and you can see it's
kind of right between the cat right
between the dogs let k equal three so we
are finding the three in in for the red
data point by looking at the plot on the
right we can see that the red data point
belongs to the class dogs as it has two
votes for class dog and one vote for
class cat and if you ask the question
well what are you measuring the distance
what is that distance um it could be the
measurements of the ears whether they're
pointed or flat floppy that might be one
of the features you're looking at is how
floppy the ears are um another one might
be the whiskers versus the nose um and
then you take those measurements and
using uh one of the most common things
in K means measurement is the ukian
geometry you can figure out the distance
between those points there's a lot of
different algorithms for that but you
can think about it that you do have to
have some kind of solid data to measure
and so we can conclude that the new data
point belongs to the class dog so let's
go ahead and see what this looks like in
code and do a demo on the K nearest
Neighbors in here and we'll go right
back into our Jupiter notebook and open
up a new um Python Programming script
page of course once we're in here we'll
want to look at the uh pyit learn um I
did just a quick search for SK neighbors
Ken neighbors classifier um this
actually is the older version 0 no 023
is the one we want and you'll see here
that we have all their defaults in
Neighbors equals 5 at defaults we were
talking about that between three and 10
there's different ways to weigh it
there's an algorithm based on it I
mentioned ukian geometry finding the
distance there's other algorithms for
figuring out what that distance is and
how to weight those uh and there's a lot
of other parameters you can adjust for
the most part the K means uh basic setup
is a good place to start and just let
the defaults go uh we might play with
some of those we'll see what the guys in
the back did and from here we're going
to import numpy we're going to use
pandas if you haven't been running
pandas pandas is our data frame which
sits on top of numpy uh data frames our
you know numpy is our number array
pandas is our data frame map plot
library because we're going to plot some
graphs everybody likes some pretty
pictures it makes it a lot easier to see
what's going on when you have a nice
display and that's also what the caborn
is in here in the uh setup that sits on
top of the map plot Library the ones we
really want to look at right here are
the what we're bringing in from sklearn
these ones right here uh so from sklearn
we're going to load I mentioned the
breast cancer that's a very popular one
because it has I believe it's 36
measurements so there's 36 features and
unless you're a expert you're not going
to know what any of those features
really mean you can sort of guess but
there special measurements they take of
when they take a image uh and of course
our confusion Matrix so that we can take
a look and see what the data looks like
and how good we did uh and and then we
have our knen neighbors classifier on
here uh and then I mentioned that uh
whenever you do training and testing you
want to split the data up you don't want
to train the data and then test it on
the same data that just tells you how
good your training model is it doesn't
tell you whether it actually works on
unknown data and so this just splits it
off so that we can train it and then we
can take a look at data we don't have in
there and see how good it did and we'll
go ahead and load our uh data so here's
our our setup on that oops there we go
so we're going to go ahead and load the
data up uh we have our x value and
that's going to come from our breast
cancer. data and column breast cancer
feature names so there's our actual um
all our different features we'll print
that out here in a second and then we
have our um mean area mean compactness
so I guess we're going to take the data
and we're only going to use a couple of
the column s this just makes it easier
to read um of course when you actually
were going to do this you'd want to use
all your columns and then we have our Y
and this is simply um whether it's
either malignant or B9 and then um we
want to go ahead and drop the first line
because that's how it came in on there
and we'll go ahead let's just take a
look at this a little closer here let's
go and run this real quick and just
because I like to see my data before I
run it we can look at this and we can
look at the original features remember
we're only going to use two features off
of here just to make it a little easier
to follow and here's the actual data and
you can see that this is just this
massive stream of data coming in here
it's going to just skip around because
there's so much in there to set up I
think there's like 500 if I remember
correctly and you can see here's all the
different measurements they take but we
don't we don't really need to see that
on here we're just going to take a look
at just the two columns and then also
our solution we'll go and just do a
quick uh print y on here so you can see
what the y looks like and it is simply
just
000000 you know B9 00001 so a one means
it's B9 zero means it's malignant uh is
what we're looking at on that and cut
that out of there the next stage is to
go ahead and split our data I mentioned
that earlier uh we'll just go ahead and
let them do the splitting forest for us
uh we have XT train X test y train y
test and so we go ahead and train test
split XY random State equals 1 makes it
nice and easy for us we'll go and run
that and so now we have our training and
our testing train means we're going to
use that to train the model and then
we're going to use the test to test to
see how good our model does and then
we'll go ahead and create our model
here's our KNN model the K Neighbors
classifier in Neighbors equals 5 the
metrics is ukian remember I talked about
ukian uh this is simply your c^2 = A2 +
B2 + U A2 = B2 + C + C squ plus d^2 and
then you take the square root of all
that that's what they're talking about
here it's just the length of the
hypotenuse of a triangle but you can
actually do that in multiple Dimensions
just like you do in two Dimensions with
a regular triangle and here we have our
fit this should start to look familiar
since we already did that in our last
example that's very standard for S uh s
kit and any other one although sometimes
the fit algorithms look a little bit
more complicated because they're doing
more things on there especially when you
get into neural networks uh and then you
have your K neighbors that just tells we
created a um a k neighbor setup they
kind of wanted us to reformat the Y but
it's not that big of a deal for this uh
and it comes out and shows you that
we're using the ukian uh metric for our
measurement so now we've created a model
here's our live model we fitted the data
to it we say hey here's our training
data uh let's go ahead and predict it so
we're going to take our y predict equals
KNN predict y test so this is data we
have not this model has not seen this
data and so we're going to create a
whole new set of data data off of there
now before we look at our prediction in
fact let's um I'm going to bring this
down and and put it back in here later
let's take a look at our X test data
versus the Y test what does it look like
and so we have our mean area we're going
to compare it to our mean compactness
we're going to go ahead and run that and
we can see here the data if you look at
this just eyeballing it let me put it in
here we have a lot of blue here and we
have a lot of orange here and so these
dots in the middle especially like this
one here and these here these are the
ones that are going to give us false
negatives and so we should expect this
is your noise this is where we're not
sure what it is and then B9 is in this
case is done in blue and malignant is
done in one uh so if you look at it
there's two points based on these
features which makes it really hard to
have a 100% where the 100% is down here
um or up here that's kind of the thing
I'd be looking for when we're talking
about cancer and stuff like that where
you really don't want any uh false
negatives you want everything you false
positive great you're going to go in
there and have another setup in there
where you might get a get a op Toops or
something like that done on it again
that's very data specific on here uh so
now let's go ahead and pull in and and
get our um our prediction in here and
we'll create our y prediction we'll go
and run that so now this is loaded with
what we think the unknown data is going
to B and we can go ahead and take that
and go ahead and plot it because it's
always nice to have some pretty pictures
and when we plot it we're going to do
the mean area versus mean compactness
again you look at this map and you can
see that there's some clear division
here we can clearly say on some of the
stuff that are why prediction if we look
at this map up here and this map down
here we probably got some pretty good
deal it looks pretty good like they
match a lot this is of course just
eyeballing it really you don't want to
eyeball these things you want to show
people the pictures so that they can see
it and you can say hey this is what it
looks like uh but we really want the
confusion Matrix and when we do the Y
test and the Y predict we can see in the
confusion Matrix here it did pretty good
um and we'll just go ahead and point
that out real quick um here's our 42
which is positive and our
79 and if I remember correctly I'd have
to look at the data which one of these
is a false negative I believe it's the
nine that's scary
I would not want to be one of those nine
people told that I don't have cancer and
then suddenly find out I do uh so we
would need to find a way to sort this
out and there is different ways to do
that uh a little bit past this but you
can start messing with the actual ukian
geometry and the activation uh
measurements and start changing those
and how they interact but that's very
Advanced there's also other ways to
classify them or to create a whole
another class right here of we don't
knows those are just a couple of the
Solutions you might use for that but for
a lot of things this works out great uh
you can see here you know maybe you're
trying to sell something well if this
was not uh life dependent and this was
if I display this ad 42 of these people
are going to buy it and if I display
this other ad if I don't display it 79
people are going to go a different
direction or whatever it is so maybe
you're trying to display whether they're
going to buy something if you added on
to the website in which case that's
really a good numbers you've just added
a huge number of sales to your company
so that was our K nearest neighbors uh
let's go ahead and take a look at
support Vector machines so support
Vector machines uh is the main objective
of a support Vector machine algorithm is
to find a hyperplane in an n-dimensional
space in is a number of features that
distinctly classifies the data points
and if you remember we were just looking
at those nice graphs we had earlier in
fact Let Me Go a and flip back on over
there if we were looking at this data
here we might want toy try to find a
nice line through the data and that's
what we're talking about with uh this
next setup so the main objective of
support Vector machine algorithm is to
find a hyperplane in an N dimensional
space N is a number of features that
distinctly classifies the data points to
separate the two classes of data there
are many hyperplanes that can be chosen
our objective is to find the plane that
has the maximum margin I.E the maximum
distance between data points of both CL
classes the dimensions of the hyper
plane depends on the number of features
if there are two input features then the
hyper plane is just a line if there are
three features then the hyper plane
becomes a two-dimensional plane the line
that separates the data into two classes
is called as support vector classifier
or hard margin and that's why I just
showed you on the other data you can see
here we look for a line that splits the
data evenly the problem with hard margin
is that it doesn't allow outliers and
doesn't work with non-linearly separable
data and we just were looking at that
let me flip back on over here and when
we look at this setup in here and we
look at this data here we go look how
many outliers are in here these are all
with all these blue dots on the wrong
side of the line would be considered
outlier and the same with the red line
and so it becomes very difficult to
divide this data unless there's a clear
space there we go therefore we introduce
soft margins which accept the new data
point and optimize a model for nonlinear
data points soft margins pass through
the data points at the border of the
classes the support Vector machine can
be used to separate the two classes of
shapes here we can see that although
triangles and diamond shapes have pointy
edges but we are able to classify them
in two categories using a support Vector
machine let's go ahead and see what that
looks like in a demo we flip back on
over to our Jupiter notebook we always
want to start with taking a look at the
sklearn uh API in this case the svm SVC
there is a significant number of
parameters because SK the um svm has
been a lot of development in the recent
years and it's become very popular if we
scroll all the way down to methods
you'll see right here as our fit and our
predict that's what you should see in
most of the um sidekit learn packages so
this should look very familiar to what
we've already been working on and we'll
go ahead and bring in our import and run
that uh we show already have pandas
numpy our matplot library which we're
going to be using to graph some of the
things a little bit different right here
you'll see that we're going to go ahead
and bring in um one of the fun things
you can do with test data is uh make
circles circles are really hard to
classify you have a ring on the inside
and a ring on the outside and you can
see where that can cause some issues and
we'll take a look at that a little
closer in a minute here's our svm uh
setup on there and then of course our
metrics because we're going to use that
to take a closer look at things so we go
and run this whoops already did once
we've gone ahead and done that we're
going to go ahead and start making
ourselves some data and this part
probably a little bit more complicated
uh than we need I'm not going to go too
much in detail on it uh we're going to
make a mesh grid and we'll see what that
looks like in a minute where we're
defining the minimums you can see in
here create a mesh grid of points here's
our parameters of x y and H it's going
to return XX y y you can also send a
note to make sure you get a copy of this
if you want to dig deeper into this
particular code especially and we have a
y men yaax uh yman y Max plus one here's
our mesh grid we're actually going to
make XX and y y plot the Contours all
the way through and this is just a way
of creating data it's kind of a fun way
to create some data we go plot Contours
ax LF XX y y and return it out add some
perimeters here so that when we're doing
it we have our setup on there train
property and then we'll go ahead and
make our data just throw that right in
there too in the same setup and run that
uh so now we have X and Y we're going to
make our circles we have n samples equal
samples in this case we're going to have
500 samples we went ahead and gave it uh
noise of 0.005 random State 123 these
are all going into oops let go back up
here we go make our mesh grid make
circles there it is uh uh so this is
going into our make circles up here and
this is part of that setup on this and
then once we've gone ahead and make the
circle let's go ahead and plot it uh
that way you can see what we're talking
about right now what I'm saying is
really confusing because without a
visual it doesn't really mean very much
what we're actually doing so I'm going
go ahe and run this with the plot and
let's go back up here and just take a
look we've made our Circle we have our
in samples equals sample so we're going
to have 500 we're going to have training
property point8 here's our data frame we
go and load it into the data frames so
we can plot it groups DF Group by label
uh this is kind of a fun way if you have
multiple columns you can really quickly
pull whatever setup is in there and then
we go ahead and plot it and you can see
here we have two rings that are formed
and that's all this is doing is just
making this data for us this is really
hard data to figure out um a lot of
programs get confused in this because
there's no straight line or anything
like that but we can add planes in
different setups on here and so you can
see we have some very interesting data
we have our zero is in blue and our
one's in the yellow in the middle and
the data points are um an XY coordinate
plot on this one of the things we might
want to do on here is go ahead and find
the um Min to Max ratio uh set up in
there and we can even do let's just do a
print X so you can see what the data
looks like that we're producing on this
there we go so uh xal x - Xmen over x
max Max - Xmen all we're doing is
putting this between zero and one
whatever this data is we want um a 0er
to one setup on here and if you look at
this all our data is
8.5 that's what this particular line is
doing that's a pretty common thing to do
in processing data especially in neural
networks uh neural networks don't like
big numbers they create huge biases and
cause all kinds of problems and that's
true in a lot of our models some of the
models it doesn't really matter but when
you're doing enough of these you just
start doing them uh you just start
putting everything between zero and one
there's even some algorithms to do that
in the SK learn although it's pretty as
you can see it's pretty easy to do it
here so uh let's go ahead and jump into
the next thing which is a linear kind of
setup Cal 1.0 this is the svm
regularization parameter we're going to
use models here's our svm and let's go
and scroll up just a notch there we go
now we so here we are with our model
we're going to create the the setup with
the SVC kernel is linear and we'll come
back to that because that's an important
uh setup in there as far as what our
kernel is and you'll you'll see why
that's so important here in a minute
because we're going to look at a couple
of these and so this one is we're
actually going to be changing how that
processes it uh and then our C here's
our one our 0.0 and then the rest of
this is uh plotting we're just adding
titles making the Contours so it's a
pretty graph you can actually spend this
would be a whole class just to do all
the cool things you can do with scatter
plots and regular plots and colors and
things like that in this case we're
going to create a graph with a nice
white line down the middle so that you
can see what's going on here and when we
do this you can see that as it as it
split the data uh the linear did just
that it drew a line through the data and
it says this is supposed to be blue and
this is supposed to be red and it
doesn't really fit very well that's
because we used a linear division of the
data and it's not very linear data on
it's anything but linear so when we when
we look at that it's like well okay that
didn't work what's the next option well
there's a lot of choices in here one of
them is just simply we can change this
from the kernel being linear to poly and
we'll just go back up here and use the
same chart uh oops here we go uh so here
we go uh linear kernel we'll change this
to poly and then when we come in here
and create our model here's our model up
here linear we can actually just go
right in and change this to the poly
model and if you remember remember when
we go back over here to the SVC and
let's scroll back up here there's a lot
of different options oops even further
okay so when we come up here we start
talking about the kernel here's the
kernel there's linear there's poly RBF
sigmoid precomputed there's a lot of
different ways to do this setup um and
their actual default is RBF very
important to note that uh so when you're
running these models understanding which
parameter is really has a huge effect on
what's going on in this particular one
with the spvm the kernel is so important
you really need to know that and we
switched our kernel to poly and when we
run this uh you can see it's changed a
little bit we now have quite an
interesting looking diagram and you can
see on here it now has these
classifications correct but it messes up
in this blue up here and it messes up on
this blue is correct and this blue is
supposed to be red you can see that it
still isn't quite fitting on there and
so that is uh we do a a poly fit uh you
can see if you have a split in data
where there's a group in the middle this
one kind of data and the groups on the
outside are different the polyfit or the
poly kernel is what's going to be fit
for that so uh if that doesn't work then
what are we going to use well uh they
have the RBF kernel and let's go ahead
and take a look and see what the RBF
looks like and uh let me go and turn
there we go turn my drawing off and the
RBF kernel oops there we go RBF and then
of course for our title it's always nice
to have it match with the RBF kernel and
we go ahead and run this and you can see
that the RBF kernel does a really good
job uh it actually has divided the data
up on here and this is the kind of what
you expect here was that ring here's our
inner ring and an outer ring of data and
so the RBF fits this data package quite
nicely um and that when we talk about
svm it really is powerful in that it has
this kind of sorting feature to it in
its algorithms this is something that is
really hard to get the SK means to do or
the K means uh setup and so when you
start looking at these different machine
learning algorithms understanding your
data and how it's grouped is really
important it makes a huge difference as
far as what you're Computing and what
you're doing with it so that was the
demo on the support Vector uh certainly
you could have done continued on that
and done like a confusion Matrix and all
that kind of fun stuff to see how good
it was and split the data up to see how
it uh uh vectorizes the visual on that
so important it makes a big difference
just to see what it looks like and that
giant donut and why it it does Circle so
well or your poly version or your linear
version so we've looked at some very
numerical kind of uh setups where
there's a lot of math involved ukian
geometry um that kind of thing a totally
different machine learning algorithm for
approaching this is the decision trees
and there's also Forest that go with the
decision trees they're based on multiple
trees combined the decision tree is a
supervised learning algorithm used for
classification it creates a model that
predicts the value of a Target variable
by learning simple decision rules
inferred from the data features a
decision tree is a hierarchal tree
structure where an internal node
represents features or tribute the
branch represents a decision Rule and
each Leaf node represents the outcome
and you can see here where they have the
first one uh yes or no and then you go
either left or right and so forth one of
the coolest things about decision trees
um is and I'll see people actually run a
decision tree even though their final
model is different because a decision
tree allows you to see what's going on
you can actually look at it and say why
did you go right or left what was the
choice where's that break uh and that is
really nice if you're trying to share
that information with somebody else as
to why when you start getting into the
why this is happening decision trees are
very powerful so the topmost note of a
decision tree is known as the root node
it learns to partition on the basis of
the attribute value it partitions the
tree in a recursive manner so you have
your decision node if you get yes you go
down to the next Noe that's a decision
Noe and either yes you go to if it ends
on a leaf node then you know your answer
uh which is yes or no so there's your
there's your in classification set up on
there here's an example of a decision
tree that tells whether I'll sleep or
not at a particular evening mine would
be depending on whether I have the news
on or not do I need to sleep no okay
I'll work uh yes is it raining outside
yes I'll sleep no I'll work so I guess
if it's uh not raining outside it's
harder to fall asleep where they have
that nice uh rain coming in and again
this is really cool about a decision
tree is I can actually look at it and go
oh I like to sleep when it rains outside
so when you're looking at all the data
you can say oh this is where the switch
comes in when it rains outside I'll
sleep really good if it's not raining or
if I don't need sleep then I'm not going
to sleep I'm going to go work so let's
go ahead and take a look at that that
looks like in the code just like we did
before we go ahead and open up the site
kit setup just to tell you what the
decision tree classifier has you have
your parameters which we'll look a
little bit more in depth at as we write
the code but it has uh different ways of
splitting it the strategy used to choose
a split at each node uh Criterion max
depth remember the tree how far down do
you want it do you want it to take up
the space of your whole computer with
and and map every piece of data or you
know the smaller that number is the
smaller the level the tree is and the
less processing it takes but is also
more General so you're less likely to
get as indepth and answer um and then of
course minimal samples you need for it
to split samples for the leaf there's a
lot of things in here as far as what how
big the tree is and how to define it and
when do you define it and how to weight
it and they have their different
attributes which you can dig deeper into
uh that can be very important if you
want to know the why of things uh and
then we go down here to our methods and
you'll see just like everything else we
have our fit method very important uh
and our predict uh the two main things
that we use what is what we're going to
predict our X to be equal to and we'll
go ahead and go up here and start
putting together the code uh we're going
to import our numpy our pandas there's
our confusion Matrix our train test
Split Decision tree classifi that's the
big one that we're actually working with
uh that's the line right here where
we're going to be oops decision tree
there it is decision tree classifier
that's the one I was looking for and of
course we want to know the accuracy and
the classification report on here and
we're going to do a little different
than we did the other examples and
there's a reason for this let me go and
run this and load this up here uh we're
going to go ahead and build things on
functions and this is when you start
splitting up into a team this is the
kind of thing you start seeing a lot
more both in teams and for yourself
because you might want to swap one data
to test it on a different data depending
on what's going on uh so we're going to
have our import data here um the data
set length the balance and so forth um
this just returns balance data let me
just go ahead and print because I'm
curious as to what this looks like
import data and it's going to return the
balance data so if I run that uh if we
go ahead and print this out here and run
that you can see that we we have a whole
bunch of data that comes in there and
some interesting setup on here has a
let's see BR RR I'm not sure exactly
what that represents on here uh 111 112
and so forth so we have a different set
of data here the shape is uh five
columns 1 2 3 4 five uh seems to have a
number at the beginning which I'm going
to guess uh B RL a letter I mean and
then a bunch of numbers in there 1111
let's see down here we got 555 uh set up
on this and let's see balance data and
since it said balance data I'm going to
guess that uh b means balanced R means
you need to move it right and L means
it's um needs to be moved left or skewed
to the left I'm not sure which one uh
let's go and close that out and we'll go
ahead and create a function to split the
data set uh X balance data equals data
values y balance equals data values of
zero there's that letter remember left
right and balance then we're looking for
the values of 1 through five and we go
ahead and split it just like you would X
train y train set random State 100 test
size is.3 so we're taking 30% of the
data and it's going to return your X
your y your y train your uh your X train
your X test your y train your um y test
again we do this because if you're
running a lot of these you might want to
switch how you split the data and how
you train it I tend to use a bfold
method I'll take a third of the data
and I'll train it on the other two3 and
test it on that third and then I'll
switch it I'll switch which third is a
test data and then I can actually take
that information and correlate it and it
gives me a a really uh robust package
for figuring out what the complete
accuracy is uh but in this case we're
just going to go ahead this is our
function for splitting data and this is
where it kind of gets interesting
because remember we were talking a
little bit about uh the different
settings in our model and so uh in here
we're going to create a decision tree
but we're going to use the Gen Genie
setup and where did that come from uh
what's the Gen on here uh so if we go
back to the top of their page and we
have what uh Criterion are we going to
use we're going to use Genie they have
Genie and entropy those are the two main
ones that they use for the decision tree
uh so this one's going to be Genie and
if we're going to have a function that
creates the Genie model and it even goes
down here and here's our fit train of
the Genie model uh we'll probably also
want to create one for entropy sometimes
I even just um I might even make this
just one function with the different
setups and I know one of my one of the
things I worked on recently I had to
create a one that tested across multiple
models and so I would send the
parameters to the models or I would send
this part right here where it says
decision tree classifier that whole
thing might be what I send to create the
model and I know it's going to fit we're
going to have our xtrain and we're going
to have our predict and all that stuff
is the same so you can just send that
model to your function uh for testing
different models again this just gives
you one of the ways to do it and you can
see here we're going to chain train with
the genie and we're also going to CH
train with the entropy to see how that
works and if you're going to have your
models going two separate models you're
sending there we'll go ahead and create
a prediction this simply is our y
predict equals our uh whatever object we
sent whatever model we sent here the clf
object and predict against our X test
and you can see here print y predict and
return y predict set up on here we'll
load that definition up and then if
you're going to have a function that
runs the predict and print some things
out uh we should also have our accuracy
function so here's our calculate the
accuracy what are we sending we're
sending our y test data this could also
be y actual and Y predict and then we'll
print out a confusion Matrix uh then
we'll print out the accuracy of the um
score on here and print a report
classification report bundle it all
together there so if we bring this all
together we have um all the steps we've
been working towards which is importing
our data by the ways you'll spend 80% of
your time importing data in most machine
learning setups and cooking it and
burning it and getting it formatted so
that it it uh works with whatever models
you're working with the decision
has some cool features in that if you're
missing data it can actually pick that
up and just skip that and says I don't
know how to split this there's no way of
knowing whether it rained or didn't rain
last night so I'll look at something
else like whether you watched uh TV
after 8:00 you know that blue screen
thing uh so we have our function
importing our data set we bring in the
data we split the data so we have our X
test test and Y train and then we have
our different models our clf Genie so
it's a decision tree classif far using
the genie setup and then we can also
create the model using entropy uh and
then once we have that we have our
function for making the prediction and
we have our function for calculating the
accuracy uh and then if we're going to
have that we should probably have our
main code involved here this probably
looks more familiar if you're depending
on what you're working on if you're
working on like a piie charm then you
would see this in throwing something up
real quick in jupyter Notebook uh so
here's our our main data import which
we've already defined uh we get our
split data we create our Genie we create
our entropy so there's our two models
going on here there's our two models so
these are two separate data models we've
already sent them to be trained then
we're going to go ahead and print the
results using Genie index so we'll start
with the genie and we want to go ahead
with the genie and print our um our
predictions YX test to the genie and
calculate the accuracy on here and then
we want to print the results using
entropy so this this is just the same
thing coming down like we did with the
genie we're going to put out our y
predict entropy and our calculations so
let's go ahead and run that and just see
what this uh piece of code does uh we do
have like one of our data needs to be is
getting a warning on there there nothing
major because it's just a simple warning
probably an update of a new version's
coming out uh and so here we are we have
our data set it's got 625 you can
actually see an example of the data set
B meaning balanced I guess and here's
our five data points 1111 means it's
balanced it's skewed to the right with
1112 uh and so forth on here and then
we're going to go ahead and predict from
our prediction whether it's to the right
or to the left you can think of a
washing machine that's SK that's banging
on one side of the thing or maybe it's
an automated car where we're down the
middle of the road that's IM balance and
it starts going veering to the right so
we need to correct for it uh and when we
print out the confusion Matrix we have
three different variables r l and B so
we should three the three different
variables on here and you have as far as
whether it predicts in this case the
balance there's not a lot of balance
loads on here and didn't do a good job
guessing whether it's balanced or not
that's what I took from this first one
uh the second one I'm guessing is the
right so it did pretty good job guessing
the right balance you can see that a
bunch of them came up left unbalanced um
probably not good for an automated car
as it tells you 18 out of the uh 18
missed things and tells you to go the
wrong Direction and here we are going
the other way uh 19 to 71 and of course
we can back that up with an accuracy
report on here and you can see the
Precision how well the left and right
balance is 79% 79% precision and so
forth and then we went and use the
entropy and let me just see if we can
get so we can get them both next to each
other here's our entropy of our um the
first setup our first model which is the
Genie model 6718
2070 pretty close the two models you
know that's not a huge difference in
numbers this second one of entropy did
slightly it looks like slightly worse
because it did one better as far as the
right balance and did what is this four
worse on the left balance or whatever uh
so slightly worse if I was guessing
between these I'd probably use the first
one they're so close though that
wouldn't be it wouldn't be a Clear
Choice as to which one worked better and
there's a lot of numbers you can play
with here which might give better
results depending on what the data is
going in now uh one of the takeaways you
should have from the different category
routines we ran is that they run very
similar you you certainly change the
perimeters in them as to whether you're
using what model you're using and how
you're using it and what data they get
applied to but when you're talking about
the S kit learn package it does such an
awesome job of making it easy easy uh
you split your data up you train your
data and you run the prediction and then
you see what kind of accuracy what kind
confusion confusion Matrix It generates
so um we talk about algorithm selection
logistic regression K nearest neighbors
uh logistic regression is used when we
have a binomial outcome for example to
predict whether an email is Spam or not
whether the tumor is malignant or not
the logistic regression works really
good on that you can do it in a k
nearest neighbors also the question is
which one will it work better in um I
find the logistic regression models work
really good in a lot of raw number so if
you're working with say the stock market
is this a good investment or a bad
investment um so that's one of the
things that it handles the numbers
better K nearest neighbors are used in
scenarios where
nonparametric no fixed number of
perimeters algorithms are required it is
used in pattern recognition Data Mining
and intrusion detection uh so K means
really good in finding the patterns um
I've seen that as a pre-processor to a
lot of other processors where you use
the K nearest neighbors to figure out
what data groups together very powerful
package support Vector machines uh
support Vector machines are used
whenever the data has higher Dimensions
the human genome microarray svms are
extensively used in the hard handwriting
recognition models and you can see that
we were able to switch between the
parabolic and the circular setup on
there where you can now have that
doughnut kind of data and be able to
filter that out with the support Vector
machine and then decision trees are
mostly used in operational researches
specifically in decision analysis to
help identify a strategy most likely to
reach any goal they are pre preferred
where the model is easy to understand I
like that last one it's a good
description is it easy to understand so
you have data coming in when am I going
to go to bed you know you know is it
raining outside you can go back and
actually look at the pieces and see
those different decision modes takes a
little bit more to dig in there and
figure out what they're doing uh but you
can do that and you can actually help
you figure out why um people love it for
the why Factor so uh strings and
limitations big one on all of these the
strings and limitations we talk about
logistic regressions uh the strings are
it is easy to implement and efficient to
train it is relatively easy to
regularize the data points remember how
we put everything between zero and one
when you look at logistic regression
models uh you don't have to worry about
that as much limitations has a high
Reliance on proper representation of
data that can only predict a categorical
outcome with the K nearest neighbors it
doesn't need a separate training period
new data can be added seamlessly without
affecting the accuracy of the model uh
kind of an interesting thing because you
can do partial training uh that can
become huge if you're running across
really large data sets or the data is
coming in you can continually uh do a
partial fit on the data with the K
nearest neighbors and continue to adjust
that data uh it doesn't doesn't work on
high dimensional and large data sets we
were looking at the breast cancer uh 36
different features what happens when you
have 127 features or a million features
and you say well what do you have a
million features in well if I was
analyzing uh logic um the legal
documents I might have a tokenizer that
splits a words up to be analyzed and
that tokenizer might create 1 million
different words available that might be
in the document for doing weights uh
sensitive to noisy data outliers and
missing values that's a huge one with K
nearest neighbors they really don't know
what to do with a missing value how do
you compute the the distance if you
don't know what the value is uh the svm
uh Works more efficiently on high
dimensional data it is relative ly
memory efficient so it's able to create
those planes with only a few different
variables in there as opposed to having
to store a lot of data for different uh
features and things like that it's not
suitable for a large data sets uh the
svm you start running this over
gigabytes of data causes some huge
issues underperforms if the data has
noise or overlapping that's a big one we
were looking at that where the spvm
splits it and it creates a soft buffer
but what happens when you have a lot of
stuff in the middle uh this hard is sort
out and doesn't know what to do with
that causes SPM to start crashing or not
perform as well decision trees handles
nonlinear perimeters and missing values
efficiently the missing values is huge
I've seen this in uh was it the wine
tasting data sets where they have three
different data sets and they share
certain features uh but then each one
has some features that aren't in the
other ones and it has to figure out how
to handle those well the decision tree
does that automatically instead of
having to figure a way to f fill that
data in before processing like you would
with the other models uh it's easy to
understand and has less training period
so it trains pretty quickly uh comes up
there and just keeps forking the tree
down and moving the parts around and so
it it doesn't have to go through the
data multiple times guessing and
adjusting it just creates the tree as it
goes overfitting and high variants are
the most annoying part of it that's
that's an understatement uh that has to
do with how many leavs and how many
decisions you have it do the more you
have the more over it is to the data it
also uh just in making the choices and
how the choices come in it might overfit
to a specific feature because that's
where it started at and that's what it
knows and it really um is challenged
with large data sets they've been
working on that with the data Forest but
it's not suitable for large data sets
it's really something you'd probably run
on a single machine and not across um
not across a uh data pool or anything
decision tree one of the many powerful
tools in the machine learning Li Library
begins with a problem I think I have to
buy a car so in making this question you
want to know how do I decide which one
to buy and you're going to start asking
questions is a mileage greater than 20
is a price less than 15 will it be
sufficient for six people does it have
enough airbag antiock breaks all these
questions come up then as we feed all
this data in we make a decision and that
decision comes up oh hey this seems like
a good idea here's a car so as we going
through this decision process using a
decision tree we're going to explore
this maybe not buying a car but in how
to process data what's in it for you
let's start by finding out what is
machine learning and why we even want to
know about it for processing our data
and we'll go into the three basic types
of machine learning and the problems
that are used by Machine learning to
solve finally we'll get into what is a
decision tree what are the problems a
decision tree solves what are the
advantages and disadvantages of using a
decision tree and then we want to dig in
a little deep into the mechanics how
does the decision tree work and then
we'll go in and do a case loan repayment
prediction where we actually going to
put together some python code and show
you the basic python code for generating
a decision tree what is machine learning
there are so many different ways to
describe what is machine learning in
today's world and illustrate it we're
going to take a graphic here and uh
making decisions or trying to understand
what's going on and really underlying
machine learning is people want wish
they were smarter wish we could
understand the world better so you can
see a guy here who's uh saying hey how
can I understand the world better and
someone comes up and says let's use
artificial intelligence machine learning
is a part of artificial intelligence and
now he get a big smile on his face
because now he has artificial
intelligence to help him make his
decisions uh and they can think in new
ways so this brings in new ideas so what
is machine learning this is a wonderful
graph here you can see where we have a
learn predict decide these are the most
basic three premises of machine learning
in learning we can describe the data new
ways and able to learn new aspects about
what we're looking at and then we can
use that to predict things and we can
use that to make decisions so maybe it's
something that's never happened before
but we can make a good guess whether
it's going to be a good investment or
not it also helps us categorize stuff so
we can remember it better so it's easier
to pull it out of the catalog we can
analyze data in new ways we never
thought possible and then of course
there's the uh very large growing
industry of recognize we can do facial
recognition driver recognition automated
car recognition all these are part of
machine learning going back to our guy
here who's in his ordinary system and
would like to be smarter make better
choices what happens with machine
learning is an application of artificial
intelligence wherein the system gets the
ability to automatically learn and
improved based on experience so this is
exciting because you have your ordinary
guy who now has another form of
information coming in and this is with
the artificial intelligence helps him
see things he never saw or track things
he can't track so instead of having to
read all the news feeds he can now have
an artificial intelligence
sorted out so he's only looking at the
information he needs to make a choice
with and of course we use all those
machine learning tools back in there and
he's now making smarter choices with
less work types of machine learning
let's break it into three primary types
of learning first is supervised learning
where you already have the data and the
answers so if you worked at a bank you'd
already have a list of all the previous
loans and who defaulted on them and who
made good payments on them you then
program your machine learning tool and
that lets you predict on the next person
whether they're going to be able to make
their payments or not on their loan if
you have one category where you already
know the answers the next one would be
you don't know the answers you just have
a lot of information coming in
unsupervised learning allows you to
group liked information together so if
you're analyzing photos it might group
all the images of trees together and all
the images of houses together without
ever knowing what a house or a tree is
which leads us to the third type of
machine learning the third type of
machine learning is rein enforcement
learning unlike supervised or
unsupervised learning you don't have the
data prior to starting so you get the
data one line at a time and then whether
you make a good choice or a bad choice
the machine learning tool has to then
adjust accordingly so you get a plus or
minus feedback you can liken this to the
way a human learns we experience life
one minute at a time and we learn from
that and either our memories is good or
we learn to avoid something problems in
machine learning to understand where the
decision tree fits into our machine
learning tools we have to understand the
basics of some of the machine learning
problems and three of the primary ones
fall underneath classification problems
with categorical Solutions like yes or
no true or false one or zero this might
be does it belong to a particular group
yes or no then we have regression
problems where there's a continuous
value needs to be predicted like product
prices profit and you can see here this
is a very simple linear graph uh you can
guess what the next value is is based on
the first four it kind of follows a
straight line going up and clustering
this is problems where the data needs to
be organized to find specific patterns
like in the case of product
recommendation they group all the
different products that people just like
you viewed on a shopping site and say
people who bought this also bought this
the most commonly used for the decision
tree is for classification for figuring
out is it red or is it not is it a fruit
or is it a vegetable yes or no true
false left or right 01 and so when we
talk about classification we're going to
look at the basic machine learning these
are the four main tools used in
classification there's the Nave Bas
logistic regression decision tree and
random Forest the first two are for
simpler data so if your data is not very
complex you can usually use these to do
a fairly good representation by drawing
a line through the data or a curve
through the data they work Wonderful in
a lot of problems but as things get more
complicated the decision tree comes in
and then if you have a very large amount
of data you start getting into the
random Forest so the decision tree is
actually a part of the random Forest but
today we're just going to focus on the
decision
tree what is a decision tree let's go
through a very simple example before we
dig in deep decision tree is a
tree-shaped diagram used to determine a
course of action each branch of the tree
represents a possible decision
occurrence or reaction let's start with
a simple question how to identify a
random vegetable from shopping bag so we
have this group of vegetables in here
and we can start off by asking a simple
question is it red and if it's not then
it's going to be the purple fruit to the
left probably an eggplant if it's true
it's going to be one of the red fruits
is a diameter greater than two if false
it's going to be a what looks to be a
red chili and if it's true it's going to
be a bell pepper from the capsicum
family so it's a
capsicum problems that decision tree can
solve so let's look at the two different
categories the decision tree can be used
on it can be used on the classification
the true false yes no and it can be used
on regression where we figure out what
the next value is in a series of numbers
or a group of data in classification the
classification tree will determine a set
of logical if then conditions to
classify problems for example
discriminating between three types of
flowers based on certain features in
regression a regression tree is used
when the target variable is numerical or
continuous in nature we fit the
regression model to the Target variable
using each of the independent variables
each split is made based on the sum of
squared error before we dig deeper into
the mechanics of the decision tree let's
take a look at the advantages of using a
decision tree and we'll also take a
glimpse at the disadvantages the first
thing you'll notice is that it's simple
to understand interpret and visualize it
really shines here because you can see
exactly what's going on in a decision
tree little effort is required for data
preparation so you don't have to do
special scaling there's a lot of things
you don't have to worry about when using
a decision tree it can handle both
numerical and categorical data as we
discovered earlier and nonlinear
parameters don't affect its performance
so even if the data doesn't fit an easy
curved graph you can still use it to
create an effective decision or
prediction if we're going to look at the
advantages of a decision tree we also
need to understand the disadvantages of
a decision tree the first disadvantage
is overfitting overfitting occurs when
the algorithm captures noise in the data
that means you're solving for one
specific instance instead of a general
solution for all the data High variance
the model can get unstable due to small
variation in data low bias tree a highly
complicated decision tree tends to have
a low bias which makes it difficult for
the model to work with new data decision
tree important terms before we dive in
further we need to look at some basic
terms we need to have some definitions
to go with our decision tree in the
different parts we're going to be using
we'll start with entropy entropy is a
measure of Randomness or
unpredictability in the data set for
example we have a group of animals in
this picture there's four different
kinds of animals and this data set is
considered to have a high entropy you
really can't pick out what kind of
animal it is based on looking at just
the four animals as a big clump of of uh
entities so as we start splitting it
into subgroups we come up with our
second definition which is Information
Gain Information Gain it is the measure
of decrease in entropy after the data
set is split so in this case based on
the color yellow we've split one group
of animals on one side as true and those
who aren't yellow as false as we
continue down the yellow side we split
based on the height true or false equals
10 and on the other side height is less
than 10 true or false and as you see as
we split it the entropy continues to be
less and less and less and so our
Information Gain is simply the entropy
E1 from the top and how it's changed to
E2 in the bottom and we'll look at the
deeper math although you really don't
need to know a huge amount of math when
you actually do the programming in
Python because they'll do it for you but
we'll look on the actual math and how
they compute entropy finally we went
under the different parts of our tree
and they call the leaf node Leaf node
carries the classification or the
decision so it's a final end at the
bottom the decision node has two or more
branches this is where we're breaking
the group up into different parts and
finally you have the root node the
topmost decision node is known as the
root
node how does a decision tree work
wonder what kind of animals I'll get the
jungle today maybe you're the hunter
with the gun or if you're more into
photography you're a photographer with a
camera so let's look at this group of
animals and let's try to classify
different types of animals based on
their features using a decision tree so
the problem statement is to classify the
different types of animals based on
their features using using a decision
tree the data set is looking quite messy
and the entropy is high in this case so
let's look at a training set or a
training data set and we're looking at
color we're looking at height and then
we have our different animals we have
our elephants our giraffes our monkeys
and our tigers and they're of different
colors and shapes let's see what that
looks like and how do we split the data
we have to frame the conditions that
split the data in such a way that the
Information Gain is the highest note
gain is a measure of De increase in
entropy after splitting so the formula
for entropy is the sum that's what this
symbol looks like that looks like kind
of like a e funky e of K where I equals
1 to k k would represent the number of
animal the different animals in there
where value or P value of I would be the
percentage of that animal times the log
base 2 of the same the percentage of
that animal let's try to calculate the
entropy for the current data set and
take a look at what that looks like and
and don't be afraid of the math you
don't really have to memorize this math
just be aware that it's there and this
is what's going on in the background and
so we have three giraffes two tigers one
monkey two elephants a total of eight
animals gathered and if we plug that
into the formula we get an entropy that
equals 3 over 8 so we have three drafts
a total of eight times the log usually
they use base two on the log so log base
2 of 3 over 8 plus in this case let's
say it's the elephants 2 over 8 two
elephants over total of 8 * log base 2 2
over 8 plus 1 monkey over total of 8 log
base 2 1 over8 and plus 2 over8 of the
Tigers log base 2 over 8 and if we plug
that into our computer our calculator I
obviously can't do logs in my head we
get an entropy equal to
0.571 the program will actually
calculate the entropy of the data set
similarly after every split to calculate
the gain now we're not going to go
through each set one at a time to see
what those numbers are we just want you
to be aware that this is a Formula or
the mathematics behind it gain can be
calculated by finding the difference of
the subsequent entropy values after a
split now we will try to choose a
condition that gives us the highest gain
we will do that by splitting the data
using each condition and checking that
the gain we get out of them the
condition that gives us the highest gain
will be used to make the first split can
you guess what that first split will be
just by looking at this image as a human
it's probably pretty easy to split it
let's see if you're right if you guessed
the color yellow you're correct let's
say the condition that gives us the
maximum gain is yellow so we will split
the data based on the color yellow if
it's true that group of animals goes to
the left if it's false it goes to the
right the entropy after the splitting
has to decreased considerably however we
still need some splitting at both the
branches to attain an entropy value
equal to zero so we decide to split both
of nodes using height as a condition
since every Branch now contains single
label type we can can say that entropy
in this case has reached the least value
and here you see we have the giraffes
the Tigers the monkey and the elephants
all separated into their own groups this
tree can now predict all the classes of
animals present in the data set with
100% accuracy that was easy use case
loan repayment prediction let's get into
my favorite part and open up some Python
and see what the programming code in the
scripting looks like in here we're going
to want to do a prediction and we start
with this individual here who's
requesting to find out how good his
customers are going to be whether
they're going to repay their loan or not
for his bank and from that we want to
generate a problem statement to predict
if a customer will repay loan amount or
not and then we're going to be using the
decision tree algorithm in Python let's
see what that looks like and let's dive
into the code in our first few steps of
implementation we're going to start by
importing the necessary packages that we
need from Python and we're going to load
up our data and take a look at what the
data looks like so the first thing I
need is I need something to edit my
Python and run it in so let's flip on
over and here I'm using the Anaconda
Jupiter notebook now you can use any
python ID you like to run it in but I
find the jupyter notebook's really nice
for doing things on the Fly and let's go
ahead and just paste that code in the
beginning and before we start let's talk
a little bit about what we're bringing
in and then we're going to do a couple
things in here we have to make a couple
changes as we go through this first part
of the import the first thing we bring
in is numpy as NP that's very standard
when we're dealing with mathematics
especially with uh very complicated
machine learning tools you almost always
see the numpy come in for your num your
number it's called number python it has
your mathematics in there in this case
we actually could take it out but
generally you'll need it for most of
your different things you work with and
then we're going to use pandas as PD
that's also a standard the pandas is a
data frame setup and you can liken this
to uh taking your basic data and storing
it in a way that looks like an Excel
spreadsheet so as we come back to this
when you see NP or PD those are very
standard uses you'll know that that's
the pandas and I'll show you a little
bit more when we explore the data in
just a minute then we're going to need
to split the data so I'm going to bring
in our train test and split and this is
coming from the sklearn package cross
validation in just a minute we're going
to change that and we'll go over that
too and then there's also the sk. tree
import decision tree classifier that's
the actual tool we're using remember I
told you don't be afraid of the
mathematics it's going to be done for
you well the decision tree classifier
has all that mathematics in there for
you so you don't have to figure it back
out again and then we have SK learn.
metrics for accuracy score we need to
score our our setup that's the whole
reason we're splitting it between the
training and testing data and finally we
still need the sklearn import tree and
that's just the basic tree function is
needed for the decision tree classifier
and finally we're going to load our data
down here and I'm going to run this and
we're going to get two things on here
one we're going to get an error and two
we're going to get a warning let's see
what that looks like so the first thing
we had is we have an error why is this
error here well it's looking at this it
says I need to read a file and when this
was written the person who wrote it this
is their path where they stored the file
so let's go ahead and fix
that and I'm going to put in here my
file path I'm just going to call it full
file name and you'll see it's on my C
drive and this is very lengthy setup on
here where I stored the data 2. CSV
file don't worry too much about the full
path because on your computer it'll be
different the data. 2 CSV file was
generated by simply learn if you want a
copy of that you can comment down below
and request it here in the
YouTube and then if I'm going to give it
a name full file name I'm going to go
ahead and change it here to
full file name so let's go ahead and run
it now and see what
happens and we get a
warning when you're coding understanding
these different warnings and these
different errors that come up is
probably the hardest lesson to learn so
let's just go ahead and take a look at
this and use this as a uh opportunity to
understand what's going on here if you
read the warning it says the cross
validation is depreciated so it's a
warning on it's being removed and it's
going to be moved in favor of the model
selection so if we go up here we have
sklearn Doc crossvalidation and if you
research this and go to the sklearn site
you'll find out that you can actually
just swap it right in there with model
selection and so when I come in here and
I run it again that removes a warning
what they've done is they've had two
different developers develop it in two
different branches and then they decided
to keep one of those and eventually get
rid of the other one that's all that is
and very easy and quick to to
fix before we go any further I went
ahead and opened up the data from this
file remember the the data file we just
loaded on here the dataor 2. CSV let's
talk a little bit more about that and
see what that looks like both as a text
file because it's a comma separated
variable file and in a spreadsheet this
is what it looks like as a basic text
file you can see at the top they've
created a header and it's got 1 2 3 4
five columns and each column has data in
it and let me flip this over because
we're also going to look at this uh in
an actual spreadsheet so you can see
what that looks like and here I've
opened it up in the open Office calc
which is pretty much the same as um
Excel and zoomed in and you can see
we've got our columns and our rows of
data little easier to read in here we
have a result yes yes no we have initial
payment last payment credit score house
number if we scroll away
down we'll see that this occupies a,1
lines of code or lines of data with uh
the first one being a column and then
1,000 lines of
data now as a
programmer if you're looking at a small
amount of data I usually start by
pulling it up in different sources so I
can see what I'm working
with but in larger data you won't have
that option it'll just be um to too
large so you need to either bring in a
small amount that you can look at it
like we're doing right now or we can
start looking at it through the python
code so let's let go ahead and move on
and take the next couple steps to
explore the data using python let's go
ahead and see what it looks like in
Python to print the length and the shape
of the data so let's start by printing
the length of the database we can use a
simple lend function from Python and
when I run this you'll see that it's a
thousand long and that's what we
expected there's a th lines of data in
there if you subtract the column head
and this is one of the nice things when
we did the uh balance data from the the
panda read CSV you'll see that the
header is row zero so it automatically
removes a
row and then shows the data separate it
does a good job sorting that data out
for us and then we can use a different
function and let's take a look at that
and again we're going to utilize the
tools in
Panda and since the balance uncore data
was loaded as a panda data
frame we can do a shape on it and let's
go ahead and run the shape and see what
that looks
like what's nice about this shape is not
only does it give me the length of the
data we have a th lines it also tells me
there's five columns so we were looking
at the data we had five columns of data
and then let's take one more step to
explore the data using Python and now
that we've taken a look at the length
and the shape let's go ahead and use the
uh Panda module for head another
beautiful thing in the data set that we
can utilize so let's put that on our
sheet here and we have print data set
and balance data. head and this is a
panda's print statement of its own so it
has its own print feature in there and
then we went ahead and gave a label for
our print job here of data set just a
simple print statement and when we run
that and let's just take a closer look
at that let me zoom in
here there we
go pandas does such a wonderful job of
making this a very clean readable data
set so you can look at the data you can
look at the column header you can have
it uh when you put it as the head it
prints the first five lines of the data
and we always start with zero so we have
five lines we have 0 1 2 3 4 instead of
1 2 3 4 5 that's a standard scripting
and programming set is you want to start
with the zero position and that is what
the data head does it pulls the first
five rows of data puts in a nice format
that you can look at and view very
powerful tool to view the data so
instead of having to flip and open up an
Excel spreadsheet or open Office Cal or
trying to look at a word dock where it's
all scrunched together and hard to read
you can now get a nice open view of what
you're working with we're working with a
shape of a thousand long five wide so we
have five columns and we do the full
data head you can actually see what this
data looks like the initial payment last
payment credit scores house number so
let's take this now that we've explored
the data and let's start digging into
the decision tree so in our next step
we're going to train and build our data
tree and to do that we need to First
separate the data out we're going to
separate into two groups so that we have
something to actually train the data
with and then we have some data on the
side to test it to see how good our
model is remember with any of the
machine learning you always want to have
some kind of test set to to weigh it
against so you know how good your model
is when you distribute it let's go ahead
and break this code down and look at it
in pieces so first we have our X and
Y where do X and Y come from well well X
is going to be our data and Y is going
to be the answer or the target you can
look at it source and Target in this
case we're using X and Y to denote the
data n and the data that we're actually
trying to guess what the answer is going
to be and so to separate it we can
simply put in x equals the balance of
the data. values the first brackets
means that we're going to select all the
lines in the database so it's all the
data and the second one says we're only
going to look at columns 1 through 5
remember we always start with zero zero
is a yes or no and that's whether the
loan went default or not so we want to
start with one if we go back up here
that's the initial payment and it goes
all the way through the house
number well if we want to look at uh 1
through 5 we can do the same thing for Y
which is the answers and we're going to
set that just equal to the zero row so
it's just the zero row and then it's all
rows going in there so now we've divided
this into two different data sets one of
them with the data going in and one with
the
answers next we need to split the
data and here you'll see that we have it
split into four different parts the
first one is your X training your X test
your y train your y
test simply put we have X going in where
we're going to train it and we have to
know the answer to train it with
and then we have X test where we're
going to test that data and we have to
know in the end what the Y was supposed
to be and that's where this train test
split comes in that we loaded earlier in
the modules this does it all for us and
you can see they set the test size equal
to. 3 so it's roughly 30% will be used
in the test and then we use a random
state so it's completely random which
rows it takes out of there and then
finally we get to actually build our
decision tree and they've called it here
clf inter P that's the actual decision
tree or decision tree classifier and in
here they've added a couple variables
which we'll explore in just a minute and
then finally we need to fit the data to
that so we take our clf entropy that we
created and we fit the X train and since
we know the answers for XT train are the
Y train we go ahe and put those in and
let's go ahead and run this and what
most of these sklearn modules do is when
you set up the variable in this case
when we set the clf entropy equal
decision tree class fire it
automatically prints out what's in that
decision tree there's a lot of variables
you can play with in here and it's quite
beyond the scope of this tutorial to go
through all of these and how they work
but we're working on entropy that's one
of the options we've added that it's
completely a random state of 100 so 100%
And we have a max depth of three now the
max depth if you remember above when we
were doing the different graphs of
animals means it's only going to go down
three layers before it stops and then we
have minimal samples of leaves is five
so it's going to have at least five
Leafs at the end so I'll have at least
three splits I'll have no more than
three layers and at least five end
leaves with the final result at the
bottom now that we've created our
decision tree classifier not only
created it but trained it let's go ahead
and apply it and see what that looks
like so let's go ahead and make a
prediction and see what that looks like
we're going to paste our predict code in
here and before we run it let's just
take a quick look at what's it's doing
here
we have a variable y predict that we're
going to do and we're going to use our
variable clf entropy that we
created and then you'll see do predict
and that's very common in the sklearn
modules that there different tools have
the predict when you're actually running
a prediction in this case we're going to
put our X test data in here now if you
delivered this for use an actual
commercial use and distributed it this
this would be the new loans you're
putting in here to guess whether the
person's going to be uh pay them back or
not in this case so we need to test out
the data and just see how good our
sample is how good of our tree does at
predicting the loan payments and finally
since Anaconda Jupiter notebook is works
as a command line for python we can
simply put the Y predict e in to print
it I could just as easily put the
print and put brackets around y predict
in to print it out we'll go ahead and do
that it doesn't matter which way you do
it and you'll see right here that it
runs a prediction this is roughly 300 in
here remember it's 30% of a th000 so you
should have about 300 answers in here
and this tells you which each one of
those lines of our test went in there
and this is what our y predict came out
so let's move on to the next step where
we're going to take this data and try to
figure out just how good a model we have
so here we go since sklearn does all the
heavy Lifting for you and all the math
we have a simple line of code to let us
know what the accuracy is and let's go
ahead and go through that and see what
that means and what that looks like
let's go ahead and paste this in and let
me zoom in a little bit there we go so
you have a nice full picture and we'll
see here we're just going to do a print
accuracy is and then we do the accuracy
score and this was something we imported
um earlier if you remember at the very
beginning let me just scroll up there
real quick so you can see where that's
coming from that's coming from here down
here from sklearn docs import accuracy
score and you could probably run a
script make your own script to do this
very easily how accurate is it how many
out of 300 do we get right and so we put
in our y test that's the one we ran the
predict on and then we put in our y
predict that's the answers we got and
we're just going to multiply that by a
100 because this is just going to give
us an answer as a decimal and we want to
see it as a percentage and let's run
that and see what it looks like and if
you see here we got an accuracy of 93.6
6667 so when we look at the number of
loans and we look at how good our model
fit we can tell people it has about a
93.6 fitting to it so just a quick recap
on that we now have accuracy setup on
here and so we have created a model that
uses a decision tree algorithm to
predict whether a customer will repay
the loan or not the accuracy of the
model is about 94.6% % the bank can now
use this model to decide whether it
should approve the loan request from a
particular customer or not and so this
information is really powerful we might
not be able to as individuals understand
all these numbers because they have
thousands of numbers that come in but
you can see that this is a smart
decision for the bank to use a tool like
this to help them to predict how good
their uh profits going to be off of the
loan balances and how many are going to
default or not there's no better time to
train yourself in the exciting field of
machine learning if you're looking for a
course that covers everything from the
fundamentals to Advanced Techniques like
machine learning algorithm development
and unsupervised learning look no
further than our celtech postgraduate
program in AI machine learning in
partnership with IBM this a ml course
CES the latest tools and Technologies
from the AI ecosystem and features
master classes by ctech faculty and IBM
experts hackathon and ask me anything
sessions this program showcases Celtic
ctm is excellence and IBM's industry
progess the artificial intelligence
course CES key Concepts like statistics
data science with python machine
learning deep learning NLP and
reinforcement learning through an
Interactive Learning model with live
sessions androll now and unlock exciting
a& ml opportunities the course link is
mentioned in the description box below
Forest currently today is used in remote
sensing uh for example they're used in
the etm devices if you're a space buff
that's the enhanced thermatic mapper
they use on satellites which see uh far
outside the human Spectrum for looking
at at land masses and they acquire
images of the Earth's surface the
accuracy is higher and training time is
less than many other machine learning
tools out there also object detection
multiclass object detection is done
using random Forest algorithms a good
example is a traffic where you're trying
to sort out the different cars buses and
things and it provides a better
detection in complicated environments
they very complicated up there and then
we have uh another example connect and
let's take a little closer look at
connect connect they use a random for
Forest as part of the game console and
what it does is it tracks the body
movements and it recreates it in the
game and let's see what that looks like
uh we have a user who performs a step in
this case it looks like Elvis Presley
going there that is then recorded So the
connect registers the movement and then
it marks the user based on accuracy and
it looks like we have uh prints going on
this one from Elvis Presley to Prince
it's great uh so it marks user base on
the accuracy if we look at that a little
closer we have a training set to
identify body parts where are the hands
where are the feet uh what's going on
with the body that then goes into a
random Forest classifier that learns
from it once we train the
classifier and then identifies the body
parts while the person's dancing it's
able to represent that in a computer
format and then based on that it scores
the game and how accurate you are as
being Elvis Presley or prince in you're
dancing let's take take an overview of
what we're going to cover today what's
in it for you we're going to start with
is what is machine learning we're not
going to go into detail on that we're
going to specifically look how the
random Force fits in the machine
learning hierarchy then we're going to
look at some applications of random
Forest what is classification which is
its primary use why use random Forest
what's the benefits of it and how does
it actually come together what is random
forest and then we'll get into random
forest and the decision tree how all
that's like the final step and how it
works and finally we'll get some python
code in there and we'll use the case the
iris flower analysis now if you don't
know what any of these terms mean or
where we're going with this don't worry
we're going to cover all the basics and
have you up and running and even having
doing some basic script in Python by the
end let's take a closer look at types of
machine learning specifically we're
going to look at where the decision tree
fits in with the different machine
learning packages out there we'll start
with the basic types of ma machine
learning there's supervised learning
where you have lots of data and you're
able to train your models there's
unsupervised learning where it has to
look at the data and then divide it
based on its own algorithms without
having any training and then there's
reinforcement learning where you get a
plus or negative if you have the answer
correct this particular tool belongs to
the supervised learning let's take a
closer look at that what that means in
supervised learning uh supervised
learning falls into two groups
classification and regression well we'll
talk about regression a little later and
how that differs this particular format
goes underneath classification so we're
looking at supervised learning and
classification in the machine learning
tools classification is a kind of
problem wherein the outputs are
categorical in nature like yes or no
true or false or zero or one in that
particular framework there's the knnn
where the NN stands for nearest neighbor
Nave Bay the decision tree which is part
of the random Forest that we're studying
today so why random Forest It's always
important to understand why we use this
tool over the other ones what are the
benefits here and so with the random
Forest the first one is there's no
overfitting if you use of multiple trees
reduce the risk of overfitting training
time is less overfitting means that we
have fit the data so close to what we
have as our sample that we pick up on
all the weird parts and instead of
predicting the overall data you're
predicting the weird stuff which you
don't want high accuracy runs
efficiently on large database for large
data it produces highly accurate
predictions in today's world of uh Big
Data this is really important and this
is probably where it really shines this
is where y random Forest really comes in
it estimates missing data data in
today's world is very messy so when you
have a random Forest it can maintain the
accuracy when a large proportion of the
data is missing what that means is if
you have data that comes in from five or
six different areas and maybe they took
one set of Statistics in one area and
they took a slightly different set of
Statistics in the other so they have
some of the sh same shared data but one
is missing like the uh number of
children in the house if you're doing
something over demographics and the
other one is missing the size of the
house it will look at both of those
separately and build two different trees
and then it can do a very good job of
guessing which one fits better even
though it's missing that data let us dig
deep into the theory of exactly how it
works and let's look at what is random
Forest random forest or random decision
Forest is a method that operates by
constructing multiple decision trees the
decision of the majority of the trees is
chosen by the random Forest as the final
decision and this uh we have some nice
Graphics here we have a decision tree
and they actually use a real tree to
denote the decision tree which I love
and given a random some kind of picture
of a fruit this decision tree decides
that the output is it's an apple and we
have a decision tree to where we have
that picture of the fruit goes in and
this one decides that it's a lemon and
the decision 3 tree gets another image
and it decides it's an apple and then
this all comes together in what they
call the random forest and this random
Forest then looks at it and says okay I
got two votes for apple one vote for
lemon the majority is Apples so the
final decision is apples to understand
how the random Forest works we first
need to dig a Little Deeper and take a
look at the random forest and the actual
decision tree and how it builds that
decision tree and looking closer at how
the individual decision trees work we'll
go ahead and continue to use the fruit
example since we're talking about trees
and forests a decision tree is a tree
shaped diagrammed used to determine a
course of action each branch of the tree
represents a possible decision
occurrence or reaction so in here we
have a bowl of fruit and if you look at
that it looks like um they switch from
lemons to oranges so we have oranges
cherries and apples and the first
decision of the decision tree might be
is a diameter greater than or equal to
three and if it says false it knows that
they're cherries because everything else
is bigger than that so all the cherries
fall into that decision so we have all
that data we're training we can look at
that we know that that's what's going to
come up is the color orange well goes hm
orange or red well if it's true then it
comes out as the orange and if it's
false that leaves apples so in this
example it sorts out the fruit in the
bowl or the images of the fruit a
decision tree these are very important
terms to know because these are very
Central to understanding the decision
tree and when working with them the
first is entropy everything on the
decision tree and how it makes those
decision is based on entropy entropy is
a measure of Randomness or
unpredictability in the data set uh then
they also have Information Gain the leaf
node the decision node and the root node
we'll cover these other four terms as we
go down the tree but let's start with
entropy so starting with entropy we have
here a high amount of Randomness what
that means is that whatever is coming
out of this decision if it was going to
guess based on this data it wouldn't be
able to tell you whether it's a lemon or
an apple it would just say it's a fruit
uh so the first thing we want to do is
we want to split this apart and we take
the initial data set we're going to
create a data set one and a data set two
we just split it into two and if you
look at these new data sets after
splitting them the entropy of each of
those sets is much less so for the first
one whatever comes in there it's going
to sort that data and it's going to say
okay if this data goes this direction
it's probably an apple and if it goes
into the other direction it's probably a
lmon so that brings us up to Information
Gain it is the measure of decrease in
the entropy after the data set is split
what that means in here is that we've
gone from one set which has a very high
entropy to two lower sets of entropy and
we've added in the values of E1 for the
first one and E2 for the second two
which are much lower and so that
information gain is increased greatly in
this example and so you can find that
the information gra simply equals uh
decision E1 minus E2 as we're going down
our list of uh definitions we'll look at
the leaf node and the leaf node carries
the classification or the ision so we
look down here to the leaf node we
finally get to our set one or our set
two when it comes down there and it says
okay this object's gone into set one if
it's gone into set one it's going to be
split by some means and we'll either end
up with apples on the leaf node or a
lemon on the leaf node and on the right
it'll either be an apple or lemons those
Leaf nodes or those final decisions or
classifications uh that's the definition
of leaf node in here if we're going to
have a final Leaf where we make the
decision we should have a name for the
nodes above it and they call those
decision nodes a decision node decision
node has two or more branches and you
can see here where we have the uh five
apples and one lemon and in the other
case the five lemons and one apple they
have to make a choice of which tree It
Goes Down based on some kind of
measurement or information given to the
tree and that brings us to our last
definition the root node the topmost
decision node is known as the root node
and this is where you have all of your
data and you have your first decision it
has to make or the first split in
information so far we've looked at a
very general image um with the fruit
being split let's look and see exactly
what that means to split the data and
how do we make those decisions on there
uh let's go in there and find out how
does a decision tree work so let's try
to understand this and let's use a
simple example and we'll stay with the
fruit we have a bowl of fruit and so
let's create a problem statement and the
problem is we want to classify the
different types of fruits in the bowl
based on different features the data set
in the bowl is looking quite messy and
the entropy is high in this case so if
this bow was our decision maker it would
know what choice to make it has so many
choices which one do you pick Apple
grapes or lemons and so we look in here
we're going to start with a dra a
training set so this is our data that
we're training our data with and we have
a number of options here we have the
color and under the color we have red
yellow purple uh we have a diameter uh
331 331 and we have a label Apple lemon
Grapes apple lemon grapes and how do we
split the data we have to frame the
conditions to split the data in such a
way that the Information Gain is the
highest it's very key to note that we're
looking for the best gain we don't want
to just start S in out the smallest
piece in there we want to split it the
biggest way we can and so we measure
this decrease in entropy that's what
they call it entropy there's our entropy
after splitting and now we'll try to
choose a condition that gives us the
highest gain we will do that by
splitting the data using each condition
and checking the gain that we get out of
them the conditions that give us the
highest gain will be used to make the
first split so let's take a look at
these different conditions we have color
we have diameter and if we look
underneath that we have a couple
different values we have diameter equal
= 3 color equals yellow red diameter
equals 1 and when we look at that you'll
see over here we have 1 2 three four 3es
that's a pretty high selection so let's
say the condition gives us the maximum
gain of three so we have the most pieces
fall into that range so our first split
from our decision node is we split the
data based on the diameter is it greater
than or equal to three if it's not
that's false it goes into the greate
bowl and if it's true it goes into a
bowl fold of lemon and apples the
entropy after splitting has decreased
considerably so now we can make two
decisions if you look at there very uh
much less chaos going on there this note
has already attained an enty value of
zero as you can see there's only one
kind of label left for this Branch so no
further splitting is required for this
node however this node on the right is
still requires a split to decrease the
iny further so we split the right node
further based on color if you look at
this if I split it on color that pretty
much cuts it right down the middle it's
the only thing we have left in our
choices of color and diameter too and if
the color is yellow it's going to go to
the right bowl and if it's false it's
going to go to the left Bowl so the
entropy in this case is now zero so now
we have three bowls with zero entropy
there's only one type of data in each
one of those bowls so we can predict a
lemon with 100% accuracy and we can
predict the Apple also with 100%
accuracy along with our grapes up there
so we've looked at kind of a basic tree
in our forest but what we really want to
know is how does a random Forest work as
a whole so to begin our um random Forest
classifier let's say we already have
built three trees and we're going to
start with the first tree that looks
like this just like we did in the
example this tree looks at the diameter
if it's greater than or equal to three
it's true true otherwise it's false so
one side goes to the smaller diameter
one side goes to larger diameter and if
the color is orange it's going to go to
the right true we're using oranges now
instead of lemons and if it's red it's
going to go to the left false and we
build a second tree very similar but
split differently instead of the first
one being split by a diameter uh this
one when they created it if you look at
that first Bowl it has a lot of red
objects so it says is the color red
because that's going to bring our inter
down the fastest and so of course if
it's true it goes to the left if it's
false it goes to the right and then it
looks at the shape false or true and so
on and so on and tree three is the
diameter equal to one and it came up
with this because there's a lot of
cherries in this bowl so that would be
the biggest split on there is is the
diameter equal to one that's going to
drop the entropy the quickest and as you
can see it splits it into true if it
goes false and they've added another
category does it grow in the summer and
if it's false it goes off to the left if
it's true it goes off to the right let's
go ahead and bring these three trees so
you can see them all in one image so
this would be three completely different
trees categorizing a fruit and let's
take a fruit now let's try this and this
fruit if you look at it we've blackened
it out you can't see the color on it so
it's missing data remember one of the
things we talked about earlier is that a
random Forest works really good if
you're missing data if you're missing
pieces so this fruit has an image but
maybe he's a person had a black and
white camera when they took the picture
and we're going to take a look at this
and it's going to have um they put the
color in there so ignore the color down
there but the diameter equals three we
find out it grows in the summer equals
yes and the shape is a circle and if you
go to the right you can look at what one
of the decision trees did this is the
third one is a diameter greater than
equal to three is a color orange well it
doesn't really no on this one but it if
you look at the value it say true and it
go to the right tree 2 classifies it as
cherries is a color equal red is the
shape a circle true it is a circle so
this would look at it and say oh that's
a cherry and then we go to the other
classifier and it says is the diameter
equal one well that's false does it grow
in the summer true so it goes down and
looks at as oranges so how does this
random Forest work the first one says
it's an orange the second one said it
was a cherry and the third one says H
it's an orange and you can guess that if
you have two oranges and one says it's a
cherry uh when you add that all together
the majority of the vote says orange so
the answer is it's classified as an
orange even though we didn't know the
color and we're missing data on it I
don't know about you but I'm getting
tired of fruit so let's switch and I did
promise you we'd start looking at a case
example and get into some python coding
today we're going to use the case the
iris flower analysis oo this is the
exciting part as we roll up our sleeves
and actually look at some python coding
before we start the python coding we
need to go ahead and create a problem
statement wonder what species of Iris do
these flowers belong to let's try to
predict the species of the flowers using
machine learning in Python let's see how
it can be done so here we begin to go
ahead and Implement our python code and
you'll find that the first half of our
implementation is all about organizing
and exploring the data coming in let's
go ahead and take this first step which
is loading the different modules into
python and let's go ahead and put that
in our favorite editor whatever your
favorite editor is in this case I'm
going to be using the Anaconda Jupiter
notebook which is one of my favorites
certainly there's notepad++ and eclipse
and dozens of others or just even using
the python terminal window any of those
will work just fine to go ahead and
explore this python coding so here we go
let's go ahead and flip over to our
jupyter notebook and I've already opened
up a new page for Python 3 code and I'm
just going to paste this right in there
and let's take a look and see what we're
bringing into our python the first thing
we're going to do is from the SK learn.
dat sets import load Iris now this isn't
the actual data this is just the module
that allows us to bring in the data the
load Iris and the iris is so popular
it's been around since 1936 when Ronald
fiser published a paper on it and
they're measuring the different parts of
the flower and based on those
measurements predicting what kind of
flower it is and then if we're going to
do a random Forest classifier we need to
go ahead and import a random forest
classifier from the sklearn module so SK
learn. Ensemble import random force
classifier and then we want to bring in
two more modules um and these are
probably the most commonly used modules
in Python and data science with any of
the um other modules that we bring in
and one is going to be pandas we're
going to import pandas as PD PD is a
common term used for pandas and pandas
is basically creates a data form for us
where when you create a panda's data
frame it looks like an Excel spreadsheet
and you'll see that in a minute when we
start digging deeper into the code panda
is just wonderful cuz it plays nice with
all the other modules in there and then
we have numpy which is our numbers
Python and the numbers python allows us
to do different mathematical sets on
here we'll see right off the bat we're
going to take our NP and we're going to
go ahead and Seed the randomness with it
with zero so np. random. seed is seeding
that is zero this code doesn't actually
show anything we're going to go ahead
and run it cuz I need to make sure I
have all those loaded and then let's
take a look at the next module on here
the next six slides including this one
are all about exploring the data
remember I told you half of this is
about looking at the data and getting it
all set so let's go ahead and take this
code right here the script and let's get
that over into our jupyter notebook and
here we go we've gone ahead and uh run
the import and I'm going to paste the
code down
here and let's take a look and see
what's going on the first thing we're
doing is we're actually loading the iris
data and if you remember up here we
loaded the module that tells it how to
get the iris data now we're actually
assigning that data to the variable Iris
and then we're going to go ahead and use
the DF to Define data frame and that's
going to equal PD and if you remember
that's pandas as PD so that's our pandas
and Panda data frame and then we're
looking at Iris data
and columns equals Iris feature names
and we're going to do the DF head and
let's run this so you can understand
what's going on
here the first thing you want to notice
is that our DF has created uh what looks
like an Excel spreadsheet and in this
Excel spreadsheet we have set the
columns so up on the top you can see the
four different columns and then we have
the data iris. data down below it's a
little confusing without knowing where
this data is coming from so let's look
at the bigger picture and I'm going to
go print I'm just going to change this
for a moment and we're going to print
all of Iris and see what that looks like
so when I print alliv irus I get this
long list of information and you can
scroll through here and see all the
different titles on there what's
important to notice is that first off
there's a brackets at the beginning so
this is a python
dictionary and in a python dictionary
you'll have a key or a label and this
label pulls up whatever information
comes after it so feature names which we
actually used over here under columns is
equal to an array of SE length seel
width pedal length pedal width these are
the different names they have for the
four different columns and if you scroll
down far enough you'll also see data
down here oh goodness it came up right
towards the top and uh data is equal to
the different data we're looking
at now there's a lot of other things in
here like Target we're going to be
pulling that up in a minute and there's
also the names uh the target names which
is further down and we'll show you that
also in a minute let's go ahead and set
that back to the head and this is one of
the neat features of pandas and Panda
data frames is when you do DF doad or
the panda datf frame. head it'll print
the first five lines of the data set in
there along with the headers if you have
them in this case we have the column
headers set to Iris features and in here
you'll see that we have zero 1 2 3 4 in
Python most arrays always start at zero
so when you look at the first five it's
going to be 0 one 2 3 4 not 1 2 3 4 5 so
now we've got our Iris data imported
into a data frame let's take a look at
the next piece of code in here and so in
this section here of the code we're
going to take a look at the Target and
let's go ahead and get this into our
notebook this piece of code so we can
discuss it a little bit more in detail
so here we are in our Jupiter notebook
I'm going to put the code in here and
before I run it I want to look at a
couple things going on so we have a DF
species and this is interesting cuz
right here you'll see where I have DF
species in Brackets which is uh the key
code for creating another column and
here we have iris. Target now these are
both in the pandas setup on here so in
pandas we can do either one I could have
just as easily done Iris and then in
Brackets Target depending on what I'm
working on both are um acceptable let's
go ahead and run this code and see how
this changes and what we've done is
we've added the target from the iris
data set as another column on the
end now what species is this is what
we're trying to predict so we have our
data which tells us the answer for all
these different pieces and then we've
added a column with the answer that way
when we do our final setup we'll have
the ability to program our our neural
network to look for these this different
data and know what a satsa is or a Vera
color which we'll see in just a minute
or virginica those are the three that
are in there and now we're going to add
one more column I know we're organizing
all this data over and over again it's
kind of fun there's a lot of ways to
organize it what's nice about putting
everything onto one data frame is I can
then do a print out and it shows me
exactly what I'm looking at and I'll
show you where you where that's
different where you can alter that and
do it slightly differently but let's go
ahead and put this into our script up to
De now and here we go we're going to put
that down here and we're going to run
that and let's talk a little bit about
what we're doing now we're exploring
data and one of the challenges is
knowing how good your model is did your
model work and to do this we need to
split the data and we split it into two
different parts usually call it the
training and the testing and so in here
we're going to go ahead and put that in
our database so you you can see it
clearly and we've set it DF remember you
can put brackets this is creating
another column is train so we're going
to use part of it for training and this
equals NP remember that stands for numpy
random. uniform so we're generating a
random number between 0 and one and
we're going to do it for each of the
rows that's where the length DF comes
from so each row gets a generated number
and if it's less than 75 it's true and
if it's greater than 75 it's FAL false
this means we're going to take 75% of
the data roughly CU there's a Randomness
involved and we're going to use that to
train it and then the other 25% we're
going to hold off to the side and use
that to test it later on so let's flip
back on over and see what the next step
is so now that we've labeled our
database for which is training and which
is testing let's go ahead and sort that
into two different variables train and
test and let's take this code and let's
bring it into our project and here we go
let's paste it on down here and before I
run this let's just take a quick look at
what's going on here is we have up above
we created remember there's our def.
head which prints the first five rows
and we've added a column is train at the
end and so we're going to take that
we're going to create two variables
we're going to create two new data
frames one's called train one's called
test 75% in train 25% in test and then
to sort that out we're going to do that
by by doing DF our main original data
frame with the iris data in it and if DF
is train equals true it's going to go in
the train and if DF is train equals
false it goes in the test and so when I
run this we're going to print out the
number in each one let's see what that
looks like and you'll see that it puts
118 in the training module and it puts
32 in the testing module which lets us
know that there was 150 lines of data in
here so if you went and looked at the
original data you could see that there's
150 lines and that's roughly 75% in one
and 25% for us to test our model on
afterward so let's jump back to our code
and see where this goes in the next two
steps we want to do one more thing with
our data and that's make it readable to
humans um I don't know about you but I
hate looking at zeros and ones so let's
start with the features and let's go
ahead and take those and make those
readable to humans and let's put that in
our code
let's see here we go paste it in and
you'll see here we've done a couple very
basic things we know that the columns in
our data frame again this is a panda
thing the DF
columns and we know the first four of
them 0 1 2 3 that'd be the first four
are going to be the features or the
titles of those columns and so when I
run this you'll see down here that it
creates an index sea length sea width
pedal length and petal wi and this
should be familiar cuz if you look up
here here's our column titles going
across and here's the first
four one thing I want you to notice here
is that when you're in a command line
whether it's jupyter notebook or you're
running command line in the uh terminal
window if you just put the name of it
it'll print it out this is the same as
doing
print
features and the Shand is you just put
features in here if you're actually
writing a code and saving the script and
running it by remote you really need to
put the print in there but for this when
I run it you'll see it gives me the same
thing but for this we want to go ahead
and we'll just leave it as features
because it doesn't really matter and
this is one of the fun thing about
Jupiter notebooks is I'm just building
the code as we go and then we need to go
ahead and create the labels for the
other part so let's take a look and see
what that for our final step in prepping
our data before we actually start
running the training and the testing is
we're going to go ahead and convert the
species on here into something the
computer understands so let's put this
code into our script and see where that
takes
us all right here we go we set y equal
to pd.
factorize train species of zero so let's
break this down just a little bit we
have our pandas right here PD factorize
what does factorize doing I'm going to
come back to that in just a second let's
look at what trained species is and why
we're looking at the group zero on there
and let's go up here and here is our
species remember this on that we created
this whole column here for species and
then it has Sosa Sosa Sosa Sosa and if
you scroll down enough you'd also see
virginica and Vera color we need to
convert that into something the computer
understands zeros and ones so the train
species of zero because this is in the
format of a of an array of arrays so you
have to have the zero on the end and
then species is just that column
factorize goes in there and looks at the
fact that there's only three of them so
when I run this you'll see that y
generates an array that's equal to in
this case it's a training set and it's
zeros ones and twos representing the
three different kinds of flowers we have
so now we have something that computer
understands and we have a nice table
that we can read and understand and now
finally we get to actually start doing
the predicting so here we go uh we have
two lines of code oh my goodness that
was a lot of work to get to two lines of
code but there is a lot in these two
lines of code so let's take a look and
see what's going on here and put this
into our full script that we're running
and let's paste this in here and let's
take a look and see what this is we have
we're creating a variable clf and we're
going to set this equal to the random
forest classifier and we're passing two
variables in here and there's a lot of
variables you can play with as far as
these two are concerned they're very
standard in jobs all that does is to
prioritize it not something to really
worry about usually when you're doing
this on your own computer you do in jobs
equals 2 if you're working in a larger
or big data and you need to prioritize
it differently this is what that number
does is it changes your priorities and
how it's going to run across the system
and things like that and then the random
state is just how it starts zero is fine
for here
but uh let's go ahead and run
this we also have cf. fit train features
comma Y and before we run it let's talk
about this a little bit more
cf. fit so we're fitting we're training
it we are actually creating our random
Forest classifier right here this is the
code that does everything and we're
going to take our training set remember
we kept our test off to the side and
we're going to take our training set
with the features and then we're we're
going to go ahead and put that in and
here's our Target the Y so the Y is 0 1
and two that we just created and the
features is the actual data going in
that we put into the training set let's
go ahead and run
that and this is kind of an interesting
thing because it printed out the random
force
classifier and everything around it and
so when you're running this in your
terminal window or in a script like this
this automatically treats this like just
like when we were up here and I typed in
y and I printed out y instead of print y
this does the same thing it treats this
as a variable and prints it out but if
you actually running your code that
wouldn't be the case and what is printed
out is it shows us all the different
variables we can change and if we go
down here you can actually see in jobs
equals 2 you can see the random State
equals zero those are the two that we
sent in there you would really have to
dig deep to find out all these different
meaning meanings of all these different
settings on here some of them are
self-explanatory if you kind of think
about it a little bit like Max features
is auto so all the features that we're
putting in there is just going to
automatically take all four of them
whatever we send it it'll take some of
them might have so many features because
you're processing words there might be
like 1.4 million features in there
because you're doing legal documents and
that's how many different words are in
there at that point you probably want to
limit the maximum features that you're
going to process and leaf nodes that's
the end nodes remember we had the fruit
and we're talking about the leaf nodes
like I said there's a lot in this we're
looking at a lot of stuff here so you
might have in this case there's probably
only think three leaf nodes maybe four
you might have thousands of leaf nodes
at which point you do need to put a cap
on that and say okay it can only go so
far and then we're going to use all of
our resources on processing this and
that really is what most of these are
about is limiting the process and making
sure we don't uh overwhelm a system and
there's some other settings in here
again we're not going to go over all of
them warm start equals false warm start
is if you're programming it one piece at
a time externally since we're not we're
not going to have like we're not going
to continually to train this particular
Learning Tree and again like I said
there's a lot of things in here that
you'll want to look up more detail from
the
sklearn and if you're digging in deep
and running a major project on here for
today though all we need to do is fit
our train our features and our Target
why so now we have our training model
what's next if we're going to create a
model we now need to test it remember we
set aside the test feature test group
25% of the data so let's go ahead and
take this code and let's put it into our
uh script and see what that looks like
okay here we go and we're going to run
this and it's going to come out with a
bunch of zeros ones and twos which
represents the three type of flowers the
satsa the virginica and the Versa color
and what we're putting into our predict
is the test features and I always kind
of like to know what it is I am looking
at so real quick we're going to do
test features and remember features is
an
array of SEO length SEO width pedal
length pedal width so when we put it in
this way it actually loads all these
different columns that we loaded into
features so if we did just features let
me just do features in here so you can
see what features looks like this is
just playing with the with Panda's data
frames you'll see that it's an index so
when you put an index in like
this into test features into test it
then takes those columns and creates a
panda data frames from those columns and
in this case we're going to go ahead and
put those into our predict so we're
going to put each one of these lines of
data the 5.0 3.4
1.5.2 and we're going to put those in
and we're going to predict what our new
um Forest classifier is going to come up
with and this is what it predicts it
predicts uh 00001 211 222 and and uh
again this is the flower type satos of
virginica and Versa color so now that
we've taken our test features let's
explore that let's see exactly what that
data means to us so the first thing we
can do with our predicts is we can
actually generate a different prediction
model when I say different we're going
to view it differently it's not that the
data itself is different so let's take
this next piece of code and put it into
our
script so we're pasting it in here and
you'll see that we're doing uh predict
and we've added underscore proba for
probability so there's our cf. predict
probability so we're we're running it
just like we ran it up here but this
time with this we're going to get a
slightly different result and we're only
going to look at the first 10 so you'll
see down here instead of looking at all
of them uh which was uh what 27 you'll
see right down here that this generates
a much larger field on the probability
and let's take a look and see what that
looks like and what that means so when
we do the predict underscore pra for
probability it generates three numbers
so we had three leaf nodes at the end
and if you remember from all the theory
we did this is the predictors the first
one is predicting a one for satos it
predicts a zero for virginica and it
predicts a zero for versacolor and so on
and so on and so on and let's um you
know what I'm going to change this just
a little bit let's look at
10 to 20 just because we
can and we start to get in a little
different of data and you'll see right
down here it gets to this one this line
right here and this line has 0 0.5
0.5 and so if we're going to vote and we
have two equal votes it's going to go
with the first one so it says uh satsa
gets zero votes virginica gets 0.5 votes
versacolor gets 0.5 votes but let's just
go with the virginica since these two
are equal and so on and so on down the
list you can see how they vary on here
so now we've looked at both how to do a
basic predict of the features and we've
looked at the predict probability let's
see what's next on here so now we want
to go ahead and start mapping names for
the plants we want to attach names so
that it makes a little more sense for us
and that's what we're going to do in
these next two steps we're going to
start by setting up our predictions and
mapping them to the name so let's see
what that looks like and let's go ahead
and paste that code in here and run it
and this goes along with the next piece
of code so we'll skip through this
quickly and then come back to it a
little bit so here's
iris. Target
names and uh if you remember correctly
this was the the names that we've been
talking about this whole time the satsa
virginica versacolor and then we're
going to go ahead and do the prediction
again we've run we could have just set a
variable equal to this instead of
rerunning it each time but we're going
ahead and run it again cf. predict test
features remember that Returns the zeros
the ones and the twos and then we're
going to set that equal to predictions
so this time we're actually putting it
in a variable and when I run
this it distributes and it it comes out
as an array and the array is satsa satsa
Sosa Sosa Sosa we're only looking at the
first five we could actually do let's do
the first 25 just so we can see a little
bit more on there and you'll see that it
starts uh mapping it to all the
different flower types the versacolor
and the virginica in there and let's see
how this goes with the next one so let's
take a look at the top part of our
species in here and we'll take this code
and put it in our
script and let's put that down here and
paste it there we go and we'll go ahead
and run it and let's talk about both
these sections of code here and how they
go together the first one is our
predictions and I went ahead and did uh
predictions through 25 let's just do
five and so we have cetosis cetosis
cetosis cetosis that's what we're
predicting from our test model and then
we come down here and we look at test
species I remember I could have just
done test. species. head and you'll see
it says Sosa Sosa Sosa Sosa and they
match so so the first one is what our
forest is doing and the second one is
what the actual data is now is we need
to combine these so that we can
understand what that means we need to
know how good our forest is how good it
is at predicting the features so that's
where we come up to the next step which
is lots of fun we're going to use a
single line of code to combine our
predictions and our actuals so we have a
nice chart to look at and let's go ahead
and put that in our script in our
Jupiter notebook here let's see what
let's go ahead and paste that in and
then uh I'm going to because I'm on the
Jupiter notebook I can do a control
minus so you can see the whole line
there there we go resize it and let's
take a look and see what's going on here
we're going to create in pandas remember
PD stands for pandas and we're doing a
cross tab this function takes two sets
of data and creates a chart out of them
so when I run it you'll get a nice chart
down here and we have the predicted
species so across the top you'll see the
Sosa vers color vinica and the actual
species Sosa Versa color vinica and so
the way to read this chart and let's go
ahead and take a look on how to read
this chart here when you read this chart
you have Sosa where they meet you have
vericolor where they meet and you have
virginica where they meet and they're
meeting where the actual and the
predicted agree so this is the number of
accurate predictions so in this case it
equals 30 if you had 13 + 5 + 12 you get
30 and then we notice here where it says
virginica but it was supposed to be
versacolor this is inaccurate so now we
have two two inaccurate predictions and
30 accurate predictions so we'll say
that the model accuracy is 93 that's
just 30 ided 32 and if we multiply by
100 we can say that it is 93% accurate
so we have a 93% accuracy with our model
I did want to add one more quick thing
in here on our scripting before we wrap
it up so let's flip back on over to my
script in here we're going to take this
uh line of code from up above I don't
know if you remember it but predicts
equals the iris. target names so we're
going to map it to the names and we're
going to run the prediction and we read
it on test features but you know we're
not just testing it we want to actually
deploy it so at this point I would go
ahead and change this and this is an
array of arrays this is really important
when you're running these to know that
so you need the double brackets and I
could actually create data maybe let's
let's just do two flowers so maybe I'm
processing more data coming in and we'll
put two flowers in here and then uh I
actually want to see what the answer is
so let's go ahead and type in PRS and
print that out and when I run this
you'll see that I've now predicted two
flowers that maybe I measured in my
front yard as Versa color and Versa
color not surprising since I put the
same data in for each one this would be
the actual uh end product going out to
be used on data that you don't know the
answer
for so that's going to conclude our
scripting part of this so what is gin
clustering gans's clustering is an
unsupervised learning algorithm in this
case you don't have labeled data unlike
in supervised learning so you have a set
of data and you want to group them and
as the name suggests you want to put
them into clusters which means objects
that are similar in nature similar in
characteristics need to be put together
so that's what K means clustering is all
about the term k is basically is a
number so we need to tell the system how
many clusters we need to perform so if K
is equal to 2 there will be two clusters
if K is equal to 3 three clusters and so
on and so forth that's what the k stands
for and of course there is a way of
finding out what is the best or Optimum
value of K for a given data we will look
at that so that is K means cluster so
let's take an example K's clustering is
used in many many scenarios but let's
take an example of Cricket the game of
cricket let's say you received data of a
lot of players from maybe all over the
country or all over the world and this
data has information about the runs
scored by by the people or by the player
and the wickets taken by the player and
based on this information we need to
Cluster this data into two clusters
batsmen and Bowlers so this is an
interesting example let's see how we can
perform this so we have the data which
consists of primarily two
characteristics which is the runs and
the wickets so the bowlers basically
take wickets and the batsmen score runs
there will be of course a few Bowlers
who can score some runs and similarly
there will be some batsman who will Who
would have taken a few wickets but with
this information we want to Cluster
those players into batsmen and Bowlers
so how does this work let's say this is
how the data is so there are information
there is information on the Y AIS about
the Run code and on the x-axis about the
wickets taken by the players so if we do
a quick plot this is how it would look
and and um when we do the clustering we
need to have the Clusters like shown in
the third diagram out here so we need to
have a cluster which consists of people
who have scored High runs which is
basically the batsman and then we need a
cluster with people who have taken a lot
of wickets which is typically the
bowlers there may be a certain amount of
overlap but we will not talk about it
right now so with C in's clustering we
will have here that means K is equal to
2 and we will have two clusters which is
batsmen and Bowlers so how does this
work the way it works is the first step
in cayman's clustering is the allocation
of two centroids randomly so two points
are assigned as so-called centroids so
in this case we want two clusters which
means K is equal to 2 so two points have
been randomly assigned as centroids keep
in mind these points can be anywhere
there are random points they are not
initially they are not really the
centroids centroid means it's a central
point of a given data set but in this
case when it starts off it's not really
the centroid okay so these points though
in our presentation here we have shown
them one point closer to these data
points and another closer to these data
points they can be assigned randomly
anywhere okay right so that's the first
step the next step is to determine the
distance of each of the data points from
each of the randomly assigned centroids
so for example we take this point and
find the distance from this centroid and
the distance from this centroid this
point is taken and the distance is form
from this centroid and this Cent and so
on and so forth so for every point the
distance is measured from both the
centroids and and then whichever
distance is less that point is assigned
to that centroid so for example in this
case visually it is very obvious that
all these data points are assigned to
this centroid and all these data points
are assigned to this centroid and that's
what is represented here in blue color
and in this yellow color the next step
is to actually determine the central
point or the actual centroid for these
two clusters so we have this one initial
cluster this one initial cluster but as
you can see these points are not really
the centroid centroid means it should be
the central position of this data set
Central position of this data set so
that is what needs to be determined as
the next step so the central point or
the actual centroid is determined and
the original randomly allocated centroid
is repositioned to the actual centroid
of this new clusters and this process is
actually repeated now what might happen
is some of these points may get
reallocated in our example that is not
happening probably but it may so happen
that the distance is found between each
of these data points once again with
these centroids and if there is if it is
required some points may be reallocated
we will see that in a later example but
for now we will keep it simple so this
process is continued till the centroid
repositioning stops and that is our
final cluster so this is our so after
iteration we come to this position this
situation where the centroid doesn't
need any more repositioning and that
means our algorithm has converged
convergence has occurred and we have the
cluster two clusters we have the
Clusters with a centroid so this process
is repeated the process of calculating
the distance and repositioning the
centroid is is repeated till the
repositioning stops which means that the
algorithm has converged and we have the
final cluster with the data points and
the cids so this is what you're going to
learn from this session we will talk
about the types of clustering what is
K's clustering application of K's
clustering K's clustering is done using
distance measure so we will talk about
the common distance measures and then we
will talk about about how K's clustering
works and go into the details of kain's
clustering algorithm and then we will
end with the demo and a use case for C's
clustering so let's begin first of all
what are the types of clustering there
are primarily two categories of
clustering hierarchical clustering and
then partitional clustering and each of
these categories are further subdivided
into agglomerative and divisive
clustering and K means and fuzzy c means
clustering let's take a quick look at
what each of these types of clustering
are in hierarchical clustering the
Clusters have a tree like structure and
hierarchical clustering is further
divided into agglomerative and divisive
agglomerative clustering is a bottomup
approach we begin with each element as a
separate cluster and merge them into
successively larger clusters so for
example we have a b CDE e f we start by
combining B and C form one cluster cler
d and e form one more then we combine d
and f one more bigger cluster and then
add BC to that and then finally a to it
compared to that divisive clustering or
divisive clustering is a top- down
approach we begin with the whole set and
proceed to divide it into successively
smaller clusters so we have AB bcde e f
we first take that as a single cluster
and then break it down into a b c d e
and f then we have partitional
clustering split into two subtypes k
means clustering and fuzzy c means in K
means clustering the objects are divided
into the number of clusters mentioned by
the number K that's where the K comes
from so if we say k is equal to 2 the
objects are divided into two clusters C1
and C2 and the way it is done is the
features or characteristics are compared
and all objects having similar
characteristics are are club together so
that's how K means clustering is done we
will see it in more detail as we move
forward and fuzzy c means is very
similar to K means in the sense that it
clubs objects that have similar
characteristics together but while in K
means clustering two objects cannot
belong to or any object a single object
cannot belong to two different clusters
in c means objects can belong to more
than one cluster so that is the primary
difference between K means and fuzzy c
means so what are some of the
applications of K means clustering K
means clustering is used in a variety of
examples or variety of business cases in
real life starting from academic
performance diagnostic system search
engines and wireless sensor networks and
many more so let us take a little deeper
look at each of these examples academic
performance So based on the scores of
the students students are categorized
into a b c and so on clustering forms a
backbone of search engines when a search
is performed the search results need to
be grouped together the search engines
very often use clustering to do this and
similarly in case of wireless sensor
networks the clustering algorithm plays
the role of finding the cluster heads
which collects all the data in its
respective cluster so clustering
especially K means clustering uses
distance measure so let's take a look at
what what is distance measure so while
these are the different types of
clustering in this video we will focus
on K means clustering so distance
measure tells how similar some objects
are so the similarity is measured using
what is known as distance measure and
what are the various types of distance
measures there is ukian distance there
is Manhattan distance then we have
squared ukian distance measure and
cosine distance measure these are some
of the distance measures supported by K
means clustering let's take a look at
each of these what is ukian distance
measure this is nothing but the distance
between two points so we have learned in
high school how to find the distance
between two points this is a little
sophisticated formula for that but we
know a simpler one is square root of Y2
- y1 s + X2 - X1 s so this is an
extension of that formula so that is the
ukian distance between two points what
is the squared ukian distance measure
it's nothing but the square of the ukian
distance as the name suggests so instead
of taking the square root we leave the
square as it is and then we have
Manhattan distance measure in case of
Manhattan distance it is the sum of the
distances across the x-axis and the y
axis
and note that we are taking the absolute
value so that the negative values don't
come into play so that is the Manhattan
distance measure then we have cosine
distance measure in this case we take
the angle between the two vectors formed
by joining the points from the origin so
that is the cosine distance measure okay
so that was a quick overview about the
various distance measures that are
supported by K means now let's go and
check how exactly K means clustering
work works okay so this is how kain's
clustering works this is like a
flowchart of the whole process there is
a starting point and then we specify the
number of clusters that we want now
there are couple of ways of doing this
we can do by trial and error so we
specify a certain number maybe K is
equal to 3 or four or five to start with
and then as we progress we keep changing
until we get the best clusters of or
there is a technique called elbow
technique whereby we can determine the
value of K what should be the best value
of K how many clusters should be formed
so once we have the value of K we
specify that and then the system will
assign that many centroids so it picks
randomly that to start with randomly
that many points that are considered to
be the centroids of these clusters and
then it measures the distance of each of
the data points points from these
centroids and assigns those points to
the corresponding centroid from which
the distance is minimum so each data
point will be assigned to the centroid
Which is closest to it and thereby we
have K number of initial clusters
however this is not the final clusters
The Next Step it does is for the new
groups for the Clusters that I have been
form formed it calculates the mean
position thereby calculates the new
centroid position the position of the
centroid moves compared to the randomly
allocated one so it's an iterative
process once again the distance of each
point is measured from this new centroid
point and if required the data points
are reallocated to the new centroids and
the mean position or the new centroid is
calculated once again if the centroid
moves then the iteration continues which
means the convergence has not happened
the clustering has not converged so as
long as there is a movement of the
centroid this iteration keeps happening
but once the centroid stops moving which
means that the cluster has converged or
the clustering process has converged
that will be the end result so now we
have the final position of the centroid
and the data points are allocated
accordingly to the closest centroid I
know it's a little difficult to
understand from this simple flowchart so
let's do a little bit of visualization
and see if we can explain it better
let's take an example if we have a data
set for a grocery shop so let's say we
have a data set for a grocery shop and
now we want to find out how many
clusters this has to be spread across so
how do we find the optimum number of
clusters there is a technique called the
elbow method so when these clusters are
formed there is a parameter called
within sum of squares and the lower this
value is the better the cluster is that
means all these points are very close to
each other so we use this within sum of
squares as a measure to find the optimum
number of clusters that can be formed
for a given data set so we create
clusters or we let the system create
clusters of a variety of numbers maybe
of 10 10 clusters and for each value of
K the within SS is measured and the
value of K which has the least amount of
within SS or WSS that is taken as the
optimum value of K so this is the
diagrammatic representation so we have
on the Y AIS the within sum of squares
or WSS and on the x-axis we have the
number of clusters so as you can imagine
if you have K is equal to 1 which means
all the data points are in a single
cluster the withs value will be very
high because they are probably scattered
all over the moment you split it into
two there will be a drastic fall in the
within SS value and that's what is
represented here but then as the value
of K increases the decrease the rate of
decrease
will not be so high it will continue to
decrease but probably the rate of
decrease will not be high so that gives
us an idea so from here we get an idea
for example the optimum value of K
should be either two or three or at the
most four but beyond that increasing the
number of clusters is not dramatically
changing the value in WSS because that
pretty much gets stabilized okay now
that we have got the value of K and
let's assume that these are our delivery
points the next step is basically to
assign two centroids randomly so let's
say C1 and C2 are the centroids assigned
randomly now the distance of each
location from the centroid is measured
and each point is assigned to the
centroid Which is closest to it so for
example these points are very obvious
that these are Clos to C1 whereas this
point is far away from C2 so these
points will be assigned which are close
to C1 will be assigned to C1 and these
points or locations which are close to
C2 will be assigned to C2 and then so
this is the how the initial grouping is
done this is part of C1 and this is part
of C2 then the next step is to calculate
the actual centroid of this data because
remember C1 and C2 are not the Cent rids
they have been randomly assigned points
and only thing that has been done was
the data points which are closest to
them have been assigned to them but now
in this step the actual centroid will be
calculated which may be for each of
these data set somewhere in the middle
so that's like the main point that will
be calculated and the centroid will
actually be positioned or repositioned
there same with C2 so the new centroid
for this group is C2 this new position
and C1 is in this new position once
again the distance of each of the data
points is calculated from these
centroids now remember it's not
necessary that the distance Still
Remains the or each of these data points
still remain in the same group by
recalculating the distance it may be
possible that some points get
reallocated like so you see this so this
point earlier was closer to C2 because
C2 was here but after calculating
repositioning it is observed that this
is closer to C1 than C2 so this is the
new grouping so some points will be
reassigned and again the centroid will
be calculated and if the centroid
doesn't change so that is a repeative
process iterative process and if the
centroid doesn't change once the
centroid stops changing that means the
algorithm has converged and this is our
final cluster with this as the center
CID C1 and C2 as the centroids these
data points as a part of each cluster so
I hope this helps in understanding the
whole process iterative process of K
means clustering so let's take a look at
the K means clustering algorithm let's
say we have X1 X2 X3 n number of points
as our inputs and we want to split this
into K clusters or we want to create K
clusters so the first step is to run
randomly pick K points and call them
centroids they are not real centroids
because centroid is supposed to be a
center point but they are just called
centroids and we calculate the distance
of each and every input point from each
of the centroids so the distance of X1
from C1 from C2 C3 each of the distances
we calculate and then find out which
distance is the lowest and assign X1 to
that particular random centroid repeat
that process for X2 calculate its
distance from each of the centroids C1
C2 C3 up to CK and find which is the
lowest distance and assign X2 to that
particular CID same with X3 and so on so
that is the first round of assignment
that is done now we have K groups
because there are we have assigned the
value of uh k K so there are K centroids
and uh so there are K groups all these
inputs have been split into K groups
however remember we picked the centroids
randomly so they are not real centroids
so now what we have to do we have to
calculate the actual centroids for each
of these groups which is like the main
position which means that the position
of the randomly selected centroids will
now change and they will be
the main positions of these newly formed
K groups and once that is done we once
again repeat this process of calculating
the distance right so this is what we
are doing as a part of step four we
repeat step two and three so we again
calculate the distance of X1 from the
centroid C1 C2 C3 and then see which is
the lowest value and assign X1 to that
calc calculate the distance of X2 from
C1 C2 C3 or whatever up to CK and find
whichever is the lowest distance and
assign X2 to that croid and so on in
this process there may be some
reassignment X1 was probably assigned to
Cluster C2 and after doing this
calculation maybe now X1 is assigned to
C1 so that kind of reallocation may
happen so we repeat the steps two and
three till the position of the centroids
don't change or stop changing and that's
when we have convergence so let's take a
detail look at at each of these steps so
we randomly pick K cluster centers we
call them centroids because they are not
initially they are not really the
centroids so we let us name them C1 C2
up to CK and then step two we assign
each data point to the closest Center so
what we do we calculate the distance of
each x value from from each C value so
the distance between X1 C1 distance
between X1 C2 X1 C3 and then we find
which is the lowest value right that's
the minimum value we find and assign X1
to that particular centroid then we go
next to X2 find the distance of X2 from
C1 X2 from C2 X2 from C3 and so on up to
CK and then assign it to the point or to
the centroid which has the lowest value
and so on so that is Step number two in
Step number three We Now find the actual
centroid for each group so what has
happened as a part of Step number two we
now have all the points all the data
points grouped into K groups because we
we wanted to create K clusters right so
we have K groups each one may be having
a certain number of input values they
need not be equally distributed by the
way based on the distance we will have K
groups but remember the initial values
of the C1 C2 were not really the
centroids of these groups right we
assigned them randomly so now in step
three we actually calculate the centroid
of each group which means the original
point which we thought was the centroid
will shift to the new position which is
the actual centroid for each of these
groups okay and we again calculate the
distance so we go back to step two which
is what we calculate again the distance
of each of these points from the newly
positioned centroids and if required we
reassign these points to the new
centroids so as I said earlier there may
be a reallocation so we now have a new
set or a new group we still have K
groups but but the number of items and
the actual assignment may be different
from what was in step two here okay so
that might change then we perform step
three once again to find the new
centroid of this new group so we have
again a new set of clusters new
centroids and new assignments we repeat
this step two again once again we find
and then it is possible that after
iteration hting through three or four or
five times the centroid will stop moving
in the sense that when you calculate the
new value of the centroid that will be
same as the original value or there will
be very marginal change so that is when
we say convergence has occurred and that
is our final cluster that's the
formation of the final cluster all right
so let's see a couple of demos of uh K
means cluster string we will actually
see some live Demos in uh python
notebook using python notebook but
before that let's find out what's the
problem that we are trying to solve the
problem statement is let's say Walmart
wants to open a chain of stores across
the State of Florida and uh it wants to
find the optimal store locations now the
issue here is if they open too many
stores close to each other obviously the
they will not make profit but but if
they if the stores are too far apart
then they will not have enough sales so
how do they optimize this now for an
organization like Walmart which is an
e-commerce giant they already have the
addresses of their customers in their
database so they can actually use this
information or this data and use K means
clustering to find the optimal location
now before we go into the
python notebook and show you the Live
code I wanted to take you through very
quickly a summary of the code in the
slides and then we will go into the
python notebook so in this block we are
basically importing all the required
libraries like numpy matplot Leb and so
on and we are loading the data that is
available in the form of let's say the
addresses for Simplicity take we will
just take them as some data points then
the next thing we do is quickly do a
scatter plot to see how they are related
to each other with respect to each other
so in the scatter plot we see that there
are a few distinct groups already being
formed so you can actually get an idea
about how the cluster would look and how
many clusters what is the optimal number
of clusters and then starts the actual K
means clustering process so we will
assign each of these points to the
centroids and then check whether they
are the optimal distance which is the
shortest distance and assign each of the
points data points to the centroids and
then go through this iterative process
till the whole process converges and
finally we get an output like this so we
have four distinct
clusters and um which is if we can say
that this this is how the population is
probably distributed across Florida
State and uh the centroids are like the
location where the store should be the
optimum location where the store should
be so that's the way we determine the
best locations for the store and that's
how we can help Walmart find the best
locations for the stores in Florida so
now let's take this into python notebook
let's see how this looks looks when we
are learning running the code live all
right so this is the code for K means
clustering in Jupiter notebook we have a
few examples here which we will
demonstrate how K means clustering is
used and even there is a small
implementation of kin's clustering as
well okay so let's get started okay so
this block is basically importing the
various libraries that are required like
M plot lib and numpy and so on and so
forth which should be used as a part of
the code then we are going and creating
blobs which are similar to clusters now
this is a very neat feature which is
available in psychic learn make blobs is
a nice feature which creates clusters of
data sets so that's a wonderful
functionality that is readily available
for us to create some test data kind of
thing okay so that's exactly what we are
doing here we are using make blobs and
we can specify how many clusters we want
so centers we are mentioning here so it
will go ahead and so we just mentioned
four so it will go ahead and create some
test data for us and this is how it
looks as you can see visually also we
can figure out that there are four
distinct classes or clusters in this
data set and that is what make blobs
actually provides now from here onwards
we will basically run run the standard K
means functionality that is readily
available so we really don't have to
implement K means itself the C's
functionality of the the function is
readily available you just need to feed
the data and we create the Clusters so
this is the code for that we import K
means and then we create an instance of
K means and we specify the value of K
this ncore clusters is the value of K
remember K means in K means K is
basically the number of clusters that
you want to create and it is a integer
value so this is where we are specifying
that so we have K is equal to 4 and so
that instance is created we take that
instance and as with any other machine
learning functionality fit is what we
use the function or the method rather
fit is what we use to train the model
here there is no real training uh kind
of thing but that's the call okay so we
are calling fit and what we are doing
here we are just passing the data so X
has these values the data that has been
created right so that is what we are
passing here and uh this will go ahead
and create the Clusters and uh then we
are
using after doing uh fit We Run The
predict which basically assigns for each
of these observations which cluster it
Bel belongs to all right so it will name
the Clusters maybe this is cluster one
this is two three and so on or will
actually start from zero cluster 0o 1 2
and three maybe and then for each of the
observations it will assign based on
which cluster it belongs to it will
assign a value so that is stored in Yore
K means when we call predict that is
what it does and we can take a quick
look at these uh Yore K means or with
the cluster numbers that have been
assigned for each observation so this is
the cluster number assigned for
observation one maybe this is for
observation two observation three and so
on so we have how many about I think 300
samples right so all the 300 samples
there are 300 values here each of them
the cluster number is given and the
cluster number goes from 0 to three so
there are four clusters so the numbers
go from 0 1 2 3 so that's what is seen
here okay now so this was a quick
example of generating some dummy data
and then clustering that okay and this
can be applied if you have proper data
you can just load it up into X for
example here and then run the C so this
is the central part of the K's
clustering program example so you
basically create an instance and you
mention how many clusters you want by
specifying this parameter andore
clusters and that is also the value of K
and then pass the data to get the values
now the next section of this code is the
implementation of a k means now this is
kind of a rough implementation of the K
means algorithm so we will just walk you
through I will walk you through the code
uh at each step what it is doing and
then we will see a couple of more
examples of how K means clustering uh
can be used in maybe some real life
examples real life use cases all right
so in this case here what we doing doing
is basically implementing K means
clustering and there is a function for a
library calculates for a given two pairs
of points it will calculate the the
distance between them and see which one
is the closest and so on so this is like
this is pretty much like what K means
does right so it calculates the distance
of each point or each data set from
predefined centroid and then based on
whichever is the lowest this particular
data point is assigned to that Cent so
that is basically available as a
standard function and we will be using
that here so as explained in the slides
the first step that is done in case of
C's clustering is to randomly assign
some centroids so as a first step we
randomly allocate a couple of centroids
which we call here we calling as
centers and then we put this in a loop
and we take it through an iterative
process for each of the data points we
first find out using this function
pairwise distance argumen for each of
the points we find out which one which
Center or which randomly selected
centroid is the closest and accordingly
we assign that data or the data point to
that particular centroid or cluster and
once that is done for all the data
points we C calculate the new centroid
by finding out the mean position with
the the center position right so we
calculate the new centroid and then we
check if the new centroid is the
coordinates or the position is the same
as the previous croid the positions we
will compare and if it is the same that
means the process has converged so
remember we do this process till the
centroids or the centroid doesn't move
anymore right right so the centroid gets
relocated each time this relocation is
done so the moment it doesn't change
anymore the position of the centroid
doesn't change anymore we know that
convergence has occurred so till then so
you see here this is like an infinite
Loop while true is an infinite Loop it
only breaks when the centers are the
same the new center and the old Center
positions are the same and once that is
uh done we return the centers and the
labels now of course as explained this
is not a very sophisticated and advanced
implementation very basic implementation
because one of the flaws in this is that
sometimes what happens is the centroid
the position will keep moving but in the
change will be very minor so in that
case also that is actually convergence
right so for example the change is
01 we can consider that as convergence
otherwise what will happen is this will
either take forever or it will be never
ending so that's a small flaw here so
that is something additional checks may
have to be added here but again as
mentioned this is not the most
sophisticated implementation this is
like a kind of a rough implementation of
the K means clustering okay so if we
execute this code this is what we get as
the output so this is the definition of
this particular function and then we
call that find underscore clusters and
we pass our data X and the number of
clusters which is four and if we run
that and plot it this is the output that
we get so this is of course each cluster
is represented by a different color so
we have a cluster in green color yellow
color and so on and so forth and these
big points here these are the centroids
this the final position of the centroids
and as you can see visually also this
appears like a kind of a center of all
these points here right similarly this
is like the center of all these points
here and so on so this is the example or
this is an example of a implementation
of K means clustering and uh next we
will move on to see a couple of examples
of how K means clustering is used in
maybe some real life scenarios or use
cases in the next example or demo we're
going to see how we can use K's
clustering to perform color compression
we will take a couple of images so there
will be two examples and uh we will try
to use C's clustering to compress the
colors this is a common situation in
image processing when you have an image
with millions of uh colors but then you
cannot render it on some devices which
may not have enough memory uh so that is
the scenario where where something like
this can be used so before again we go
into the python notebook let's take a
look at quickly the the code as usual we
import the libraries and then we import
the image and uh then we will flatten it
so the reshaping is basically we have
the image information is stored in the
form of pixels and if the image is like
for example 427 by 640 and it has three
colors so that's the overall dimension
of the of the initial image we just
reshape it and um then fed this to to
our algorithm and this will then create
clusters of only 16 clusters so this
this colors there are millions of colors
and now we need to bring it down to 16
colors so we use K is equal to 16 and U
this is how when we visualize this is
how it looks there are these are all
about 16 million possible colors the
input color space as 16 million possible
colors and we just compress it to 16
colors so this is how it would look when
we compress it to 16 colors and this is
how the original image looks and after
compression to 16 colors this is of the
new image looks as you can see there is
not a lot of information that has been
lost though the image quality is
definitely reduced a little bit so this
is an example which we are going to now
see in Python notebook let's go into the
python notebook and once again as always
we will import some libraries and load
this image called flower. jpg okay so
let we load that and this is how it
looks this is the original image which
has I think 16 million colors and uh
this is the shape of this image which is
basically what is the shape is nothing
but the overall size right so this is
427 pixel by 640 pixel and then there
are three layers which is this three
basically is for RGB which is red green
blue so color image will have that right
so that is the shape of this now what we
need to do is data let's take a look at
how data is looking so let me just
create a new cell and show you what is
in data basically we have captured this
information so data is what let me just
show you
here
all right so let's take a look at China
what are the values in China and if we
see here this is how the data is stored
this is nothing but the pixel values
okay so this is like a matrix and each
one has about for for this 427 by 640 P
pixels all right so this is how it looks
now the issue here is these values are
large the numbers are large so we need
to normalize them to between 0 and one
right so that's why we will basically
create one more variable which is data
which will contain the values between 0
and one and the way to do that is divide
by 255 so we divide China by 255 and we
get the new values in data so let's just
run this piece of code and this is the
shape so we now have also yeah what we
have done is we changed using reshape we
converted into the three-dimensional
into a two-dimensional data set and let
us also take a look at
how let me just
insert probably a cell here and take a
look at how data is looking all right so
this is how data is looking and now you
see this is the values are between zero
and one right so if you earlier noticed
in case of china the values were large
numbers now everything is between 0er
and one this is one of the things we
need to do all right so after that the
next thing that we need to do is to
visualize this and uh we can take random
set of maybe 10,000 points and plot it
and check and see how this looks so let
us just plot this and so this is how the
original the color the pixel
distribution is these are two plots one
is red against Green and another is red
against Blue and this is the original
distribution of the color so then what
we will do is we will use K's clustering
to create just 16 clusters for the
various colors and then apply that to
the image now what will happen is since
the data is large because there are
millions of colors using regular K means
maybe a little time consuming so there
is another version of K means which is
called mini batch gaming so we will use
that which is which processes in the
overall concept Remains the Same but
this basically processes it in smaller
batches that's the only thing okay so
the results will pretty much be the same
so let's go ahead and execute this piece
of code and also visualize this so that
we can see that there are this this is
how the 16 colors uh would look so this
is red against Green and this is red
against Blue there is uh quite a bit of
similarity between this original color
schema and the new one right so it
doesn't look very very completely
different or anything like that now we
apply this the newly created colors to
the image and uh we can take a look how
this is uh looking now we can compare
both the images so this is our original
image and this is our new image so as
you can see there is not a lot of
information that has been lost uh it
pretty much looks like the original
image yes we can see that for example
here there is a little bit uh it appears
a little dlish compared to this one
right because uh we kind of took off
some of the finer details of the color
but overall the high level information
has been maintained at the same time the
main advantage is that now this can be
this is an image which can be rendered
on a device which may not be that very
sophisticated now let's take one more
example with a different image in the
second example we will take an image of
the Summer Palace in China and we repeat
the same process this is a high
definition color image with millions of
colors and also uh
three-dimensional uh now we will reduce
that to 16 colors using K means
clustering and um we do the same process
like before we reshape it and then we
cluster the colors to 16 and then we
render the image once again and we will
see that the color the quality of the
image is slightly deteriorates as you
can see here this has much finer details
in this which are probably missing here
but then that's the compromise because
there are some devices which may not be
able to handle this kind of high density
images so let's run this code in Python
notebook all right so let's apply the
same technique for another picture which
is uh even more intricate and has
probably much complicated color schema
so this is the image now once again uh
we can take a look at the shape which is
27 by 640 by 3 and this is the new data
would look somewhat like this compared
to the flower image so we have some new
values here and we will also bring this
as you can see the numbers are much big
so we will much bigger so we will now
have to uh scale them down to values
between 0er and one and that is done by
dividing by 255 so let's go ahead and uh
do that and reshape it okay so we get a
two- dimensional Matrix and uh we will
then as a next step we will go ahead and
visualize this how it looks the the 16
colors and this is basically how it
would look 16 million colors and now we
can create the Clusters out of this the
16 cin clusters we will create so this
is how the distribution of the pixels
would look with 16 colors and then we go
ahead and uh apply this and visualize
how it is looking for with the with the
new just the 16 color so once again as
you can see this looks much richer in
color but at the same time and this
probably doesn't have as we can see it
doesn't look as rich as this one but
nevertheless the information is not lost
the shape and all that stuff and this
can be also rendered on a slightly a
device which is probably not that
sophisticated okay so that's pretty much
it so we have seen two examples of how
color compression can be done uh using
K's clustering and we have also seen in
the previous examples of how to
implement K means the code to roughly
how to implement K means clustering and
we use some sample data using blob to
just execute the C's clustering all
right so have you ever wondered how your
mail provider implements spam filtering
or how online news channels perform news
text classification or how companies
perform sentimental analysis of Their
audience on social media all of this and
more is done through a machine learning
algorithm called naive Bay classifier
what is naive Bay let's start with a
basic introduction to the Baye theorem
named after Thomas baze from the 1700s
who first coined this in the western
literature naive Bay classifier works on
the principle of conditional probability
as given by the Baye theorem before we
move ahead let us go through some of the
simple Concepts in the probability that
we will be using let us consider the
following example of tossing two coins
here we have two quarters and if we look
at all the different possibilities of
what they can come up as we get that
they can come up as head heads they can
come up as head tail tell head and tell
tail when doing the math on probability
we usually denote probability as a p a
capital P so the probability of getting
two heads equals 1/4 you can see on our
data set we have two heads and this
occures once out of the four
possibilities and then the probability
of at least one tail occurs 3/4 of the
time you'll see on three of the coin
tosses we have tails in them and out of
four that's 3/4s and then the
probability of the second coin being
head given the first coin is tail is 1/2
and the probability of getting two heads
given the first coin is a head is 1/2
we'll demonstrate that in just a minute
and show you how that math works now
when we're doing it with two coins it's
easy to see but when you have something
more complex you can see where these Pro
these formulas really come in and work
so the base theorem gives us the
conditional probability of an event a
given another event B has occurred in
this case the first coin toss will be B
and the second coin toss a this could be
confusing because we've actually
reversed the order of them and go from B
to a instead of a to B you'll see this a
lot when you work in probabilities the
reason is we're looking for event day we
want to know what that is so we're going
to label that a since that's our focus
and then given another event B has
occurred in the base theorem as you can
see on the left the probability of a
occurring given B has occurred equals
the probability of B occurring given a
has occurred times the probability of a
over the probability of B this simple
formula can be moved around just like
any algebra formula and we could do the
probability of a after a given B times
probability of b equals the probability
of B given a times probability of a you
can easily move that around and multiply
it and divide it out let us apply base
theorem to our example here we have our
two quarters and we'll notice that the
first two probabilities of getting two
heads and at least one tail we compute
directly off the data so you can easily
see that we have one example HH out of
four 1/4 and we have three with tells in
them giving us 3/4 or 34
75% the second condition the second uh
set three and four we're going to
explore a little bit more in detail now
we stick to a simple example with two
coins because you can easily understand
the math the probability of throwing a
tail doesn't matter what comes before it
and the same with the head so still
going to be 50% or 1/2 but when that
come when that probability gets more
complicated let's see you have a D6 dice
or some other instance then this formula
really comes in handy but let's stick to
the simple example for now in this
sample space let a be the event that the
second coin is had and B be the event
that the first first coin is Tails again
we reversed it because we want to know
what the second event's going to be so
we're going to be focusing on a and we
write that out as the probability of a
given B and we know this from our
formula that that equals the probability
of B given a times the probability of a
over the probability of B and when we
plug that in we plug in the probability
of the first coin being Tails given the
second coin is heads and the probability
of the second coin being heads given the
first coin being over the probability of
the first coin being Tails when we plug
that data in and we have the probability
of the first coin being Tails given the
second coin is heads times the
probability of the second coin being
heads over the probability of the first
coin being tails you can see it's a
simple formula to calculate we have 1/2
* 1/2 over 1/2 or 1/2 equal .5 or 1/4 so
the base theorem basically calculates
the conditional probability of the
occurrence of an event based on prior
knowledge of conditions that might be
related to the event we will explore
this in detail when we take take up an
example of online shopping further in
this tutorial understanding naive bays
and machine learning like with any of
our other machine learning tools it's
important to understand where the naive
base fits in the hierarchy so under the
machine learning we have supervised
learning and there is other things like
unsupervised learning there's also
reward system This falls under the
supervised learning and then under the
supervised learning there's
classification there's also regression
but we're going to be in the
classification side and then under
classification is your naive Bays let's
go ahead and glance into where is naive
Bay used let's look at some of the use
scenarios for it as a classifier we use
it in face recognition is this Cindy or
is it not Cindy or whoever or it might
be used to identify parts of the face
that they then feed into another part of
the face recognition program this is the
eye this is the nose this is the mouth
weather prediction is it going to be
rainy or sunny medical recognition news
prediction it's also used in medical
diagnosis we might diagnose somebody as
either as high risk or not as high risk
for cancer or heart disease or other
ailments and news classification when
you look at the Google news and it says
well is this political or is this world
news or a lot of that's all done with a
naive B understanding naive Baye
classifier now we already went through a
basic understanding with the coins and
the two heads and two tails and head
tail tail heads Etc we're going to do
just a quick review on that and remind
you that the naive Bay classifier is
based B on the bay theorem which gives a
conditional probability of in event a
given event B and that's where the
probability of a given b equals the
probability of B given a * probability
of a over probability of B remember this
is an algebraic function so we can move
these different entities around we can
multiply by the probability of B so it
goes to the left hand side and then we
could divide by the probability of a
given B and just as easily come up with
a new formula for the probability of B
to me staring at these algebraic
functions kind of gives me a slight
headache it's a lot better to see if we
can actually understand how this data
fits together in a table and let's go
ahead and start applying it to some
actual data so you can see what that
looks like so we're going to start with
the shopping demo problem statement and
remember we're going to solve this first
in uh table form so you can see what the
math looks like and then we're going to
solve it in Python and in here we want
to predict whether the person will
purchase a product are they going to buy
or don't buy very important if you're
running a business you want to know how
to maximize your profits or or at least
maximize the purchase of the people
coming into your store and we're going
to look at a specific combination of
different variables in this case we're
going to look at the day the discount
and the free delivery and you can see
here under the day we want to know
whether it's uh on the weekday you know
somebody's working they come in after
work or maybe they don't work weekend
you can see the bright colors coming
down there celebrating not being in work
or holiday and did we offer a discount
that day yes or no did we offer free
delivery that day yes or no and from
this we want to know whether the
person's going to buy based on these
traits so we can maximize them and find
out the best system for getting somebody
to come in and purchase our goods and
products from our store now having a
nice visual is great but we do need to
dig into the data so let's go ahead and
take a look at the data set we have a
small sample data set of 30 rows we're
showing you the first 15 of those rows
for this demo now the actual data file
you can request just type in below under
the comments on the YouTube video and
we'll send you some more information and
send you that file as you can see here
the file is very simple columns and rows
we have the day the discount the free
delivery and did the person purchase or
not and then we have under the day
whether it was a weekday a holiday was
it the weekend this is a pretty simple
set of data and long before computers
people used to look at this data and
calculate this all by hand so let's go
ahead and walk through this and see what
that looks like when we put that into
tables also note in today's world we're
not usually looking at three different
variables in 30 rows nowadays cuz we're
able to collect data so so much we're
usually looking at 27 30 variables
across hundreds of rows the first thing
we want to do is we're going to take
this data and uh based on the data set
containing our three inputs Day discount
and free delivery we're going to go
ahead and populate that to frequency
tables for each attribute so we want to
know if they had a discount how many
people buy and did not buy uh did they
have a discount yes or no do we have a
free delivery yes or no on those days
how many people made a purchase how many
people didn't and the same with the
three days of the week was it a weekday
a weekend a holiday and did they buy yes
or no as we dig in deeper to this table
for our Bay theem let the event buy ba a
now remember when we looked at the coins
I said we really want to know what the
outcome is did the person buy or not and
that's usually event a is what you're
looking for and the independent
variables discount free delivery and day
BB so we'll call that probability of B
now let us calculate the likelihood
table for one of the variables let's
start with day which includes week Day
weekend and holiday and let us start by
summing all of our rows so we have the
uh weekday row and out of the weekdays
there's 9 plus 2 so is 11 weekdays
there's eight weekend days and 11
holidays wow it's a lot of holidays and
then we want to sum up the total number
of days so we're looking at a total of
30 days let's start pulling some
information from our chart and see where
that takes us and when we fill in the
chart on the right you can see that nine
out of 24 purchases are made on the
weekday 7 out of 24 purchases on the
weekend and eight out of 24 purchases on
a holiday and out of all the people who
come in 24 out of 30 purchase you can
also see how many people do not purchase
on the week dat it's two out of six
didn't purchase and so on and so on we
can also look at the totals and you'll
see on the right we put together some of
the formulas the probability of making a
purchase on the weekend comes out 11 out
of 30 so out of the 30 people who came
into the store throughout the weekend
weekday and holiday 11 of those
purchases were made on the weekday and
then you can also see the probability of
them not making a purchase and this is
done for doesn't matter which day of the
week so we call that probability of no
buy would be 6 over 30 or02 so there's a
20% chance that they're not going to
make a purchase no matter what day of
the week it is and finally we look at
the probability of B if a in this case
we're going to look at the probability
of the weekday and not buying two of the
no buys were done out of the weekend out
of the six people who did not make
purchases so when we look at that
probability of the week day without a
purchase is going to be 33 or
33% let's take a look at this at
different probabilities and uh based on
this likelihood table let's go ahead and
calculate conditional probabilities as
below the first three we just did the
probability of making a purchase on the
weekday is 11 out of 30 or roughly 36 or
37% 367 the probability of not making a
purchase at all doesn't matter what day
of the week is roughly 0.2 or 20% % and
the probability of a weekday no purchase
is roughly two out of six so two out of
six of our no purchases were made on the
weekday and then finally we take our P
of ab if you looked we've kept the
symbols up there we got P of uh
probability of B probability of a
probability of B if a we should remember
that the probability of a if B is equal
to the first one times the probability
of no per buys over the probability of
the weekday so we could calculate it
both off the uh table we created we can
also calculate this by the formula and
we get the 367 which equals or uh. 33 *
2 over 367 which equals. 179 or roughly
uh 17 to 18% and that'd be the
probability of no purchase done on the
weekday and this is important because we
can look at this and say as the
probability of buying on the weekday is
more than the probability of not buying
on the weekday we can conclude that
customers will most likely buy the
product on a weekday now we've kept our
chart simple and we're only looking at
one aspect so you should be able to look
at the table and come up with the same
information or the same conclusion that
should be kind of intuitive at this
point next we can take the same setup we
have the frequency tables of all three
independent variables now we can
construct the likelihood tables for all
three of the variables we're working
with we can take our day like we did
before we have weekday weekend and
Holiday we filled in this table and then
we can come in and also do that for the
discount yes or no did they buy yes or
no and we fill in that full table so now
we have our probabilities for a discount
and whether the discount leads to a
purchase or not and the probability for
free delivery does that lead to a
purchase or not and this is where it
starts getting really exciting let us
use these three likelihood tables to
calculate whether a customer will
purchase a product on a specific
combination of Day discount and free
delivery or or not purchase here let us
take a combination of these factors day
equals holiday discount equals yes free
delivery equals yes let's dig deeper
into the math and actually see what this
looks like and we're going to start with
looking for the probability of them not
purchasing on the following combinations
of days we are actually looking for the
probability of a equal no buy no
purchase and our probability of B we're
going to set equal to is it a holiday
did they get a discount yes and was it a
free delivery yes
before we go further let's look at the
original equation the probability of a
if B equals the probability of B given
the condition a and the probability
times probability of a over the
probability of B occurring now this is
basic algebra so we can multiply this
information together so when you see the
probability of a given B in this case
the condition is BC and D or the three
different variables we're looking at and
when you see the probability of B that
would be the conditions we're actually
going to multiply those three separate
conditions out probability of you'll see
that in just a second in the formula
times the full probability of a over the
full probability of B so here we are
back to this and we're going to have let
a equal no purchase and we're looking
for the probability of B on the
condition a where a sets for three
different things remember that equals
the probability of a given the condition
B and in this case we just multiply
those three different variables together
so we have the probability of the
discount times the probability of free
delivery times the probability is a day
equal a holiday those are our three
variables of the probability of a if B
and then that is going to be multiplied
by the probability of them not making a
purchase and then we want to divide that
by the total probabilities and they're
multiplied together so we have the
probability of a discount the
probability of a free delivery and the
probability of it being on a holiday
when we plug those numbers in we see
that one out of six were no purchase on
a discounted day two out of six were a
no purchase on a free delivery day and
three out of six were a no purchase on a
holiday those are our three
probabilities of a of B multiplied out
and then that has to be multiplied by
the probability of a no purchase and
remember the pro probability of a no buy
is across all the data so that's where
we get the 6 out of 30 we divide that
out by the probability of each category
over the total number so we get the 20
out of 30 had a discount 23 out of 30
had a yes for free delivery and 11 out
of 30 were on a holiday we plug all
those numbers in we get
178 so in our probability math we have
a178 if it's a no buy for a holiday a
discount and a free delivery let's turn
that around and see what that looks like
if we have a purchase I promise this is
the last page of math before we we dig
into the python script so here we're
calculating the probability of the
purchase using the same math we did to
find out if they didn't buy now we want
to know if they did buy and again we're
going to go by the day equals a holiday
discount equals yes free delivery equals
yes and let a equal buy now right about
now you might be asking why are we doing
both calculations why why would we want
to know the no buys and buys for the
same data going in well we're going to
show you that in just a moment but we
have to have both of those pieces of
information so that we can figure it out
as a percentage as opposed to a
probability equation and we'll get to
that normalization here in just a moment
let's go ahead and walk through this
calculation and as you can see here the
probability of a on the condition of b b
being all three categories did we have a
discount with a purchase do we have a
free delivery with a purchase and did we
is a day equal to Holiday and when we
plug this all into that formula and
multiply it all out we get our
probability of a discount probability of
a free delivery probability of the day
being a holiday times the overall
probability of it being a purchase
divided by again multiplying the three
variables out the full probability of
there being a discount the full
probability of being a free delivery and
the full probability of there being a
day equal holiday and that's where we
get this 19 over 24 * 21 over 24 * 8
over 24 * the P of a 24 over 30 divided
by the probability of the discount the
free delivery times the day or 20 over
30 23 over 30 * 11 over 30 and that
gives us our
986 so what are we going to do with
these two pieces of data we just
generated well let's go ahead and go
over them we have a probability of
purchase equals
986 we have a probability of no purchase
equals 178 so finally we have a
conditional probabilities of purchase on
this day let us take that we're going to
normalize it and we're going to take
these probabilities and turn them into
percentages this is simply done by
taking the sum of probabilities which
equals
98686 plus. 178 and that equals the
1.64 if we divide each probability by
the sum we get the percentage and so the
likelihood of a purchase is
84.7% and the likelihood of no purchase
is
15.29% given these three different
variables so it's if it's on a holiday
if it's a with a discount and has free
delivery then there's an 84.7 1% chance
that the customer is going to come in
and make a purchase hooray they
purchased our stuff we're making money
if you're owning a shop that's like is
the bottom line is you want to make some
money so you can keep your shop open and
have a living now I promised you that we
were going to be finishing up the math
here with a few pages so we're going to
move on and we're going to do two steps
the first step is I want you to
understand why you want to why you want
to use the naive Bays what are the
advantages of naive bays and then once
we understand those advantages we're
just just look at that briefly then
we're going to dive in and do some
python coding advantages of naive Baye
classifier so let's take a look at the
six advantages of the naive Baye
classifier and we're going to walk
around this lovely wheel looks like an
origami folded paper the first one is
very simple and easy to implement
certainly you could walk through the
tables and do this by hand you got to be
a little careful because the notations
can get confusing you have all these
different probabilities and I certainly
mess those up as I put them on you know
is it on the top or the bottom got to
really pay close attention to that when
you put it into python it's really nice
because you don't have to worry about
any of that you let the python handle
that the python module but understanding
it you can put it on a table and you can
easily see how it works and it's a
simple algebraic function it needs less
training data so if you have smaller
amounts of data this is great powerful
tool for that handles both continuous
and discrete data it's highly scalable
with number of predictors and data
points so as you can see you just keep
multiplying different probabilities in
there and you can cover not just three
different variables or sets you can now
expand this to even more categories
number five it's fast it can be used in
real time predictions this is so
important this is why it's used in a lot
of our predictions on online shopping
carts uh referrals spam filters is
because there's no time delay as it has
to go through and figure out a neural
network or one of the other mini setups
where you're doing classification and
certainly there's a lot of other tools
out there in the machine learning that
can handle these but most of them are
not as fast as the naive bays and then
finally it's not sensitive to irrelevant
features so it picks up on your
different probabilities and if you're
short on date on one probability you can
kind of it automatically adjust for that
those formulas are very automatic and so
you can still get a very solid
predictability even if you're missing
data or you have overlapping data for
two completely different areas we see
that a lot in doing census and studying
of people and habits where they might
have one study that covers one aspect
another one that overlaps and because
the two overlap they can then predict
the unknown for the group that they
haven't done the second study on or vice
versa so it's very powerful in that it
is not sensitive to the irrelevant
features and in fact you can use it to
help predict features that aren't even
in there so now we're down to my
favorite part we're going to roll up our
sleeves and do some actual programming
we're going to do the use case text
classification now I would challenge you
to go back and send us a note on the
Note below underneath the video and
request a data for the shopping cart so
you can plug that into python code and
do that on your own time so you can walk
through it since we walk through all the
information on it but we're going to do
a python code doing text classification
very popular for doing the naive Bays so
we're going to use our new tool to
perform a text classification of news
headlines and classify news into
different topics for a News website as
you can see here we have a nice image of
the Google news and then related on the
WR subgroups I'm not sure where they
actually pulled the actual data we're
going to use from it's one of the
standard sets but certainly this can be
used on any of our news headlines and
classification so let's see how it can
be done using the naive Bay classifier
now we're at my favorite part we're
actually going to write some python
script roll up our sleeves and we're
going to start by doing our Imports
these are very basic Imports including
our news group and we'll take a quick
glance at the Target names then we're
going to go ahead and start training our
data set and putting it together we'll
put together a nice graph because it's
always good to have a graph to show
what's going on and once we've trained
it and we've shown you a graph of what's
going on then we're going to explore how
to use it and see what that looks like
now I'm going to open up my favorite
editor or inline editor for python you
don't have to use this you can use
whatever your editor that you like
whatever uh interface IDE you want this
just happens to be the Anaconda Jupiter
notebook and I'm going to paste that
first piece of code in here so we can
walk through it let's make it a little B
bigger on the screen so you have a nice
view of what's going on uh and we're
using Python 3 in this case 3.5 so this
would work in any of your 3x if you have
it set up correctly should also work in
a lot of the 2x you just have to make
sure all the the versions of the modules
match your python version and in here
you'll notice the first line is your
percentage met plot library in line now
three of these lines of code are all
about plotting the graph this one let's
The Notebook notes and this is the
inline set up that we want the graphs to
show up on this page without it in a
notebook like this which is an Explorer
interface it won't show up now a lot of
Ides don't require that a lot of them
like on if I'm working on one of my
other setups it just has a popup and the
graph pops up on there so you have a
that setup also but for this we want the
matplot library in line and then we're
going to import numpy as NP that's
number python which has a lot of
different formulas in it that we use for
both both of our sklearn module and we
also use it for any of the upper math
functions in Python and it's very common
to see that as NP nump as NP the next
two lines are all about our graphing
remember I said three of these were
about graphing well we need our map plot
library. pyplot as PLT and you'll see
that PLT is a very common setup as is
the SNS and just like the NP and we're
going to import caborn as SNS and we're
going to do the SNS do set now caborn
sits on top of High plot and it just
makes a really nice heat map it's really
good for heat maps and if you're not
familiar with heat maps that just means
we give it a color scale the term comes
from the brighter red it is the hotter
it is in some form of data and you can
set it to whatever you want and we'll
see that later on so those you'll see
that those three lines of code here are
just importing the graph function so we
can graph it and as a data scientist you
always want to graph your data and have
some kind of visual it's really hard
just to shove numbers in front of people
and they look at it and it doesn't mean
anything and then from the SK learn. dat
set we're going to import the fetch 20
news groups very common one for
analyzing tokenizing words and setting
them up and exploring how the words work
and how do you categorize different
things when you're dealing with
documents and then we set our data equal
to fetch 20 news groups so our data
variable will have the data in it and
we're going to go ahead and just print
the target names data. Target names and
let's see what that looks like and
you'll see here we have alt atheism comp
graphic comp osms windows. miscellaneous
and it goes all the way down to talk
politics. miscellaneous talk religion.
miscellaneous these are the categories
they've already assigned to this news
group and it's called Fetch 20 because
you'll see there's I believe there's 20
different topics in here or 20 different
categories as we scroll down now we've
gone through the 20 different categories
and we're going to go ahead and start
defining all the categories and set up
our data so we're actually here going to
go ahead and get it get the data all set
up and take a look at our data and let's
move this over to our Jupiter notebook
and let's see what this code does first
we're going to set our categories now if
you noticed up here I could have just as
easily set this equal to data. Target
cor names because it's the same thing
but we want to kind of spell it out for
you so you can see the different
categories it kind of makes it more
visual so you can see what your data is
looking like in the background once
we've created the categories we're going
to open up a train set so this training
set of data is going to go into fetch 20
news groups and it's a subset in there
called train and categories equals
categories so we're pulling out those
categories that match and then if you
have a train set you should also have
the testing set we have test equals
fetch 20 news groups subset equals test
and categories equals categories let's
go down one size so it all fits on my
screen there we go and just so we can
really see what's going on let's see
what happens when we print out one part
of that data so it creates train and
under train it creates train. dat and
we're just going to look at data piece
number five and let's go ahead and run
that and see what that looks like and
you can see when I print train. dat
number five under train it prints out
one of the Articles this is article
number five you can go through and and
read it on there and we can also go in
here and change this to test which
should look identical because it's
splitting the data up into different
groups train and test and we'll see test
number five is a a different article but
another article in here and maybe you're
curious and you want to see just how
many articles are in here we could do
length of train. data and if we run that
you'll see that the training data has
11,314 articles so we're not going to go
through all those articles that's a lot
of articles but um we can look at one of
them just so you can see what kind of
information is coming out of it and what
we're looking at and we'll just look at
number five for today and here we have
it rewarding the Second Amendment IDs VT
line 58 lines 58 in article uh Etc and
you can scroll all the way down and see
all the different parts to there now
we've looked at it and that's pretty
complicated when you look at one of
these articles to try to figure out how
do you wait this if you look down here
we have different words and maybe the
word from well from is probably in all
the Articles so it's not going to have a
lot of meaning as far as trying to
figure out whether this article fits one
of the categories or not so trying to
figure out which category it fits in
based on these words is where the
challenge comes in now that we' viewed
our data we're going to dive in and do
the actual predictions this is the
actual naive Bas and we're going to
throw another model at you or another
module at you here in just a second we
can't go into too much detail but it
deals specifically working with words
and text and what they call tokenizing
those words so let's take this code and
let's uh skip on over to our Jupiter
notebook and walk through it and here we
are in our jupyter notebook let's paste
that in there and I can run this code
right off the bat it's not actually
going to display anything yet but it has
a lot going going on in here so the top
we had the print module from the earlier
one I didn't know why that was in there
so we're going to start by importing our
necessary packages and from the sklearn
features extraction. text we're going to
import tfidf vectorizer I told you we're
going to throw a module at you we can't
go too much into the math behind this or
how it works you can look it up the
notation for the math is usually tf.idf
and that's just a way of weighing the
words and it weighs the words words
based on how many times they're used in
a document how many times or how many
documents they're used in and it's a
well-used formula it's been around for a
while it's a little confusing to put
this in here uh but let's let it know
that it just goes in there and waits the
different words in the document for us
that way we don't have to wait and if
you put a weight on it if you remember I
was talking about that up here earlier
if these are all emails they probably
all have the word from in them from
probably has a very low weight it has
very little value in telling you what
this document's about
same with words like in in article in
articles in cost of un maybe cost might
or where words like criminal weapons
destruction these might have a heavier
weight because they describe a little
bit more what the article's doing well
how do you figure out all those weights
in the different articles that's what
this module does that's what the tfidf
vectorizer is going to do for us and
then we're going to import our SK learn.
naive Bas and that's our multinomial NB
multi nomial naive Bas pretty easy to
understand that where that comes from
and then finally we have the sky learn
pipeline import make pipeline now the
make pipeline is just a cool piece of
code because we're going to take the
information we get from the tfidf
vectorizer and we're going to pump that
into the multinomial INB so a pipeline
is just a way of organizing how things
flow it's used commonly you probably
already guess what it is if you've done
any businesses they talk about the sales
pipeline if you're on a work crew or
project manager you have your pipeline
of information that's going through or
your projects and what has to be done in
what order that's all this pipeline is
we're going to take the tfid vectorizer
and then we're going to push that into
the multinomial NB now we've designated
that as the variable model we have our
pipeline model and we're going to take
that model and this is just so elegant
this is done in just a couple lines of
code model.fit
and we're going to fit the data and
first the train data and then the train
Target now the train data has the
different articles in it you can see the
one we were just looking at and the
train. target is what category they
already categorized that that particular
article as and what's Happening Here is
the train data is going into the tfid
vectorizer so when you have one of these
articles that goes in there it weights
all the words in there so there's
thousands of words with different
weights on them I remember once running
a model on this and I literally had 2.4
million tokens go into this so when
you're dealing like large document bases
you can have a huge number of different
words it then takes those words gives
them a weight and then based on that
weight based on the words and the
weights and then puts that into the
multinomial NB and once we go into our
naive Bay we want to put the train
Target in there so the train data that's
been mapped to the tfid vectorizer is
now going through the multinomial in B
and then we're telling it well these are
the answers these are the answers to the
different documents so this document
that has all these words with these
different weights from the first part is
going to be whatever category it comes
out of maybe it's the um Talk show or
the article on religion miscellaneous
once we fit that model we can then take
labels and we're going to set that equal
to model. predict most of the sklearn
used the term. predict to let us know
that we've now trained the model and now
we want to get some answers and we're
going to put our test data in there
because our test data is the stuff we
held off to the side we didn't train it
on there and we don't know what's going
to come up out of it and we just want to
find out how good our labels are do they
match what they should be now I've
already run this through there's no
actual output to it to show this is just
setting it all up this is just trending
our model creating the label so we can
see how good it is and then we move on
to the next step to find out what
happened to do this this we're going to
go ahead and create a confusion Matrix
and a heat map so the confusion Matrix
which is confusing just by its very name
it's basically going to ask how confused
is our answer did it get it correct or
did it Miss some things in there or have
some missed labels and then we're going
to put that on a heat map so we'll have
some nice colors to look at to see how
that plots out let's go ahead and take
this code and see how that uh take a
walk through it and see what that looks
like so back to our Jupiter notebook
going to put the code in there and let's
go ahead and run that code take it just
a moment and remember we had the inline
that way my graph shows up on the end
line here and let's walk through the
code and then we'll look at this and see
what that means so make it a little bit
bigger there we go no reason not to use
a whole screen too big so we have here
from sklearn metrics import confusion
Matrix and that's just going to generate
a set of data that says I the prediction
was such the ACT ual truth was either
agreed with it or is something different
and it's going to add up those numbers
so we can take a look and just see how
well it worked and we're going to set a
variable Matt equal to confusion Matrix
and we have our test Target our test
data that was not part of the training
very important in data science we always
keep our test data separate otherwise
it's not a valid model if we can't
properly test it with new data and this
is the labels we created from that test
data these are the ones that we predict
it's going to be so we go in and we
create our SN heat map the SNS is our
caborn which sits on top of the P plot
so when we create an SNS do heatmap we
take our confusion Matrix and it's going
to be uh matt. T and do we have other
variables that go into the SNS do heat
map we're not going to go into detail
what all the variables mean The
annotation equals true that's what tells
it to put the numbers here so you have
the 166 the 1 the 00001 format D and c
bar equals false have to do with the uh
format if you take those out you'll see
that some things disappear and then the
xtick labels and the Y tick labels those
are our Target names and you can see
right here that's the alt atheism comp
Graphics comp osms windows.
miscellaneous and then finally we have
our PLT dox label remember the SNS or
the caborn sits on top of our map plot
Library our PLT and so we want to just
tell it X label equals a true is is true
the labels are are true and then the Y
label is prediction label so when we say
a true this is what it actually is and
the prediction is what we predicted and
let's look at this graph because that's
probably a little confusing the way I
rattled through it and what I'm going to
do is I'm going to go ahead and flip
back to the slides because they have a
black background they put in there that
helps it shine a little bit better so
you can see the graph a little bit
easier so in reading this graph what we
want to look at is how the color scheme
has come out and you'll see a line right
down the middle diagonally from upper
left to bottom right what that is is if
you look at the labels we have our
predicted label on the left and our true
label on the right those are the numbers
where the prediction and the true come
together and this is what we want to see
is we want to see those lit up that's
what that heat map does as you can see
that it did a good job of finding those
data and you'll notice that there's a
couple of red spots on there where it
missed you know it's a little confused
when we talk about talk religion
miscellaneous versus talk politics
miscellaneous social religion Christian
versus Alt atheism it mislabeled some of
those and those are very similar topics
so you could understand why it might
mislabel them but overall it did a
pretty good job if we're going to create
these models we want to go ahead and be
able to use them so let's see what that
looks like to do this let's go ahead and
create a definition a function to run
and we're going to call this function
let me just expand that just a notch
here there we go I like mining big
letters predict categories want to
predict the category we're going to send
it s a string and then we're sending it
train equals train we have our training
model and then we had our pipeline model
equals model this way we don't have to
resend these variables each time the
definition knows that because I said
training equals train and I put the
equal for model and then we're going to
set the prediction equal to the model.
predicts so it's going to send whatever
string we send to it is going to push
that string through the pipeline the
model pipeline it's going to go through
through and uh tokenize it and put it
through the TF IDF convert that into
numbers and weights for all the
different documents and words and then
it'll put that through our naive bays
and from it we'll go ahead and get our
prediction we're going to predict what
value it is and so we're going to return
train. Target names predict of zero and
remember that the train. target names
that's just categories I could have just
as easily put uh categories in there.
predict of zero so we're taking the
prediction which is a number and we're
converting it to an actual category
we're converting it from um I don't know
what the actual numbers are let's say
zero equals alt atheism so we're going
to convert that zero to the word or one
maybe it equals comp Graphics so we're
going to convert number one into comp
Graphics that's all that is and then we
got to go ahead and and then we need to
go ahead and run this so I load that up
and then once I run that we can start
doing some predictions I'm going go
ahead and type in in predict category
and let's just do predict category Jesus
Christ and it comes back and says it's
social religion Christian that's pretty
good now note I didn't put print on this
one of the nice things about the Jupiter
notebook editor and a lot of inline
editors is if you just put the name of
the variable out as returning the
variable train. Target names it'll
automatically print that for you in your
own ID you might have to put in print
let's see where else we can take this
and maybe your a space science buff so
how about sending load to
International Space
Station and if we run that we get
science space or maybe you're a uh
automobile buff and let's do um oh they
were going to tell me Audi is better
than BMW but I'm going to do BMW is
better then an Audi so maybe you're car
buff and we run that and you'll see it
says recreational I'm I'm assuming
that's what recc stands for Autos so I
did a pretty good job labeling that one
how about uh if we have something like a
caption running through their president
of India and if we run that it comes up
and says talk politics miscellaneous
there's no better time to train yourself
in the exciting field of machine
learning if you're looking for a course
that covers everything from the
fundamentals to Advanced Techniques like
machine learning algorithm development
and unsupervised learning look no
further than our CCH postgraduate
programming AI machine learning in
partnership with IBM this a ml course
CES the latest tools and Technologies
from the AI ecosystem and features
master classes by celtech faculty and
IBM experts Heaton and ask me anything
sessions this program showcases celtech
ctm is excellence and IBM's industry
progess the artificial intelligence
course coveres key Concepts like
statistics data science with python
machine learning deep learning NLP and
reinforcement learning through an
Interactive Learning model with live
sessions and roll now and unlock
exciting A&L opportunities the course
link is mentioned in the description box
below so when we take our definition or
our function and we run all these things
through Kudos we made it we were able to
correctly classify texts into different
groups based on which category they
belong to using the naive Bas classifier
now we did throw in the pipeline the TF
IDF vectorizer we threw in the graphs
those are all things that you don't
necessarily have to know to understand
the naive BAS
setup or classifier but they're
important to know one of the main uses
for the naive Bay is with the tfidf
tokenizer vectorizer where it tokenizes
the word and adds labels and we use the
pipeline because you need to push all
that data through and it makes it really
easy and fast you don't have to know
those to understand naive Bays but they
certainly help for understanding the
industry and data science and we can see
our categorizer our naive Bas classifier
we were able to predict the category
religion space motorcycles Autos
politics and properly classify all these
different things we pushed into our
prediction and our train model by now we
all know machine learning models make
predictions by learning from the past
data available so we have our input
values our machine learning model Builds
on those inputs of what we already know
and then we use that to create a
predicted output is that a dog little
kid looking over there and watching the
black cat cross their path no dear you
can differentiate between a cat and a
dog based on their
characteristics cats cats have sharp
claws uses to climb smaller length of
ears meows and purs doesn't love to play
around dogs they have dle claws bigger
length of ears barks loves to run around
you usually don't see a cat running
around people although I do have a cat
that does that or dogs do and we can
look at these we can say we can evaluate
the sharpness of the claws how sharp are
their claws and we can evaluate the link
of the ears and we can usually sort out
cats from dogs based on even those two
characteristics now tell me if it is a
cat or a dog odd question usually little
kids know cats and dogs by now unless
they live a place where there's not many
cats or dogs so if we look at the
sharpness of the claws the length of the
ears and we can see that the cat has
smaller ears and sharper claws than the
other animals its features are more like
cats it must be a cat sharp claws length
of ears and it goes in the at group
because KNN is based on feature
similarity we can do classification
using KNN classifier so we have our
input value the picture of the black cat
it goes into our trained model and it
predicts that this is a cat coming out
so what is knnn what is the KNN
algorithm K nearest neighbors is what
that stands for it's one of the simplest
supervised machine learning algorithms
mostly used for classification so we
want to know is this a dog or it's not a
dog is it a cat or not a cat it
classifies a data point based on how its
neighbors are classified KNN stores all
available cases and classifies new cases
based on a similarity measure and here
we gone from cats and dogs right into
wine another favorite of mine KNN stores
all available cases and classifies new
cases based on a similarity measure and
here you see we have a measurement of
sulfur dioxide versus the chloride level
and then the different wines they've
tested and where they fall on that graph
based on how much sulfur dioxide and how
much chloride K and KNN is a perimeter
that refers to the number of nearest
neighbors to include in the majority of
the voting process and so if we add a
new glass of wine there red or white we
want to know what the neighbors are in
this case we're going to put k equals 5
we'll talk about K in just a minute a
data point is classified by the majority
of votes from its five nearest neighbors
here the unknown point would be
classified as red since four out of five
neighbors are red so how do we choose k
how do we know k equals 5 I mean that's
was the value we put in there so we're
going to talk about it how do we choose
the factor k k andn algorithm is based
on feature similarity choosing the right
value of K is a process called parameter
tuning and is important for better
accuracy so at k equal 3 we can classify
we have a question mark in the middle as
either a as a square or not is it a
square or is it in this case a triangle
and so if we set k equals to three we're
going to look at the three nearest
neighbors we're going to say this is a
square and if we put k equal to 7 we
classify as a triangle depending on what
the other data is around and you can see
as the K changes depending on where that
point is that drastically changes your
answer and uh we jump here we go how do
we choose the factor of K you'll find
this in all machine learning choosing
these factors that's the face you get
it's like oh my gosh did I choose the
right K did I set it right my values in
whatever machine learning tool you're
looking at so that you don't have a huge
bias in One Direction or the other and
in terms of knnn the number of K if you
choose it too low the bias is based on
it's just too noisy it's it's right next
to a couple things and it's going to
pick those things and you might get a
skewed answer and if your K is too big
then it's going to take forever to
process so you're going to run into
processing issues and resource issues so
what we do the most common use and
there's other options for choosing K is
to use the square root of n so N is a
total number of values you have and you
take the square root of it in most cases
you also if it's an even number so if
you're using uh like in this case
squares and triangles if it's even you
want to make your K value odd that helps
it select better so in other words
you're not going to have a balance
between two different factors that are
equal so usually take the square root of
N and if it's even you add one to it or
subtract one from it and that's where
you get the K value from that is the
most common use and it's pretty solid it
works very well when do we use KNN we
can use pay it in when data is labeled
so you need a label on it we know we
have a group of pictures with dogs dogs
cats cats data is Noise free and so you
can see here when we have a class and we
have like underweight 140 23 Hello Kitty
normal that's pretty confusing we have a
high variety of data coming in so it's
very noisy and that would cause an issue
data set is small so we're usually
working with smaller data sets where I
you might get into gig of data if it's
really clean doesn't have a lot of noise
because KNN is a lazy learner I.E it
doesn't learn a discriminative function
from the training set so it's very lazy
so if you have very complicated data and
you have a large amount of it you're not
going to use the KNN but it's really
great to get a place to start even with
large data you can sort out a small
sample and get an idea of what that
looks like using the KNN and also just
using for smaller data sets KNN works
really good how does a KNN algorithm
work consider a data set having two
variables height and C and weight in
kilogram and each point is classified as
normal or underweight so we can see
right here we have two variables you
know true false they're either normal or
they're not they're underweight on the
basis of the given data we have to
classify the below set as normal or
underweight using KNN so if we have new
data coming in that says 57 kilog and
177 cm is that going to be normal or
underweight to find the nearest
neighbors we'll calculate the ukian
distance according to the ukian distance
formula the distance between two points
in the plane with the coordinates XY and
ab is given by distance D equals the
square OT of x - a^ 2 + y - b^ 2 and you
can remember that from the two edges of
a triangle we're Computing the third
Edge since we know the X side and the
yide let's calculate it to understand
clearly so we have our unknown point and
we placed it there in red and we have
our other points where the data is
scattered around the distance D1 is a
square < TK of 170 - 167 2 + 57 - 51
squared which is about 6.7 and distance
two is about 13 and distance three is
about
13.4 similarly we will calculate the
ukian distance of unknown data point
from all the points in the data set and
because we're dealing with small amount
of data that's not that hard to do and
it's actually pretty quick for a
computer and it's not a really
complicated Mass you can just to see how
close is the data based on the ukian
distance hence we have calculated the
ukian distance of unknown data point
from all the points as showing where X1
and y1 equal 57 and 170 whose class we
have to classify so now we're looking at
that we're saying well here's the ukian
distance who's going to be their closest
neighbors now let's calculate the
nearest neighbor at k equals 3 and we
can see the three closest neighbors puts
them at normal and that's pretty
self-evident when you look at this graph
it's pretty easy to say okay what you
know we're just voting normal normal
normal three votes for normal this is
going to be a normal weight so majority
of neighbors are pointing towards normal
hence as per KNN algorithm the class of
57170 should be normal so recap of KNN
positive integer K is specified along
with a new sample we select the K
entries in our database which are
closest to the new sample we find the
most common classification of these
entries this is the classification we
give to the new sample so as you can see
it's pretty straightforward we're just
looking for the closest things that
match what we got so let's take a look
and see what that looks like in a use
case in Python so let's dive into the
predict diabetes use case so use case
predict diabetes the objective predict
whether a person will be diagnosed with
diabetes or not we have a data set of
768 people who were or were not
diagnosed with diabetes and let's go
ahead and open that file and just take a
look at that data and this is in a
simple spreadsheet format the data
itself is comma separated very common
set of data and it's also a very common
way to get the data and you can see here
we have columns a through I that's what
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 um eight columns with a
particular attribute and then the ninth
column which is the outcome is whether
they have diabetes as a data scientist
the first thing you should be looking at
is insulin well you know if someone has
insulin they have diabetes CU that's why
they're taking it and that could cause
issue on some of the machine learning
packages but for a very basic setup this
works fine for uh doing the KNN and the
next thing you notice is it didn't take
very much to open it up um I can scroll
down to the bottom of the data there's
768 it's pretty much a small data set
you know at 769 I can easily fit this
into my ram on my computer I can look at
it I can manipulate it and it's not
going to really tax just a regular
desktop computer you don't even need an
Enterprise version to run a lot of this
so let's start with importing all the
tool tools we need and before that of
course we need to discuss what IDE I'm
using certainly you can use any
particular editor for python but I like
to use for doing uh very basic visual
stuff the Anaconda which is great for
doing demos with the Jupiter notebook
and just a quick view of the Anaconda
Navigator which is the new release out
there which is really nice you can see
under home I can choose my application
we're going to be using python 36 I have
a couple different uh versions on this
particular machine if I go under
environments I can create a unique
environment for each one which is nice
and there's even a little button there
where I can install different packages
so if I click on that button and open
the terminal I can then use a simple pip
install to install different packages
I'm working with let's go ahead and go
back under home and we're going to
launch our notebook and I've already you
know kind of like uh the old cooking
shows I've already prepared a lot of my
stuff so we don't have to wait for it to
launch because it takes a few minutes
for it to open up a browser window in
this case I'm going it's going to open
up Chrome because that's my default that
I use
and since the script is pre-done you'll
see you have a number of windows open up
at the top the one we're working in and
uh since we're working on the KNN
predict whether a person will have
diabetes or not let's go and put that
title in there and I'm also going to go
up here and click on Cell actually we
want to go ahead and first insert a cell
below and then I'm going to go back up
to the top cell and I'm going to change
the cell type to markdown that means
this is not going to run as python it's
a markdown language so if I run this
first one it comes up in nice big
letters which which is kind of nice
remind us what we're working on and by
now you should be familiar with doing
all of our Imports we're going to import
the pandas as PD import numpy as NP
pandas is the pandas data frame and
numpy is a number array very powerful
tools to use in here so we have our
Imports so we've brought in our pandas
our numpy our two general python tools
and then you can see over here we have
our train test split by now youed should
be familiar with splitting the data we
want to split part of it for training
our thing and then training our
particular model and then we want to go
ahead and test the remaining data just
see how good it is pre-processing a
standard scaler pre-processor so we
don't have a bias of really large
numbers remember in the data we had like
number pregnancies isn't going to get
very large where the amount of insulin
they take and get up to 256 so 256
versus 6 that will skew results so we
want to go ahead and change that so
they're all uniform between minus one
and one and then the actual tool this is
the K neighbors classifier we're going
to use and finally the last three are
three tools to test all about testing
our model how good is it let me just put
down test on there and we have our
confusion Matrix our F1 score and our
accuracy so we have our two general
python modules we're importing and then
we have our six modules specific from
the sklearn setup and then we do need to
go ahead and run this so these are
actually imported there we go and then
move move on to the next step and so in
this set we're going to go ahead and
load the database we're going to use
pandas remember pandas is PD and we'll
take a look at the data in Python we
looked at it in a simple spreadsheet but
usually I like to also pull it up so
that we can see what we're doing so
here's our data set equals pd. read CSV
that's a pandas command and the diabetes
folder I just put in the same folder
where my I python script is if you put
in a different folder You' need the full
length on there we can also do a quick
length of uh the data set that is a
simple python command Len for length we
might even let's go ahead and print that
we'll go print and if you do it on its
own line link. dat set in the jupyter
notebook it'll automatically print it
but when you're in most of your
different setups you want to do the
print in front of there and then we want
to take a look at the actual data set
and since we're in pandas we can simply
do data set head and again let's go
ahead and add the print in there if you
put a bunch of these in a row you know
that data set one head data set two head
it only prints out the last one so I
usually always like to keep the print
statement in there but because most
projects only use one data frame Panda's
data frame doing it this way doesn't
really matter the other way works just
fine and you can see when we hit the Run
button we have the 768 lines which we
knew and we have our pregnancies it's
automatically given a label on the left
remember the head only shows the first
five lines so we have 0o through four
and just a quick look at the data you
can see it matches what we looked at
before we have pregnancy glucose blood
pressure all the way to age and then the
outcome on the end and we're going to do
a couple things in this next step we're
going to create a list of columns where
we can't have zero there's no such thing
as zero skin thickness or zero blood PR
pressure zero glucose uh any of those
you'd be dead so not a really good
Factor if they don't if they have a zero
in there because they didn't have the
data and we'll take a look at that cuz
we're going to start replacing that
information with with a couple of
different things and let's see what that
looks like so first we create a nice
list as you can see we have the values
talked about glucose blood pressure skin
thickness uh and this is a nice way when
you're working with columns is to list
the columns you need to do some kind of
transformation on uh very common thing
to do and then for this particular setup
we certainly could use the there's some
Panda tools that will do a lot of this
where we can replace the na but we're
going to go ahead and do it as a data
set column equals data set column
replace this is this is still pandas you
can do a direct there's also one that
that you look for your n a lot of
different options in here but the N nump
Nan is what that stands for is is non
doesn't exist so the first thing we're
doing here is we're replacing the zero
with a numpy none there's no data there
that's what that says that's what this
is saying right here so put the zero in
and we're going to replace zeros with no
data so if it's a zero that means the
person's well hopefully not dead
hopefully they just didn't get the data
the next thing we want to do is we're
going to create the mean which is the in
integer from the data set from the
column. mean where we skip Nas we can do
that that is a panda's command there the
skip na so we're going to figure out the
mean of that data set and then we're
going to take that data set column and
we're going to replace all the
npn with the means why did we do that
and we could have actually just uh taken
this step and gone right down here and
just replaced zero and Skip anything
were except you could actually there's a
way to skip zeros and then just replace
all the zeros but in this case we want
to go ahead and do it this way so you
can see that we're switching this to a
non-existent value then we're going to
create the mean well this is the average
person so if we don't know what it is if
they did not get the data and the data
is missing one of the tricks is you
replace it with the average what is the
most common data for that this way you
can still use the rest of those values
to do your computation and it kind of
just brings that particular value of
those missing values out of the equation
let's go ahead and take this and we'll
go ahead and run it doesn't actually do
anything so we're still preparing our
data if you want to see what that looks
like we don't have anything in the first
few lines it's not going to show up but
we certainly could look at a row let's
do that let's go into our data set with
a printed data set and let's pick in
this case let's just do glucose and if I
run this this is going to print all the
different glucose levels going down and
we thankfully don't see anything in here
that looks like missing data at least on
the ones it shows you can see a skipped
a bunch in the middle because that's
what it does if you have too many lines
in jupit or notebook it'll skip a few
and and go on to the next in a data set
let me go and remove this and we'll just
zero out that and of course before we do
any processing before proceeding any
further we need to split the data set
into our train and testing data that way
we have something to train it with and
something to test it on and you're going
to notice we did a little something here
with the Panda's database code
there we go my drawing tool we've added
in this right here off the data set and
what this says is that the first one in
pandas this is from the PD pandas it's
going to say within the data set we want
to look at the iocation and it is all
rows that's what that says so we're
going to keep all the rows but we're
only looking at zero column 0 to 8
remember column 9 here it is right up
here we printed in here is outcome well
that's not part of the training data
that's part of the answer yes column 9
but it's listed as eight number eight so
0 to eight is nine columns so uh eight
is the value and when you see it in here
zero this is actually 0 to seven it
doesn't include the last one and then we
go down here to Y which is our answer
and we want just the last one just
column 8 and you can do it this way with
this particular notation and then if you
remember we imported the train test
split that's part of the SK learn right
there and we simply put in our X and our
y we're going to do random State equals
zero you don't have to necessarily seed
it that's a seed number I think the
default is one when you seed it I'd have
to look that up and then the test size
test size is 0.2 that simply means we're
going to take 20% of the data and put it
aside so that we can test it later
that's all that is and again we're going
to run it not very exciting so far we
haven't had any print out other than to
look at the data but that is a lot of
this is prepping this data once you prep
it the actual lines of code are quick
and easy and we're almost there but the
actual writing of our KNN we need to go
ahead and to scale the data if you
remember correctly we're fitting the
data in a standard scaler which means
instead of the data being from you know
five to 303 in one column and the next
column is 1 to six we're going to set
that all so that all the data is between
minus1 and one that's what that standard
scaler does keeps it standardized and we
only want to fit the scaler with the
training set but we want to make sure
the testing set is the X test going in
is also transformed so it's processing
it the same so here we go with our
standard scaler we're going to call it
scor X for the scaler and we're going to
import the standard scaler into this
variable and then our X train equals
score x. fit transform so we're creating
the scalar on the XT train variable and
then our X test we're also going to
transform it so we've trained and
transformed the XT train and then the X
test isn't part of that training it
isn't part of that of training the
Transformer it just gets transform
that's all it does and again we're going
to go and run this and if you look at
this we've now gone through these steps
all three of them we've taken care of
replacing our zeros for key columns that
shouldn't be zero and we replaced that
with the means of those columns that way
that they fit right in with our data
models we've come down here and we split
the data so now we have our test data
and our training data and then we've
taken and we' scaled the data so all of
our data going in now no we don't tra we
don't train the Y part the Y train and Y
test that never has to be trained it's
only the data going in that's what we
want to train in there then Define the
model using K neighbors classifier and
fit the train data in the model so we do
all that data prep and you can see down
here we're only going to have a couple
lines of code where we're actually
building our model and training it
that's one of the cool things about
Python and how far we've come it's such
an exciting time to be in machine
learning cuz there so many automated
tools let's see before we do this let's
do a quick length of and let's do y we
want let's just do length of Y and we
get 768 and if we import math we do
math. square root let's do y train there
we go it's actually supposed to be X
train before we do this let's go ahead
and do import math and do math square
root length of Y test and when I run
that we get at
12.49 I want to see show you where this
number comes from we're about to use 12
is an even number so if you know if
you're ever voting on things remember
the neighbors all vote don't want to
have an even number of neighbors voting
so we want to do something odd and let's
just take one away we'll make it 11 let
me delete this out of here that's one of
the reasons I love Jupiter notebook CU
you can flip around and do all kinds of
things on the fly so we'll go ahead and
put in our classifier we're creating our
classifier now and it's going to be the
K neighbors classifier n neighbors equal
11 remember we did 12 - 1 for 11 so we
have an odd number of neighbors P equals
2 because we're looking for is it are
they diabetic or not and we're using the
ukian metric there are other means of
measuring the distance you could do like
square square means value there's all
kinds of meure this but the ukian is the
most common one and it works quite well
it's important to evaluate the model
let's use the confusion Matrix to do
that and we're going to use the
confusion Matrix wonderful tool and then
we'll jump into the F1 score and finally
accuracy score which is probably the
most commonly used quoted number when
you go into a meeting or something like
that so let's go ahead and paste that in
there and we'll set the cm equal to
confusion Matrix y test y predict so
those are the two values we're going to
put in there and let me go ahe and run
that and print it out and the way you
interpret this is you have the Y
predicted which would be your title up
here we could do uh let's just do p r
DCT PR dicted across the top and actual
going down actual it's always hard to to
write in here actual that means that
this column here down the middle that's
the important column and it means that
our prediction said 94 and prediction
and the actual agreed on 94 and 32 this
number here the 13 and the 15 those are
what was wrong so you could have like
three different if you're looking at
this across three different variables
instead of just two you'd end up with
the third row down here and the column
going down the middle so in the first
case we have the the and I believe the
zero is the 94 people who don't have
diabetes the prediction said that 13 of
those people did have diabetes and were
at high risk and the 32 that had
diabetes it had correct but our
prediction said another 15 out of that
15 it classified as incorrect so you can
see where that classification comes in
and how that works on the confus usion
Matrix then we're going to go ahead and
print the F1 score let me just run that
and you see we get a 69 in our F1 score
the F1 takes into account both sides of
the balance of false positives where if
we go ahead and just do the accuracy
account and that's what most people
think of is it looks at just how many we
got right out of how many we got wrong
so a lot of people when you're a data
scientist and you're talking to other
data scientists they're going to ask you
what the F1 score the F score is if
you're talking to the general public or
the decision makers in the business
they're going to ask what the accuracy
is and the accuracy is always better
than the F1 score but the F1 score is
more telling it lets us know that
there's more false positives than we
would like on here but 82% not too bad
for a quick flash look at people's
different statistics and running an
sklearn and running the knnn the K
nearest neighbor on it so we have
created a model using KNN which can
predict whether a person will have
diabetes or not or at the very least
whether they should go get a checkup and
have their glucose checked regularly or
not the print accurac score we got the 0
818 was pretty close to what we got and
we can pretty much round that off and
just say we have an accuracy of 80%
tells us that is a pretty fair fit in
the model so what is the AAR algorithm
before we talk about the AAR algorithm
let's talk a bit about search algorithms
in computer science a search algorithm
is an algorithm which typically solves a
search problem they used to retrieve
information which is stored within some
data structure like arrays Stacks trees
hash buckets Etc or
calculate the search space of a problem
domain either with discrete or
continuous
variables so consider you have a stack s
which contains four
elements now a stack is an ordered
collection of items in which you can add
a new item and remove an existing item
at the same time in Stacks you can put
in an item on top of another item and
you can't access the elements below the
top element without removing the top
element first so suppose we want to find
the index of uh say an element in this
stack say 64 so we're going to run it
through a search algorithm to find 64
within our data
structure what the search algorithm is
going to do is that it's going to take a
look at the top element and see that
it's not 64 it's going to remove the top
element and move on to the next element
again it's going to compare and see if
it's 64 if it's not this element two
will get removed and then it will move
on to the next element in the stack
which is
64 in this case it's going to return the
index of this
element which is at stack index 2 and
using stack index 2 we can access this
element so in a way we found the element
in the
stack this is how search algorithms work
this is just an instance or a criteria
on which we were searching but using
search algorithms you can have multiple
different search conditions so you can
search for every every element which is
below a certain number say 40 within
this stack or you can also search for
elements which are at a certain index so
this is how powerful search algorithms
are some examples of search algorithms
include binary search linear search jump
search interpolation search Etc now a
vital aspect of search algorithms is
path finding which is used to find paths
that can be taken to Traverse from one
point to another by finding the most
optimum route the AAR algorithm is one
algorithm like this it is a searching
algorithm that is used to find the
shortest path between an initial and a
final
point so assume that you have a grid or
a maze in this case your person is is at
the
start and they have to reach the end of
the maze which is here at this point
denoted by this
flag now using AAR
algorithm we can perform map traversal
and find the shortest path which has to
be taken within a map to go from the
starting position to the end
position now in this case there are many
different paths that can be taken one
option is to go along the top edges of
the map the other one is to go along the
bottom
edges and the shortest path as you can
see which takes only four grids is to go
directly through the center of the map
cut across this diagonal and reach the
end now one major aspect of a star
algorithm is that it always takes the
shorter Parts first which makes it an
optimal and complete
algorithm an optimal algorithm will find
the least cost outcome for a problem
while a complete complete algorithm
finds all the possible outcomes of a
problem AAR algorithm combines all of
these to find all the possible outcomes
of a problem starting with the least
cost
solution now this is what makes AAR
algorithms so
handy AAR was initially designed as a
graph traversal problem to help build a
robot that can find its own course and
because of this it Still Remains a
widely popular algorithm for graph
traversal now let's take a look at the
basic concept behind the AAR
algorithm so we already know that AAR
algorithm is an optimal and complete
algorithm but another aspect that makes
it so powerful is the use of weighted
graphs in its
implementation a weighted graph is
nothing but a graph which uses num to
represent the cost of taking each path
or course of action this means that the
algorithms can take the path with the
least cost and find the best rout in
terms of distance and time in path
finding
algorithms for algorithm such as a star
you're obviously going to need a graph
or a map or a path to travel right
so for computers we feed in something
called a graph a graph F contains of two
major
components first it contains something
called a
node so this is a
node and it contains something called a
path a path is nothing but a line which
connects two
nodes using this we know the direction
or the path that we have to take when we
we're traversing through a graph right
so um first let's just make a very
simple graph okay uh right now we have
two nodes A and B I'm just going to add
two more
C and
D now this connection with four nodes a
b c and d and their paths is called a
graph this whole thing basically this
whole thing is your graph these are the
graphs that these algorithms we'll have
to travel through and find the shortest
distance on so now how do we know where
we need to go in our
graph for this we have something called
a start node and an end node so let's
say our a is nothing but a start
node and our C over
here this
node is our end
node right so now we know that we have
to go from this node a all the way to
this node C in this case it becomes very
easy I can either go from A to B to C or
from a to d to C but how do I know which
path is the most Optimum path or the
path which has the least cost this is
made very easy by the use of weighted
graphs this is a basic graph but in
weighted graphs all these paths between
nodes have a certain weight to them or a
certain number assigned to
them like say let's just say this is two
the cost of this path is three this path
has a cost of five and this path has a
cost of one so now as you can see we've
assigned numbers to the parts between
different nodes these numbers tell us
the cost of traversing through that path
so when I take this path between a to B
I have I get a cost of two incured on me
and when I go from B to C I have a cost
of three similarly when I go from a to d
if I take this path I'll have a cost of
five and D to C will have a cost of 1 so
this helps us in finding out which paths
we should be taking when we're
traversing from one node to the other
now now in this case let's look at the
different possible paths we can take to
reach C the first option is that we go
from A to B and this will give us a cost
of 2 and then from
B we go to
C which will give us a cost of
three now the total cost of taking these
paths can easily be obtained by finding
the summation of the individual cost of
these paths so this will give us five
all we have to do is add up the weights
that each path has when we're traveling
it and we get to know what is going to
be the cost of a path taken so a path a
B to C has a cost of five similarly our
path a to D and D to C has a cost of 5 +
1 because a to d is 5 and D to C is 1
which is
six so between five and six we know that
five is
lesser which means that this path A to B
to
C is going to be our least cost path and
that is the path that we should be
taking so AAR algorithm makes use of
something called weighted graphs right
so AAR algorithm makes use of these
graphs in these ways now let's consider
that that I have some other node here
let's say that I have a
node e okay now B is connected to e and
e is also connected to C let's say that
the cost of taking this path B to e is 1
and E to C is zero so now let's
calculate the cost of taking the path a
b e and C okay so a A to B to e to C is
nothing but 2 + 1 + 0 which is equal to
3 when compared to A to B to C which is
nothing but 2 + 3 which is 5 and a to d
to C which is nothing but 5 + 1 which is
6 this path is obviously going to be the
shorter path right but let's consider
our programmer or let's say we ourselves
don't actually want to take this path
because coding for it is hard or because
it's very much isolated from the map so
we prefer to go transverse along some
other
nodes and this is not a preferred node
but looking at the graph no matter what
we do depending on how the weights are
distributed we are still going to have
to go via this node now now to overcome
this programmers make use of something
called heuristic values what are
heuristic values so far using a weighted
graph we've given importance to our
parts we found out which parts are the
easiest to take and which parts are the
ones which give us a higher cost of
implementation Now using heuristic
values we're going to do the same to our
nodes theistic value of a node in a
graph attempts to capture the importance
of that nodes value within that graph so
the heuristic value is nothing but an
arbitrary value which is assigned to
these nodes based on the programmer's
whims and needs just like how we have
the weightage of Parts theistic value
gives us the weight of a node and tells
us how expensive it is to Traverse
through that node it is represented by
HFN
so now let's assign heuristic values to
our graph and understand how exactly it
changes how we Traverse this graph right
so let's say our initial start node a
has a heuristic value of one and our
node B has a heuristic value of say
three a node e which is out of the way
and which we don't really want to
Traverse much on uh we can assign a very
high humanistic value to it to ensure
that it's not a path which is is
regularly taken so we can assign a
ristic value of 10 to e let's assign
other arbitary values to the other nodes
let's give d a heuristic value of one
and C A heuristic value of
zero so now as you can see even though
the parts over here take on a very short
value it would become a lot more
expensive to Travers through e just
because of its single high heuristic
value as compared to the other nodes
how does having a heuristic value in our
graph change how we are traversing so
after implementing the heuristic value
to a graph we now have two major values
which come into the play theistic value
which is nothing but the value of the
node and the path
weight we can represent this as G of n
which is nothing but the weight weights
in our weighted graph right so as you
can see when we're traversing from one
node a to a node B we're going to have
to consider both of these values so the
cost function of a graph or the total
cost of taking a
path becomes the value of the path
weight which is given by the weighted
graph along with theistic value which is
assigned by the programmer or by you
yourself and this here is the basic
function behind our AAR algorithm this
is the formula that our AAR algorithm
works
on so initially the AAR algorithm will
calculate the cost to all of its
immediate neighboring nodes and choose
the one which is incurring the least
cost this whole process will repeat
until no new nodes can be chosen and all
all the paths have been
traversed and then you should consider
the best path among them and how do you
find the cost function again you're just
going to add up the heuristic value and
the path value that you've
taken now G of n which is the path value
is nothing but the cost of traversing
from one node to another very obviously
this will vary from node to node whereas
HFM a heuristic approximation of a nod's
value is not a real value but an
approximation cost that you or some
other person has assigned to various
nodes now that we know the basic concept
behind the AAR algorithm let's take a
look at how exactly the Asar algorithm
works with the help of a case
study so now let's take a look at how
the AAR algorithm Works to do this we're
first going to consider a weighted graph
since ASR algorithm uses weighted graphs
to make its calculations
easier so consider this to be our
weighted graph we have a node
a a node
b a node
c a node
d and a node
e
okay
now node a is connected to node B node B
is connected to node
e node e is connected to node d d is
connected to C and C in turn is
connected to a c is also connected to b
and a is also connected to e so now
let's assign the path values to all the
different paths in our weighted graph
let's say A to B has a path value of one
B2 e has a path value of six D2 e has a
path value of uh five C2 to D has a path
value of 9 a to c has a path value of 10
and a to e has a path value of two and
this has a path value of three now let's
assign heuristic values let's give a the
heuristic value of two uh B theistic
value of um five let's just give this a
seven let's make
this
four and let's give C A humanistic value
of zero okay so now this is what a
weighted graph looks like um and uh from
the basic uh working you already know
that the cost function of your weighted
graph is nothing but the part path
value along with the heuristic value so
let's now
say that a here is where we have to
start
from and e and e is
our Target node okay and this is where
we are going to
be starting
from now a is are starting Noe so there
are three different parts that we can
take a to b a to c or a to e so first
let's consider that we take a to B okay
the first thing that you have to
consider is theistic value of a itself
so F of a is the first value that you're
going to be
considering right now F of a here is
going to be the uh path Value Plus
heuristic value now because a is the
starting node and there's no other node
leading up to it it is the parent node
itself so the path value here is going
to be zero because there's no path
leading up to it it's the starting node
and the starting node always has a path
value of zero next we're going to add
theistic value of a in this case 2 so 0
+ 2 so F of a is 2
right so this is the first node that
you've considered okay now after taking
node a we have three different options a
to c a to e or a to
B
so the cost function of taking the path
A to B is going to be so now let's find
the cost of taking the path A to B
right A to B so you have to add the
graph node Value Plus theistic value the
weight of taking the node A to B is
nothing but
and the heuristic value of B is five so
this is going to give us C next
a to c sorry starting next let's look at
the cost of taking the path a to e right
F of of a to e so this is going to be
two because the cost of taking this path
is two along with the heuristic value of
e which is 7 so this is going to be 99
and let's look at F of a to
c now the cost of taking this is going
to be 10 plus the value of C which is
0er so this is going to be 10
now the way how AAR algorithm works is
it will calculate the cost function of
all the neighboring nodes and go with
the node which has the least cost
function in this case the node being B
so we're not going to take this path or
this path because the cost function
value is way more than the cost function
value of f of a to
B so after a we are going to be at node
B so right now this is the direction
that we've traveled in now when we write
node B to reach node e we have two
different options such we have two
options that we can take we can either
go from B to e or we can go from B to C
okay uh the goal of AAR algorithm is to
always
minimize the cost of the path that
you're taking so using this in mind
let's
calculate F of B to
C which is going to be nothing but the
cost of the path from B to C which is
three plus the heuristic value of C
which is zero so this is going to be
three next let's calculate the cost of B
to e now this is going to be again
nothing but the path value in this case
6 Plus heuristic value in this case of e
which is
7 which is nothing but
13 so again as you can see this is the
correct path to be
taken and we are not going to be taking
this part because its value is way too
high so the next path that we're going
to be taking is this path B to C so now
we're at node C from node C we can
either go to a which is not possible
because we do not go back in the
direction that we came from to B again
that's not what we're going to be doing
or to D so the only option that we have
available is to go from C to d right so
what we're going to do is we're going to
find the cost of going from C to D again
this is going to be the value of the
path which is 99 plus the heuristic
value of D which is 4 the cost of
traversing this path is 13 but we don't
have any other path available to us
because this path has already been
closed you can't backtrack in AAR
algorithm or go back to the path where
you came from and again we've already
considered a to c before right like over
here we've already considered a to c and
we've already ruled it out so again this
is not a path that you can take so what
we're going to be doing right now is
that we're going to be traversing from C
to D and the cost of taking this path is
13 so
now this is the path that we're taken
from C to D we're at D now at D again we
can't go back to this path we can't go
back to C the only way we can go is e so
so we're going to consider F of D to e
and this is going to be again the path
that you're going to take from D to e
which is
five plus the heuristic value of e which
is 7 this whole thing is going to be
12 now once we're at C our AAR algorithm
is going to check if this is the target
node and lo and behold it is is so we've
traversed from a to e let's see the path
we've taken first the starting note that
we started off from was a from there we
looked at the cost of taking a to c a to
E and A to B and finally we settled for
going from A to B from B again we
consider the paths B to e and B to C we
cannot consider a to B because this path
has already beened traveled on and it's
already been considered
before now after considering B2 e and B
to C we found that B to C was the
shortest path from C we didn't have any
other option we couldn't back drag or go
back to B and we couldn't go to a
because this path was already been
considered and already it has been ruled
out so the only path we could take from
here was to D and again from D the only
path that we could take was to e so now
let's look at the path that we've taken
while using our Asar algorithm we
started off at the node a this was our
starting node from node a we had three
options we could go to node B to node e
or to node C after considering all of
these options we realized that A to B
was the path of least cost that we could
take one at B we considered two paths B
to e and B to C and we found out that B
to C was the path of least cost from C
there was no other path we could take we
cannot go back to the node we came from
which is B Because AAR algorithm does
not support backtracking and we couldn't
go back to a either because this path
had already been considered and we'
already ruled this path out right so the
only path we could take was
to
D now once we arrived at node D the only
node that we could travel to again was
e so using AAR algorithm this is the
final path that we've taken to Traverse
from a start node a to a Target node
e and with the help of this case study
we've also explained to you exactly how
the a star algorithm works we we use the
path values and theistic values to find
the cost of taking different paths
available to us at each
node and then we take the path which has
the least cost among all available paths
the same process will continue until
we've reached the final Target node and
again remember you cannot go back on the
path that you came from or you cannot go
on a path which is already been
considered so now you know how the AAR
algorithm works but what is the
flowchart of the AAR
algorithm now a flow chart is a picture
of the separate steps of a process in a
sequential order it's basically a
generic tool that can be adapted for a
wide variety of purposes and you can use
it to describe various processes in this
case this is the basic flowchart of the
AAR algorithm it tells the direction of
control flow within the AAR program and
using this you can Implement AAR
algorithm in any desired language of
your choice so the first step of our AAR
algorithm is to initialize a start node
and put it in an open list now in this
algorithm we're going to first create
two lists an open list and a closed list
the open list will contain all the nodes
that have been visited but the neighbors
have yet not been explode on the other
hand the Clos list contains nodes that
along with their neighbors have already
been
visited so the first node or our
starting node is going to be put in an
open list because we're still exploring
it then we're going to calculate the
cost function of the starting
node from here onwards we're going to
remove this node from the open list and
put it in the Clos list since we've
already visited it and calculated its
cost function if you're also looking at
the Neighbors which are surrounding this
node or if this node has many different
nodes around it then we're going to
calculate the cost function for those
nodes too and save the index of the node
which has the smallest cost function
f next we're going to look at if the
node we're currently
on is a final node or a Target node if
that's the case we're going to terminate
the algorithm and use pointers of all of
our nodes to get the desired
path if that's not the case then we're
going to look at the successive nodes of
n or all the nodes which come after this
node which are not in the Clos
list we're going to calculate the cost
function of each of these neighboring
nodes remove them from the open list as
they're not already in the Clos list so
they're obviously going to be in the
open list so we're going to remove them
from the open list and then we're going
to put them in the Clos list and again
we're going to save the index of the
neighboring node with the smallest cost
function and then this process is going
to keep repeating over and over until
we've reached the target node which is
where our program will get terminated so
basically what we're doing is we're
going to a certain node calculating the
cost function for that node
looking at all the successive
neighboring nodes of it and going to the
neighbor which has the least cost
function now this process will again get
repeated so from this neighboring node
we're going to find all the other nodes
which are connected to it and then we
are going to go to the node which has
the least cost function so using this
we're going to hop from one node to
another depending on which node has the
lowest cost function
once this is over we're going to again
take some other node and we're going to
repeat this process until we found all
the possible paths to a final
destination
node and in this way the AAR algorithm
is not only going to find the shortest
path but it's also going to find all
possible
paths now let's see how the AAR
algorithm can be implemented with the
help of
python in this demo we will use use the
ASR algorithm to find the least cost
path between various nodes in the
weighted graph which is shown below so
in this graph as you can see we have six
different nodes a b c d e and G the
weight of the paths between these nodes
is denoted by these numbers in black and
theistic values of the nodes itself are
denoted by the numbers in red Now using
these values we can find the shortest
distance between any two nodes let's see
how we can do this with the help of
python so now let's start by creating a
class for the AAR algorithm called the
AAR
algo now in this algorithm we're going
to have to describe the open and the
close list and to do this we're going to
be using two sets so our sets are our
open list and our closed
list we'll also be using two
dictionaries
one to store distance from the starting
node and another for parent
nodes and we're going to start by
initializing to them to zero the open
set is going to have the start node
already in it now we all know that the
distance of the starting node from
itself is zero itself so we're going to
initialize the distance of the start
node to zero and we also know that the
start node is the root node and it has
no parent nodes so the start node is its
own parent node the first step of
initializations is to put the start node
in the close set to set the distance of
the start node to itself as
zero and to set the start node as its
own parent node now that we're done with
the first couple of
initializations let's move
on to finding all the neighboring nodes
so so now we're going to have to find
the neighboring nodes with the lowest
value of the cost
function we also have to code for the
condition of reaching the destination
node if this is not the case we're going
to have to put the current nodes in the
open list and if they're not already in
it then we're going to set the parent
nodes so that's what we're going to do
first we're going to find the node with
the lowest cost function we're going to
take the the entire open set and while
the length of it is greater than zero or
basically well we're not at the parent
node we're going to Loop through
it we're going to go to all the
neighboring nodes of the open node and
then we're going to find their uh cost
function now here this is the function
that you're going to use to find the
cost
function now here what we're going to do
is is we're going to calculate theistic
value for n and if the cost function of
n is zero or if its cost function is
less than the cost function of its
neighboring node then we're going to go
we're going to move on to the next node
which is V now if n is equal to the stop
node or we've looped back and come to n
itself then we're not going to go ahead
or we're going to exit the this
Loop and we're going to move on to some
other
node otherwise if the neighbor has a
lower G value than the current node and
is in the closed list we're going to
replace this new node as the neighbor's
parent and that's what we're doing here
exactly now if the neighbor is not in
both the lists then we're going to add
it to the open list and set its G value
and that's basically what's going on
here so let's run this for the AAR
algorithm now we're going to define a
function to get the different neighbors
and their
distances next we're going to create a
function to store the heuristic values
and retrieve them as and when
required now we're going to describe our
graph here so these are all of our nodes
and the nodes that they're connected to
along with the weight of their parts so
here a is connected to B and the weight
of this path is 2 a is also connected to
e and the weight of this path is three
in the same way B is connected to C and
the path has a weight of one and G B is
also connected to G and the path has a
weight of
nine so here this is what we're going to
do to describe our entire uh weighted
graph and then we're going to finally
call our a star algorithm and give us
star starting node and a final
node
and it very quickly finds the path
between a starting node and a final node
and over here as we can see the best
part to take would be from a to e to D
and finally to G phase detection system
it is a form of biometric recognition a
method for identifying or confirming
someone's identity by glancing at their
face is called facial recognition people
can be identified by securing a mats on
facial ID using this technique realtime
visuals videos and photos can be the
sources to run phe detection this
technology is mostly employed in
security and law enforcement open CV is
the best technology to create it a
python package called open CV is made
specifically to address computer vision
jobs computer vision is a process used
in the process processing of images by
computers it is concerned with the
in-depth comprehension of digital photos
or films it is necessary to automate
operations that can be performed by
human visual systems therefore a
computer should be able to identify
items like a statue or a lamp poost or
even the face of a human being second
one is chatbot it is the best idea if
you have chosen chatbot as your project
topic this will make your resume more
attractive in case you're looking for a
job an oracle survey suggests that 80%
of the businesses uses chatbot you can
use Python Java Ruby C++ or PHP as a
programming language to develop a
chatbot designing and building NLP
chatbots that accept speech and Text
data is made easier by dialog flow you
can go through many projects to get the
rough idea there are many platforms
which will help you to build a chatbot
regardless of how excellent your chatbot
is there is always room for development
the finest chatboard developers
constantly enhance their bards over the
time using Ai and machine learning
social media recommendation system the
rise of web services like Netflix Amazon
and YouTube has increase the use of
recommended systems in our daily lives
they are algorithms that insist use in
finding information that is pertinent to
them recommender systems are important
in some firms since they can generate a
lot of income or allow you to set
yourself apart from rivals in order to
provide recommendations it evaluates the
relationship between the user and the
object as well as the parallels between
users and positions coming to predicting
stock this application is widely
applicable everywhere as AI career
aspirant one will love to develop stock
prediction applications as it is full of
data this project would be ideal for
students who want to work in the finance
industry because it it can provide I
repeat because it can provide them a
better understanding of various aspects
of the field coming to medical diagnosis
this project is advantageous from a
medical standpoint AI projects can be
created to detect heart-based diseases
and also detect cancer it is intended to
offer patients with heart illness online
medical advice and guidance after
processing the data this system will
search the database for any illnesses
that might be connected to the given
details using data mining techniques
this intelligent system determines the
disease that the patient's information
most closely
resembles based on the system diagnosis
users can then speak with qualified
medical professionals users of the
system can can also view information
about various doctors coming to an
important project that is search engine
search engines are utilized by all we
look for information on the greatest
product to buy a nice area to hang out
or solutions to any questions we have
MLP is quite significant in modern
search engines because a lot of language
processing takes place there python is
the widely used language to develop any
search engine search engine is mainly
confined with lots and lots of data it
is helpful for any AI career expirence
next is virtual assistance here the
challenge is to build a virtual
assistant to assist user why do you need
virtual assistant in your devices when
you are building your own it is also
interesting for a ml developer to build
a virtual assistant it involves NLP and
data mining voice-based virtual
assistants are popular today because
because they make life easier for users
NLP is utilized to comprehend human
language in order to construct this
system when a voice command is received
the system will translate it into
machine language and store the commands
in its database hate speech detection in
social media automated hate speech
detection is a crucial weapon in the
fight against hate speech propagation
especially on social media for the job
many techniques have been developed
including a recent explosion of deep
learning based system for the objective
of detecting hate speech a number of
techniques have been investigated
including conventional classifiers
classifiers based on deep learning and
combination of both of them on the other
hand a number of data set benchmarks
including Twitter sentiment analysis
have been introduced and made available
for the evolution of the performance of
these algorithms and the last one is
predicting house price you will need to
estimate the sale price of a brand new
home in any place for this assignment
the data set for this project includes
information on the cost of homes in
various City neighborhoods the UCI
machine learning repository is the place
where you may find the data set needed
for This research you will also receive
other data set with information on the
age of the population the city's crime
rate and the Loc
of non- retail Enterprises in addition
to the pricing of various residences
it's an excellent project to test your
knowledge if you are an up popular
market research projects that the market
for artificial intelligence will grow
from $59.7 billion in 2021 to $22.4
billion in 2028 artificial intelligence
Automation and Robotics are disrupting
almost every business companies that
don't invest in AI Services risk
becoming obsolete whether in machine
learning smart applications Appliance
digital assistants or autonomous vles
numerous companies stand to benefit from
AI but a handful of them have proven to
be the game changers for 2023 and Beyond
so hey everyone you are already watching
simply learn and here we are with the
list of top 10 AI companies in 2023 if
you love watching videos like these do
hit the Subscribe button to never miss
an update from Simply learn so let's
explore and learn about them one by one
starting with the 10th position which is
uipath robotic process automation or RPA
is a technology developed by uip path
that helps businesses to boost
productivity and reduce cost by
automating timec consuming and
repetitive operations software robots
can be equipped with uip paath AI
Technologies to carry out duties
including reading documents and emails
interpreting language and visual cues
and comprehending the content and the
intent of the communications the RPA
Market is estimated to be wor worth 38
billion and uip paath offers distinct
advantages over the competitors thanks
to its patent computer vision technology
and wide range of B Technologies in the
ninth position we have dinet the
surfaces offered by dinet include
observe availability and infrastructure
monitoring the devis AI engine developed
by the business can analyze 368 trillion
dependencies each second Davis can
quickly locate problems in a company's
digital ecosystem explain what went
wrong and evaluate and rate likely
commercial ramifications the company
estimated a market worth
285.0 million and dis po to grow Revenue
by roughly 20% annually throughout at
least 2025 then at the eighth position
we have palente Technologies data
analytics software startup palente
Technologies uses AI to analyze data
according to revenue and market share
palente was ranked as the top AI
software platform globally by IDC in
September 2022 the United States
intelligence and and defense Industries
account for a sizable portion of
valente's Revenue the business just won
a new 85.1 million contract from the US
Army Marshall command to assist with the
developing Ai and machine learning
Technologies to enhance equipment
reliability improve predictive
maintenance and improve Supply chains
palente May deliver revenues closer to
the higher end of analysis estimates
roughly 2.5 billion in 20123 then at the
seventh position is workday workday is a
provider of cloud-based applications
with an a es on human resources
management with the assistance of
workday's distinctive AI based
optimization engine businesses can
manage challenges with hiring and
stuffing fluctuation labor demand shift
scheduling and prioritizing and More in
April 2022 work day Incorporated Barista
and AI powered virtual assistant from
expressive into their platform workday
is Raising 2023 markets Worth to almost
5.53 billion representing year-over-year
growth of 22% now in the sixth position
we have intuitive surgical The DaVinci
surgical system offered by intuitive
surgical performs minimally invasive
procedures using Cutting Edge robots and
computerized visualization technology
with the help of a big data and AI
intuitive is developing tools that will
help surgeons by improving their
training and offering them real-time
Direction despite the fact that the D in
surgical system has been approved by
usfda for 22 years intuitive reported a
133% year-over-year increase installed
in the system most recent quarter the
global intuitive surgical Market is
projected to reach $6.5 billion by 2023
moving towards the fifth position we
have IBM for years IBM has been
developing strategies to use its AI
supercomputer to alter the legal banking
academic and Healthcare Industries IBM's
clients harness the power of AI to stay
current on Ever Changing regulations by
providing endtoend risk and compliance
management IBM continues to dominate the
market for the other breakthroughs in Ai
and its Auto Ai and auto AML products
can help data scientist build and
improve Ai and machine learning models
the market worth of IBM in 2023 will
range from 14.4 billion to 16 billion
following that in the fourth position is
NVIDIA high-end chipmaker Nvidia
provides the significant computing power
needed for advanced AI applications in
reality one of the world's fastest
supercomputers Leonardo is powered by
Nvidia Graphics processing units the
parent company of Facebook meta
platforms is building the biggest
artificial intelligence supercomputer in
the world meta also owns nvidia's
Quantum INF band networking system and
608a 100 nvda Graphics processing
processes Nvidia is a significant
supplier for fast growing Industries
like high-end gaming business Graphics
cloud computing artificial intelligence
and advanced automative technology
nvidia's outlook for 2023 revenue is
expected to be around 6 billion here
comes the top three in the list and in
the third position we have Amazon AI is
integrated into every aspect of Amazon's
business including e-commerce search
engines targeted advertising and Amazon
web services Amazon Alexa one of the
most popular virtual assistant is
already present in many American Homes
Amazon said in August that it would pay
1.7 billion to acquire robot scorp RBT a
maker of Home robots this action can
allow Amazon to boost the use of AI in
household worldwide Amazon expects a 491
billion Market worth between 2023 and
2027 in the second position is alphabet
alphabet the company that owns Google
and YouTube uses Ai and Automation in
practically every part of its business
including ad pricing Gmail spam filters
and content promotion in addition it is
the parent company of the autonomous car
manufacturer voo and the AI software
business Deep Mind which created history
in 2022 when it became the first
completely autonomous commercial Taxi
service to operate on public routes the
market worth of alphabet in 2023 will be
around $70 billion and the first
position on the list is Microsoft in
2020 Microsoft announced the
construction of a new supercomputer
hosted on Azure Microsoft's cloud
computing Network the superc computer
was created in collaboration with open
AI to train AI models producing
substantial AI models and related
infrastructure for programmers and other
businesses in October Microsoft released
m Micosoft designer a graphic design
tool that makes original social media
post invitations and other graphic using
AI technology Microsoft the tech giant
is expected to earn a market worth of
49.73 billion and with that we have come
to the end of this list of the top 10
artificial intelligence companies of
2023 opportunities in AI have increased
significantly in recent years the surge
in jobs related to AI is legitimate due
to its widespread involvement in crucial
fields
according to indeed the pay range for
jobs involving artificial intelligence
is between
$160,000 to
$350,000 and can go even higher so we
have come up with the list of leading
career opportunities in artificial
intelligence along with companies hiring
for those roles but before we begin here
is a question for you who do you think
is currently leading the AI Market let
us know in the comment section below so
without any further delay let's get
started starting with our list we have
robotics engineer an engineer in
robotics create prototypes constructs
and test machines and updates the
software that manages them additionally
they investigate the most affordable and
secure way to make their robotics system
aspirant should have a bachelor degree
in computer science and pursue a career
in robotics with additional training or
certification in automation is
advantageous robotics engineers are in
high demand with 9,000 plus job openings
in India and 8,000 plus openings in the
US top companies like Amazon Bosch and
fly base are hiring robotics engineers
with salaries as high as
$160,000 in the US and rupes 27 lakhs in
India next up on our list we have
product manager the role of a product
manager is to recognize and express user
requirements market research and
creating competitive evaluations and
also creating a product's vision and
putting emphasis on a product strengths
and qualities freshers cannot join as a
product manager it requires basic
experience of 2 to three years in the
field of product and software
development according to indie.com an
average of 2,000 plus jobs are currently
available in India and 20,000 plus job
vacancies are there in the US with top
companies hiring are Tesla Amazon TCS
sprinkler cognizant Etc with a salary as
high as 160,000 per year in the US and
rupees 20 lakhs perom in India up next
we have data scientist they mainly deal
with lots of data extraction of
Knowledge from all collected data is the
subject matter of a data science it was
also voted the sexiest job of the 21st
century good news is there is no need
for any special degree as a data
scientist you need to have knowledge of
machine learning programming in Python
are Java and mathematical modeling being
a fresher you can join as a data
scientist too data scientist are in
demand with 177,000 plus vacancies in
the US and 3,000 plus vacancies in India
and big businesses like accenter TCS IBM
Google JP Morgan Deo Bank of America
recruiting data employees with salary
going as high as $200,000 per year in
the US and rupees 15 lakhs perom in
India moving forward in our list we have
ai data analyst data mining data
cleaning data interpretation are the
three main task of an AI data analyst
data cleaning allows for the Gathering
of the necessary information for data
analysis an AI data analyst make
inferences from the data using
statistical tools and techniques you
need a bachelor degree in computer
science or mathematics to work as an AI
data analyst to get this job you must
have a thorough understanding of
regression and able to use msxl
according to indie.com there are
currently 700 plus AI data analyst jobs
available in the United States and
16,000 plus job vacancies in India with
top companies like Accenture IBM Vio TCS
and capam mini recruiting them and
salaries going as high as
$100,000 per year in the US and rupees
8.5 lakhs perom in India the next job
opportunity in AI is business
intelligence in engineer a business
intelligence developer's main duty is to
take both business sense and AI into
account they evaluate complex data sets
to identify various business Trends they
assist in boosting a company's earnings
by planning creating and sustaining
business intelligence solutions to
become a business intelligence engineer
you are required to have a bachelor
degree in mathematics and computer
science according to ind.com there are
8,000 plus job available in India and
5,000 plus job vac gencies in United
States companies hiring are Amazon
Development Center IBM AWS Etc with this
salary going as high as $100,000 per
year in the USA and rupees 15 lakhs per
year in India coming to the top three
jobs available in AI at number three we
have machine learning engineer
artificial intelligence is known to
include machine learning it runs
simulations using the varied data
provided and produces precise result
results they are constantly in demand
from the businesses and their position
seldom goes unfilled they handle
enormous amount of data and have
exceptional data management skills the
ability to code use computers and
understand mathematics are requirement
for success as a machine learning
engineer a master's degree in computer
science or mathematics is highly
preferred the necessary technological
Stacks include python are Scala and Java
a deep understanding of neural networks
deep learning and machine learning
algorithm is very helpful coming to job
opportunities glo.com predicts 13,000
plus job vacancies in the US and 27,000
plus jobs available in India with
companies like mathor Google Amazon
Microsoft azour IBM Etc hiring them with
salary going as high as 150,000 perom in
the US and rupees 10 lakhs perom in
India coming at runnerup position we we
have data architect data Architects are
it Specialists who utilize their
knowledge of computer science and
database architecture to assess and
analyze an organization's data
infrastructure fresher graduates cannot
become data Architects a bachelor degree
in computer science and computer
engineering or related subject is the
absolute minimum requirement to become a
data architect data Architects are in
high demand with 52,000 job vacancies in
the United United States and 7,000 plus
jobs in India and top companies hiring
data Architects are Amazon IBM Tesla
Intel Vio with the average salary quite
high as
$200,000 per year in the United States
and rupes 21 lakhs perom in India and
Topping our list of job opportunities in
AI is AI engineer AI Engineers are
problem solvers who create test and use
various artificial intelligence models
they manage the AI infrastructure well
to create practical AI models they use
neural network knowledge and machine
learning methods these models enable one
to gain business insights which AIDS the
organization in making wise business
decisions ug or PG degree in the field
of AI or computer science is required in
addition to that you can hold
certifications from any reputed
organization which will add up to your
resume please check out and enroll to
the AI program by simply learn in
collaboration with puru University the
link is provided in the description
below job openings for an AI engineer
are quite high with 35,000 plus job
vacancies in the US and 4,000 plus jobs
in India and Tech giants like Accenture
TCS IBM Google JP Morgan Delo Bank of
America recruiting them with salary
going as high as
$200,000 per year in the US and rupes 10
lakhs perom in India so with this we
have come to the end of this Advanced
artificial intelligence course and if
you have any doubts or any questions
please feel free to comment till then
stay safe keep learning and get ahead
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upscaling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certific ation
programs in cuttingedge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know
more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here